hey everyone welcome to this docker fill
course video by simply learn
in this full course we will learn
everything about docker in detail we
will begin this full course video with
what docker is then we will look into
the services and components of docker in
detail next we will see what docker
container is and what are the basic
commands of a docker container then we
will focus on docker swarm and docker
compose after that we will discuss
everything about docker networking then
we will see how to install docker on
ubuntu and windows 10. next we will talk
about 12 crucial docker interview
questions and answers for beginners and
experienced candidates finally we will
conclude this video by discussing the
differences between the two famous tools
which are docker and kubernetes
by the end of this video i can assure
you that all your docker query related
queries will have been answered
for this training with me i have our
experienced docker expert massive and
accol
together we will take you through the
various topics of docker so let's start
with an exciting video on the
configuration management tool before we
begin make sure to subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit that bell icon
to never miss an update from simply
learn hello this is matthew from simply
learn and today we're going to cover
what is docker and why it should be of
value to you as somebody who works in
devops
so let's take a little scenario of a
developer and a tester before you had
the world of docker a developer would
actually build their code and then they
send it to the tester but then the code
wouldn't work on their system the code
doesn't work on the other system due to
the differences in computer environments
so what could be the solution to this
well you could go ahead and create a
virtual machine to be the same of the
solution in both areas we think docker
is an even better solution so let's kind
of break out what the main big
differences are between docker and
virtual machines as you can see between
the left and the right hand side both
look to be very similar what you'll see
however is that on the docker side what
you'll see as a big difference is that
the guest os for each container has been
eliminated docker is inherently more
lightweight but provides the same
functionality as a virtual machine so
let's step through some of the pros and
cons of a virtual machine versus docker
so first of all a virtual machine
occupies a lot more memory space on the
host machine in contrast docker occupies
significantly less memory space the boot
up time between both is very different
docker just boots up faster the
performance of the docker environment is
actually better and more consistent than
the virtual machine docker is also very
easy to set up and very easy to scale
the efficiencies therefore are much
higher with a docker environment versus
a virtual machine environment and you'll
find it is easier to port docker across
multiple platforms than a virtual
machine finally the space allocation
between docker and a virtual machine is
significant when you don't have to
include the guest os you're eliminating
a significant amount of space and the
docker environment is just inherently
smaller so after docker as a developer
you can build out your solution and send
it to a tester as long as we're all
running in the docker environment
everything will work just great so let's
step through what we're going to cover
in this presentation we're going to look
at the devops tools and where docker
fits within that space we'll examine
what docker actually is and how docker
works and then finally we'll step
through the different components of the
docker environment so what is devops
devops is a collaboration between the
development team the operation team
allowing you to continuously deliver
solutions and applications and services
that both delight and improve the
efficiency of your customers if you look
at the venn diagram that we have here on
the left hand side we have development
on the right hand side we have operation
and then there's a crossover in the
middle and that's where the devops team
sits if we look at the areas of
integration between both groups
developers are really interested in
planning code building and testing and
operations want to be able to
efficiently deploy operate a monitor
when you can have both groups
interacting with each other on these
seven key end elements then you can have
the efficiencies of an excellent devops
team so planning in codebase we use
tools like jit and geara for building we
use gradle and mavin testing we use
selenium the integration between dev and
ops is through tools such as jenkins and
then the deployment operation is done
with tools such as docker and chef
finally nagios is used to monitor the
entire environment so let's step deeper
into what docker actually is so docker
is a tool which is used to automate the
deployment of applications in a
lightweight container so the application
can work efficiently in different
environments now it's important to note
the container is actually a software
package that consists of all the
dependencies required to run the
application so multiple containers can
run on the same hardware the containers
are maintained in isolated environments
they're highly productive and they're
quick and easy to configure so let's
take an example of what docker is by
using a house that may be rented for
someone using airbnb so in the house
there are three rooms and only one
cupboard and kitchen and the problem we
have is that none of the guests are
really ready to share the cupboard and
kitchen because every individual has a
different preference when it comes to
how the cupboard should be stocked and
how the kitchen should be used this is
very similar to how we run software
applications today each of the
applications could end up using
different frameworks so you may have a
framework such as rails perfect and
flask and you may want to have them
running for different applications for
different situations this is where
docker will help you run the
applications with the suitable
frameworks so let's go back to our
airbnb example so we have three rooms
and a kitchen and cupboard how do we
resolve this issue well we put a kitchen
and cupboard in each room we can do the
same thing for computers docker provides
the suitable frameworks for each
different application and since every
application has a framework with a
suitable version this space could also
then be utilized for putting in software
and applications that along and since
every application has its own framework
and suitable version the area that we
had previously stored for a framework
can be used for something else now we
can create a new application in this
instance a fourth application that uses
its own resources you know what with
these kinds of abilities to be able to
free up space on the computer it's no
wonder docker is the right choice so
let's take a closer look to how docker
actually works so when we look at docker
and we call something docker we're
actually referring to the base engine
which actually is installed on the host
machine that has all the different
components that run your docker
environment
if we look at the image on the left hand
side of the screen you'll see that
docker has a client server relationship
there is a client installed on the
hardware there is a client that contains
the docker product and then there is a
server which controls how that docker
client is created the communication that
goes back and forth to be able to share
the knowledge on that docker client
relationship is done through a rest api
this is fantastic news because that
means that you can actually interface
and program that api so we look here in
the animation we see that the docker
client is constantly communicating back
to the server information about the
infrastructure and it's using this rest
api as that communication channel the
docker server then would check out the
requests and the interaction necessary
for it to be the docker daemon which
runs on the server itself will then
check out the interaction and the
necessary operating system pieces needed
to be able to run the container okay so
that's just an overview
of the docker engine which is probably
where you're going to spend most of your
time but there are some other components
that form the infrastructure for docker
let's dig into those a little bit deeper
as well so what we're going to do now is
break out the four main components that
comprise of the docker environment the
four components are as follows the
docker client and server which we've
already done a deeper dive on docker
images docker containers and the docker
registry so if we look at the structure
that we have here on the left hand side
you see the relationship between the
docker client and the docker server and
then we have the rest api in between now
if we start digging into that rest api
particularly the relationship with the
docker daemon on the server we actually
have our other elements that form the
different components of the docker
ecosystem so the docker client is
accessed from your terminal window so if
you are using windows this can be
powershell on mac it's going to be your
terminal window and it allows you to run
the docker daemon and the registry
service when you have your terminal
window open so you can actually use your
terminal window to create instructions
on how to build and run your docker
images and containers if we look at the
images part of our registry here we
actually see that the image is really
just a template with the instructions
used for creating the containers which
you use within docker the docker image
is built using a file called the docker
file and then once you've created that
docker file you'll store that image in
the docker hub or registry and that
allows other people to be able to access
the same structure of a docker
environment that you've created the
syntax of creating the image is fairly
simple it's something that you'll be
able to get your arms around very
quickly and essentially what you're
doing is you're creating the option of a
new container you're identifying what
the image will look like what are the
commands that are needed and the
arguments for within those commands and
once you've done that you have a
definition for what your image will look
like so if we look here at what the
container itself looks like is that the
container is a standalone executable
package which includes applications and
their dependencies it's the instructions
for what your environment will look like
so you can be consistent in how that
environment is shared between multiple
developers testing units and other
people within your devops team now the
thing that's great about working with
docker is that it's so lightweight that
you can actually run multiple docker
containers in the same infrastructure
and share the same operating system this
is its strength it allows you to be able
to create those multiple environments
that you need for multiple projects that
you're working on interestingly though
within each container that container
creates an isolated area for the
applications to run so while you can run
multiple containers in an infrastructure
each of those containers are completely
isolated they're protected so that you
can actually control how your solutions
work there now as a team you may start
off with one or two developers on your
team but when a project starts becoming
more important and you start adding in
more people to your team you may have 15
people that are offshore you may have 10
people that are local you may have 15
consultants that are working on your
project you have a need for each of
those developers or each person on your
team to have access to that docker image
and to get access to that image we use
the docker registry which is an open
source server-side service for hosting
and distributing the images that you
have defined you can also use docker
itself as its own default registry and
docker hub now something it has to be
very mind though is that for publicly
shared images you may want to have your
own private images in which case you
would do that through your own registry
so once again public repositories can be
used to host the docker images which can
be accessed by anyone and i really
encourage you to go out to docker and
see the other docket images that have
been created because there may be tools
there that you can use to speed up your
own development environments now you
will also get to a point where you start
creating environments that are very
specific to the solutions that you are
building and when you get to that point
you'll likely want to create a private
repository so you're not sharing that
knowledge with the world in general now
the way in which you connect with the
docker registry is through simple pull
and push commands that you run through
terminal window to be able to get the
latest information so if you want to be
able to build your own container what
you'll start doing is using the pull
commands to actually pull the image from
the docker repository and the command
line for that is fairly simple in
terminal window you would write docker
pull and then you put in the image name
and any tags associated with that image
and use the command pools so in your
terminal window you would actually use a
simple line of command once you've
actually connected to your docker
environment and that command will be
docker pull with the image name and any
associated tags around that image what
that will then do is pull the image from
the docker repository whether that's a
public repository or a private one now
in reverse if you want to be able to
update the docker image with a new
information you do a push command where
you take the script that you've written
about the docker container that you
define and push it to the repository and
as you can imagine the commands for that
are also fairly simple in terminal
window you would write docker push the
image name any associated tags and then
that would then push that image to the
docker repository again either a public
or a private repository so if we recap
the docker file creates a docker image
that's using the build commands a docker
image then contains all the information
necessary for you to be able to execute
the project using the docker image any
user can run the code in order to create
a docker container and once a docker
image is built it's uploaded to a
registry or to a docker hub where it can
be shared across your entire team and
from the docker hub users can get access
to the docker image and build their own
new containers hello and welcome to
simplyline in this session we're going
to cover what kubernetes is and why you
would want to be using it within your
devops team but before we get started
remember to hit the like button if you
like this video and the subscribe button
if you want to get notified about more
of these videos as they come out and as
always if you have any comments about
content that we're covering or questions
that you have on the subject please post
them in the comments below so let's get
started we're going to break up this
presentation into four key areas we're
going to talk about life before
kubernetes which some of you are
probably experiencing right now what is
kubernetes the benefits that kubernetes
brings to you particularly if you are
using containers in a devops environment
and then finally we're going to break
down the architecture and working
infrastructure for kubernetes so you
understand what's happening and why the
actions are happening the way that they
are so let's jump into our first section
of life before kubernetes so the way
that you have done work in the past
where you may be doing work right now is
really building out and deploying
solutions into two distinct areas one is
a traditional deployment where you're
pushing out code to physical servers in
a data center and you're managing the
operating system and the code that's
actually running on each of those
servers another environment that you may
potentially be using is deploying code
out to virtual machines so let's go
through and look at the two different
types of deployment that you may be
experiencing when you have applications
running on multiple machines you run
into the potential risk that the setup
and configuration of each of those
machines isn't going to be consistent
and your code isn't going to work
effectively and there may be issues with
uptime and errors within the
infrastructure of your entire
environment there's going to be problems
with resource allocation and you're
going to have air issues where
applications may be running effectively
and not look not effectively and not
load balance
effectively across the environment the
problem that you have with this kind of
infrastructure is that it gets very
expensive uh you can only install one
piece of software one service on one
piece of hardware so your hardware is
being massively underutilized this is
where virtual machines have become
really popular with a virtual machine
you're able to have better resource
utilization and scalability at much less
cost and this allows you to be able to
run multiple virtual machines on a
single piece of hardware the problem is
is that vms or for virtual machines are
not perfect either some of the
challenges you run with vms is that the
actual hardware and software need needed
to manage the vm environment can be
expensive there are security risks with
virtual with vms there are security
risks with vms there have been data
breaches recorded about solutions that
run in virtualized environments you also
run into an issue of availability and
this is largely because you can only
have a finite number of virtual machines
running on a piece of hardware and this
results in limitations and restrictions
in the types of environment you want to
be running and then finally setting up
and managing a virtualized environment
is time consuming it can take a lot of
time and it can also get very expensive
so how about kubernetes well kubernetes
is a tool that allows you to manage
containerized deployment of solutions
and inherently kubernetes is a tool that
is really a next level maturity of
deployment so if you can think of your
maturity curve as deploying code in
directly to hardware in a data center
and then deploying your solutions to
virtual machines the next evolution of
that deployment is to use containers and
kubernetes so let's kind of go through
and look at the differences between a
virtual machine and kubernetes we've got
a few here that we want to highlight and
you'll get an understanding of what the
differences are between the two so first
of all with virtual machines there is
inherently security risks and what
you'll find as we get dig through the
architecture later in the presentation
is that kubernetes is inherently secure
and this is largely because of the
legacy code the legacy of kubernetes and
where it came from we'll talk about that
in just a moment but kubernetes is
inherently secure virtual machines are
not easily portable now with that said
they they are technically portable
they're just not very easily portable
whereas with kubernetes it's working
with docker container solutions it is
extremely portable that means that you
can actually spin up and spin down and
manage your infrastructure exactly the
way that you want it to be managed and
scale it on the demands of the customers
as they're coming in to use the solution
from a time consuming point of view
kubernetes is much less time consuming
than with a virtual machine a few other
areas that we want to kind of um
highlight from differences virtual
machines use much less isolation when
building out the
encapsulated environment than kubernetes
does for instance with a virtual machine
you have to run hypervisor on top of the
os and hardware and then inside of the
virtual machine you also have to have
the operating system as well whereas in
contrast on a kubernetes environment
because it's leveraging a darker
container and or container-like
technologies it only has to have the os
and the hardware and then inside of each
container it doesn't need to have that
additional os layer it's able to inherit
what it needs to be able to run the
application this makes the whole
solution much more flexible and allows
you to run many more containers on a
piece of hardware than versus running
virtual machines on a single piece of
hierarchy so as we highlighted here vms
are not as portable as
kubernetes and kubernetes is portable
directly related to the use of
containerization and because kubernetes
is built on top of containers it is much
less time consuming because you can
actually script and automatically
allocate resource to nodes within your
kubernetes environment because it allows
the infrastructure to run much more
effectively and much more efficiently so
this is why if we look at our evolution
of the land of time before kubernetes
why we are running into a solution where
kubernetes had to come about because the
demand for having more highly scalable
solutions that are more efficient was
just really a natural evolution of this
software deployment model that started
with pushing out code to physical
hardware and then pushing code out to
virtual machines and then needing to
have a solution much more sophisticated
kubernetes would have come about at some
point in time i'm just really glad it
came back when it did so
what is kubernetes let's let's dig into
the history of kubernetes and how it
came about so in essence uh kubernetes
is an open source platform that is
allows you to manage and deploy and
maintain groups of containers and the
container is something like docker and
if you're developing code you're
probably already using docker today
consider kubernetes as the tool that
manages multiple docker environments
together now
we talk a lot about docker and as a
container solution with kubernetes the
reality is is that kubernetes can
actually use other container tools out
there but docker just simply is the most
popular container out there both these
tools are open source that's why they're
so popular and they just allow you to be
able to have flexibility in being able
to scale up your solutions and they were
designed for the post-digital world that
we live and exist in today so a little
bit of background a little bit of trivia
around uh kubernetes so kubernetes was
originally a successor to a project at
google and the original project was
googleborg googleborg it does exactly
what kubernetes and does today but
kubernetes was rewritten from the ground
up and then released as an open source
project in 2014 so that people outside
of google could take advantage of the
power of kubernetes containerization
management tools and today it is managed
by the cloud native computing foundation
and there are many many companies that
support and manage kubernetes so for
instance if you're signing up for
microsoft azure aws google cloud all of
them will leverage kubernetes and it's
just become the the de facto tool for
managing large groups of containers so
let's kind of step through some of the
key benefits that you'd experience from
kubernetes and so we have nine key
benefits and the first it is highly
portable and is 100 open source code and
this means that you can actually go
ahead and contribute to this code
project if you want to through github
the ability to scale up the solution is
incredible um what's the the history of
kubernetes being part of a google
project for managing the google network
and infrastructure
kind of really sets the groundwork for
having a solution that is highly
scalable the
out of the high scalability also comes
the need for high availability and this
is the desire to be able to have a
highly efficient and highly energized
environment that also you can really
rely on so if you're building out a
kubernetes management
environment you know that it's going to
be
available for the solutions that you're
maintaining and it's really designed for
deployment so you can script out the
environment and actually have it as part
of your devops model so you can scale up
and meet the demands of your customer
then what you'll find is that the um
load balancing is extremely efficient
and it allows you to distribute the load
efficiently across your entire network
so your network remains stable and then
also the tool
allows you to manage the orchestration
of your storage so you can have local
storage such as an ssd on the hardware
that the kubernetes is
maintaining or if the kubernetes
environment is pulling storage from a
public cloud such as azure or aws you
can actually go ahead and make that
available to your entire system and you
can inherit the security that goes back
and forth between the cloud environments
and one of the things you'll find
consistent with kubernetes is that it is
designed for a cloud-first uh
environment um kubernetes swell is that
it's it's really a self-healing
environment so if something happens or
something fails kubernetes will detect
that failure and then either restart the
process kill the process or replace it
and then because of that you also have
automated rollouts and drawbacks in case
you need to be able to manage the state
of the environment and then finally
you have automatic bin packaging so you
can actually specify the compute power
that's being used from cpu and ram for
each container so let's dig into the
final area which is the actual
kubernetes architecture i'm going to
cover this at a high level there's
actually another video that you can
that simply learn has developed which
digs deeper into the kubernetes
architecture and so the kubernetes
architecture is a clustered based
architecture and it's really about two
key areas you have the kubernetes master
which actually controls um and all of
the activities within your entire
kubernetes
infrastructure and then you have nodes
um that actually are running on linux
machines um outs that are controlled by
the master so let's kind of go through
some of these um areas so if we look at
the kubernetes master to begin with and
we'll start with
etc this is a tool that allows for the
configuration of information and the
management of nodes within your cluster
and one of the key features that you'll
find with all of the tools that are
managed within either a the master
environment or within a node is that
they are all accessible via the api
server
and what's interesting about the api
server is that it's a restful based
infrastructure which means that you can
actually secure each connection with ssl
and other
security models to ensure that your
entire infrastructure and the
communication going back and forth
across your infrastructure is tightly
secured scheduler goes ahead and
actually as you'd expect it actually um
manages the schedule of activities
within the actual cluster and then you
have the control and the controller is a
daemon server that actually manages and
pushes out the instructions to all of
your nodes so the other tools really are
the
the infrastructure and you can consider
them the administration site um of the
master whereas controller is the
management actually pushes out all of
the controls via the api server so let's
actually dig into
one of the actual nodes themselves and
there are three key areas of the nodes
one is the docker environment which
actually helps and manage and maintain
the container that's actually inside
of the node and then you have the
kubelet which is responsible for
information that goes back and forth and
it's going to do most of the
conversation with the api server on the
actual health of that node and then you
have the actual kubernetes proxy which
actually runs the services actually
inside of the node so as you see all of
these infrastructures are extremely
lightweight and designed to be very
efficient and very available for your
infrastructure and so here's a quick
recap of the different tools that are
available and it really breaks down into
two key areas you have your kubernetes
master and the kubernetes node the
kubernetes master has the instructions
of what's going to happen within your
kubernetes infrastructure and then it's
going to push out those in structure to
an indefinite number of nodes that will
allow you to be able to scale up and
scale down your solution in a dynamic
way welcome to all our viewers i'm
anjali from simply learn and today i'll
be taking you through the installation
process for docker so before we begin
let me give you an intro to docker so
what is docker docker is a tool which is
used to automate the deployment of
applications in lightweight containers
so when i say containers i mean a
software package that consists of all
the dependencies required to run the
particular application and when you
deploy containers you're basically
providing the capability for the
application to run in any kind of
environment so dockers have multiple
features some of which are that multiple
containers can run on the same hardware
it has very high productivity when
compared to virtual machines it
maintains isolated applications and has
a very quick and easy configuration
process so now let's begin with the demo
we'll be installing docker on an ubuntu
system so this is my system i'll just
open the terminal so the first thing you
can start with is removing any docker
installation that you probably already
have present in your system if you want
to start from scratch so this is the
command to do so sudo apt get remove
docker
docker engine docker dot io enter your
password
and docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install docker
once again
before that i'll just clear my screen
okay so before i install docker let me
just ensure that all these softwares on
my system currently is in its latest
state
so sudo apt get update
great so that's done next thing we'll
actually install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get
install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that's occurred so sometimes it's
possible that due to the environment of
the machine that you're working in this
particular command does not work
in which case there's always another
command that you can start with
just type docker install
and that by itself will give you the
command you can use to install docker
so as it says here sudo apt install
docker dot io is a command that we will
need to execute to install docker
and after that we'll execute the suros
snap install docker so sudo apt install
docker dot io first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have
sudo snap install docker so snap install
docker installs a newly created snap
package
there are basically some other
dependencies for docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire docker io it will
take some time
great so our docker is installed the
next thing we do as i mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages so the command for
that is
sudo snap install docker
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
installation process for docker but
we'll perform a few more stages where we
will test if the installation has been
done right
so before we move on with the testing
for docker let's once again just check
the version that we have installed
so for that the command is docker
version
and as you can see docker version
17.12.1
ce has been installed
next thing we do is we pull an image
from the docker hub
so docker run
hello
world now hello world is a docker image
which is present on the docker hub
docker hub is basically a repository
that you can find online so with this
command the docker image hello world has
been pulled onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now the command to check
this
is sudo docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository
this is present on our system currently
so the image has been successfully
pulled onto the system and this means
that our docker is working
now we'll try out another command
sudo docker ps minus a
this displays all the containers that
you have pulled so far
so as you can see here there are three
hello world images displayed and all of
them are in exited state so i did this
demo previously too which is why the two
hello worlds which is created two
minutes ago is also displayed here and
the first hello world which has been
created a minute ago is the one we just
did for this demo now as you have
probably noticed that all the hello
world images over here all these
containers are in the exited state so
when you give the option for docker ps
minus a where minus a stands for all it
displays all the containers whether they
are in exited or running state if you
want to see only those containers which
are in their running state you can
simply execute sudo docker ps
suro
docker
yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them are in
running state
and with that we come to an end of our
docker installation welcome everyone to
our one another demo on which we are
going to see that how exactly we can do
the installation of docker on the
windows platform specifically on windows
10. now docker is something which is
available for most of the operating
systems different different platforms so
it supports both the unix and the
windows platform as such so um linux
through various commands we can do the
installation but in the case of windows
you have to download the exe file and a
particular installer from the docker hub
websites you can simply google it and
you will get a kind of a link from where
you will be able to download the package
so let's go to the chrome and try to
search on for the windows stream uh
particular installer you will get a link
from docker hub you download it you get
the stable version you get the edge
version whichever version you want you
wish to download you can download it so
let's go back to the chrome so here you
have the docker desktop for windows so
you can go for the stable or you can go
for the edge right so you also have the
comparison that what is the difference
between these two versions right
so um the particular edge version is
something which is getting releases
every month and uh the
stable version is getting the releases
every quarter so they are not doing much
of the changes to the stable version as
compared to the edge there so you just
have to double click on the installer
and that will help you to do the
installation of the process so let's get
started so you just click on the get
instable version so when you do that the
particular installer is going to install
now it's going to take like around 300
mb there so that's the kind of installed
which is available so once the installer
is downloaded so what you can do is that
you can actually go ahead and you can uh
proceed with the doing the double click
on this installer when you double click
on that you have to proceed with some of
the steps like you know from the gui
itself you are going to proceed with
these steps so we'll wait for 10 to 20
seconds more and then the installer will
be done and then we can do the double
click and the installation will proceed
so another thing is that uh there is a
huge difference between the installer
like for example in case of unix the
installer is a little bit less but in
case of windows it's a gui is also
involved and there are a lot of binaries
which is available there so that's the
reason why you know the huge size is
there now it's available for free that's
for sure and it also requires the
windows 10 professional or enterprise
64-bit there so um if you are working on
some previous uh version of operating
systems like windows 7 and all you have
the older version called docker toolbox
so they used to call it as like docker
toolbox earlier but now they are calling
it as a docker desktop with the new
docker windows 10 support as such here
so another couple of seconds and then
the installer will be done and then we
will be able to proceed with the
installation
so let's see that how much progress is
there to the download so we'll click on
the downloads and here still we have
some particular installations or some
download going on so we'll wait for some
time and once the installation is done
then we'll go back and we'll proceed
with installation
so couple of seconds
so it's almost done so i'll just click
on this one you can go to the directory
to the downloads and you can double
click on that also but if you want to do
the installation you can click on this
one also and it will ask for the
approval yes or no you have to provide
now once that is done so um a desktop a
kind of a gui component will open there
so it will start proceeding with
installation so it's asking whether you
want to add a desktop the shortcut to
desktop so you can say okay i'm going to
click on ok so it will unpack the files
all the files which is required for
docker to successfully install that is
getting unpacked over here so it will
take some time to do the installation
because it's doing a lot of work here so
you can just wait for till the execution
of the installer to be completed and
once the installer is done you can open
your command line and start working on
the docker
so taking some time to extract the files
now it's asking us to you know do the
close and do the restart so once that is
done you will be able to proceed further
and you can just you know run the
command line and any docker command if
you can run so that will give you the
response whether the docker is installed
or not so you can see here that docker
is you know something which is installed
so you can run like docker version you
will be able to get a version of the
client when you do the restart of the
machine then at that moment of time the
docker server will also be started and
then this particular error message will
go off right now the docker daemon is
not up and running because the
installation requires a restart and when
you close on this one and go for the
restart the machine will be restarted
here so this is the way that how exactly
we can go for a docker installation and
we can go on that part welcome everyone
to this topic on docker tutorial for the
beginners here now in this one we are
going to talk about the various
components for example what is the
devops here why the devops is important
what is docker the advantages of docker
installation of docker
architecture of docker components of
docker game
so these are the different things which
we are going to talk about over here now
let's start with what exactly isn't
devops all about here now devops is
nothing but a collaboration between the
development and the operations teams
over here which enables continuous
delivery of the applications and
services to the end user so it's a
combination or collaboration between the
two teams development and operations
which helps us to go for a further
implementation of various processes like
continuous integration continuous
deployment continuous delivery all these
things are possible with this
collaboration over here now why exactly
docker is important for us as such
in a city far away from this one so
a developer decided to develop a tons of
software on a single vm now he can put
up applications he is having a big
server and he wants to host the the
multiple application on a single machine
but for him these virtual machine got a
crash because definitely if you are
putting up more uh different different
applications as such on the on a single
vm uh it's not able to take up that much
kind of load over there so in order to
avoid this situation how exactly he can
do the various options or what he can
implement to have this uh issue resolved
so ultimately docker is something which
is the solution of him so if he really
wants to host multiple applications
on a single virtual machine or he want
to have different different applications
then docker is the ultimate solution for
him to do that and by doing so
uh there will be no issues as such when
we talk about that uh the errors or the
virtual machines cannot be crashed and
but there will be no impact on the
virtual machine as such so why exactly
docker is important so let's talk about
the comparison between the docker and
virtual machine there are very few
reasons why exactly uh the docker is
being chosen open a virtual machine
because virtual machine is a
full-fledged component which can take up
any kind of load but some of the reasons
are still that in which case we will be
preferring the docker instead of the
virtual machine here the very first one
is the memory users so docker is having
a very less memory uses because there is
no concept of guest operating system
whereas on the other hand the virtual
machines are going to take a huge amount
of ram uh resources in order to keep
that particular operating system up and
running second one performance because
uh if definitely if you have less
utilization and the users is less the
performance will be better but for some
reason if you are taking up more
resources and you will not be able to
deliver that amount of performance as
such over there and then again we have
portability so portability is also quite
easy when we talk about the virtual
machines in case of docker it's quite
portable as compared to the virtual
machine and then the last time is that
the boot up time so virtual machine boot
up time is probably in minutes but uh in
case of docker it's in seconds so if we
summarize it on this one so the memory
utilization the boot up time the
performance everything is better in case
of docker as compared to the virtual
machines
right for a classic example let's say
that what about the memory user 9gb of
memory uh you know is something if you
can see that f1 f2 and f3 is there so
green and red color represents the
occupied memory and the wasted memory
now
there is a particular utilization of
let's say that um you know a server
which is available there and uh you know
3 gb of
ram is something which is wasted and 4
gb of ram is something which is being
occupied there so app 2 is using like 2
gb and then you can see that the
specific 2gb of ram is occupied and 3gb
is occupied and the wasted one is 1gb so
vm can see over there that you know 9gb
of ram is used and the remaining 6 gb of
uh unused ram can not be used here
because if for example i allocate like 4
gb of ram to the virtual machine it's
there itself it it gets locked on so
it's not like okay i'm using only 4gb
ram out of this
9gb of ram then the next
5 gb of ram will be totally wasted so
you cannot reuse it for any purpose
so this is a problem with the virtual
machine that if you allocate some memory
to the uh specific virtual machine
if you are not using that much uh
resources or that much memory the
remaining memory will be simply wasted
because this is hardcorely allocated to
virtual machine and you cannot utilize
these unused memory as such over there
so this is the limitation from the
memory perspective but in case of docker
definitely if uh you know out of the 9gb
of ram if we are using uh only 3gb of
ram
so whatever the unused memory is there
so we can actually use it to for the new
containers so it's not dedicatedly
allocated to the virtual machines if you
are using
out of 9gb if you are using 1gb 2gb 3gb
of 4gb whatever the remaining
memory is available that you can simply
use it for the other containers also
this ensures that you always go for an
optimal utilization of your resources
and unnecessarily there is no wastage of
the different different resources or the
different components over here in this
one so that's the reason why the docker
containers are quite uh efficient in
terms of memory when we compare it with
the virtual machine next one is the
performance now um in a virtual machine
we know that you know on the
infrastructure on the physical
infrastructure on top of that you put up
a kind of operating system a base
operating system is there and then on
top of that you have the hypervisor and
this hypervisor then is used to create
the virtual machines which is having a
kind of guest operating system inside it
now the issue over here is that you have
two operating systems over here
so the guest operating system is also
going to take some particular resources
and
for example memory or a space a
processor so in every terms in every
source terms it is going to
go ahead and say that okay i'm going to
use the uh particular some of the
resources now problem is
that if you're hosting a very small
application you will end up in having a
more consumption because of this guest
operating system will take more more of
the resources and then you are just
using some small very small resources
for your application in an uh real world
so docker container on the other hand
does not have a concept of the guest
operating system and that's where what
happens that the docker engine is more
than sufficient to handle the docker
containers and inside the docker
containers there is the application
which is being hosted over there now
with this one definitely the performance
is quite better as compared to any
virtual machine because of the terms
that there is no unnecessarily wasted of
the resources because in the previous
case virtual machines a full-fledged
guest operating system is up and running
you need some resources to be allocated
to that but in case of containers you
don't need to have that particular
functionality implemented then
portability so um you know having a
portability or moving an application
which works on a system a does not means
that it will work on the system b also
this is a similar problem which we face
that you know the usually the
application works perfectly fine in a
lower environment and when it goes to
the production environment it sometimes
fails and it does not comes up properly
so this isn't portability issue which we
have when we talk about the virtual
machines but when in case of containers
when we got a container up and running
in a lower environment and once the
container is prepared you don't have to
do the changes on modification to that
depending on the environment the same
container can be deployed in production
environment and it's very easy so
whatever container prepared in the lower
environment in a dev environment the
same will work in production environment
without any issues because it contains
all the dependencies and executables
everything inside it so you don't have
to do any kind of modifications or
changes to these containers as such over
here and the last one is a boot up time
so uh the boot up time of the virtual
machines is in minutes and whereas the
boot up time of uh the
docker containers is in
seconds or probably in milliseconds so
these are the reason why we consider the
virtual machine as in resources
based uh environment but on the other
hand docker is something which is quite
light and fast as compared to virtual
machines so let's see that what exactly
is in docker all about here so in this
one you can see uh we have the physical
infrastructure on which we have
the host operating system now we don't
have the hypervisor and the guest
operating system instead of that we have
the docker engine which is taking care
of managing the docker containers and
inside these docker containers you have
the applications and all the required
binaries and the libraries here so there
is no concept of the gift operating
system these docker engine is the uh
person or is the process which is taking
care of all the requests which is going
on and if this docker engine is up and
running then all the containers will
also be accessible and will be available
now docker is nothing but a os level
virtualization
software platform that enables
developers and id administrators to
create deploy and run applications in a
docker container with all its
dependencies so docker is a very
important tool nowadays if you want to
look forward to the host your
application because of its portability
uh benefit that you don't require much
of the changes uh depending on the
platform or depending on the environment
so whatever the developers are able to
build up the same thing will go till the
production environment now let's talk
about what exactly is in docker
container here now docker container is a
lightweight software package that uh
includes all the dependencies whether
it's a base operating system uh some
framework sample libraries it's it's
something which is a part of this one so
that if you will be
if you want to host your application you
will be able to do that so it's a
complete package so both the source code
and the dependencies is what you put up
inside the docker containers
now
within this docker containers you can
have multiple applications there
multiple programming languages multiple
frameworks can be hosted there in fact
the databases also can be hosted within
this docker containers you can host them
as such over there now one of the
different advantages of docker let's
talk about that now the first one is the
rapid deployment so rapid deployment is
the very first
advantages which we are getting over
here second
quick and easy configuration
better efficiency
portability
scalability
and security over here now there are
different ways in which we can
understand the uh benefits or we can
have the understanding about the
docker here
so uh these are some couple of
benefits now let's take up uh take them
one by one the for the first one is the
deployment part so
it's it supports the rapid deployment
now
just like a web application for instance
i want to deploy to website so there are
some couple of steps which needs to be
done across different different
environments like for example if i have
five environments i have to do the
deployment the same steps in all the
five environments at the different
period of time now when we talk about
docker containers we don't have to run
those steps multiple times because once
those steps are executed in one docker
container the same docker container goes
till the production environment so you
don't have to actually do a rebuild of
the docker containers and you can simply
say that okay i have got the docker
container here so you can just run one
or two couple of commands and that will
help you to host your docker containers
so you don't have to redo or rework on
any kind of the deployment work into the
production environment or into the
higher environments and then we goes for
the quick and easy configurations so uh
the configurations of docker containers
is quite easy you can have your own
custom docker images built out the
docker files so these processes can be
integrated within the jenkins also so
cicd is quite possible with the help of
docker if you want to really do that and
uh then we have better efficiency yes
they have a better efficiency and reduce
resources management as compared to the
virtual machines portability uh we have
already thought about that that it's
easy to move from one environment from
one system to another in fact it's easy
from the developer also so from one
machine from one developer to another
developer it's very easy to move these
uh different docker containers then we
have scalability
scalability is also possible with this
docker containers just like multiple
virtual machines you can also create
multiple containers and you can share
the traffic out of that so but that
scalability and all is possible with the
orchestration tools uh then security is
there so
you can have your best practices of the
security implemented because um it's
just a kind of a virtualization just
like a virtual machine so you have all
the uh different uh possibilities which
is available which you can explore when
you talk when you want to make this
stock container secure right so these
were some of the benefits which was
there for the docker here now let's talk
about the installation of docker here
now installation of docker is pretty
common and whatever platform you want
it's available over there so it's
available for ubuntu windows
it's available for mac operating system
so for ubuntu you have to run the
commands on the open to depart operating
system to download it and for windows
it's actually having a
a particular exe file so you can go for
the installation of exe file and then we
have the mac operating system so for mac
operating system you have the dmg files
and when you do the dmg file so it will
uh help you to install the
component over there so mac you can also
use the home view wants to do the
installation of that particular
component now next one is the
architecture of docker
now the architecture of docker is pretty
straightforward there are key components
which is available there in the
architecture of docker here the very
first one is the as the client facing is
the docker client now docker client or
you can say that docker cli is available
there now this is the component it's a
command line interface which takes up
the request from the end user like for
example i'm running the command so it
will take all the requests from me as an
end user and it will send those uh
particular things or the requirements to
the docker daemon to the server using
the rest api interface so this docker
daemon is something which keeps on
running on the server and it's a
background process it gets deployed as
in service there in case this docker
demon is not available or it's not up
and running you will not get the proper
response from the docker command line
here so in order to get your activity or
your
procedures implemented you need to have
the docker server or docker daemon up
and running in fact this docker cli can
be configured to connect to any other
servers or any other different server
docker daemon also so it's a
connectivity which is happening over the
rest api interface where all the
requests are processed are sent to the
docker demon and whatever response is
coming back that is given back to the
end user so what are the different
components of docker here let's talk
about that so docker client consists of
the cli company uh like we have already
discussed so that is something which is
uh going to take up all the requests
from the end user then um it's using the
rest api interface which is there to
have the connectivity with the docker
daemon so docker daemon is uh something
uh which is always up and running so if
you run couple of commands like docker
pull push and also that activity you are
actually sending the request to the
docker demon and docker daemon is
actually doing all the work so it's not
a docker client which is doing it just
taking its kind of interface which will
take the things up and send it back or
send it forward to the docker day
right so it's a background process which
keeps on running on the server on the
operating system and uh it's it's the
same process across all the
infrastructure all the different
platforms whether you use mac operating
system use windows or you use linux
everywhere this is the basic
functionality and uh it keeps on
listening to the rest api interface so
uh whatever the request new request
comes in it immediately process it and
whatever the response whether you are
stopping a container whether you're
running a container according to that
the action will be taken and the
response will be sent back to the rest
api to the docker client so a docker is
a process or it's a command line which
is used to start the docker daemon
when you run the command like service
docker status on the server you will be
able to see the command which is getting
executed in the back end so there you
can see that docker is the process or is
the command line which is used to
initialize the docker daemon and of
course there is a kind of configurations
which you have to pass it on as a
parameters so even if you run psiphony f
command you will be able to know that
what process is running from the docker
perspective and the third component is a
a particular docker registry so we have
a ready-made uh cloud service which is
available known as the docker hub so you
can actually store the docker images on
these docker registry so there are a lot
of ready-made docker images which is
available there but of course you can
have your own docker image also over
there or you want you can have your own
custom
registry docker registries also for
example in jfrog you can have your
private hosted registries also so all
these uh different repositories you can
use with your docker container so docker
containers is having the flexibility
that whichever registries or
repositories you want to connect or you
want to establish the connectivity you
can always do that now let's talk about
the docker image over here
in detail
now a docker image is nothing but a
template of instructions it's having a
couple of instructions in which you will
be using these instructions to create a
final dock container so docker image is
uh nothing but uh for example i want to
have a tomcat apache docker image so
what are the instructions i have to do
so the very first thing is that i have
to pick up a base operating system then
on top of that i will be installing the
jdk or some prerequisite packages and
then on top of that we will be
configuring on to the tomcat apache
there so these are the steps these are
the different instructions step by step
procedure which we are implementing so
that at the end of the
activity we will be able to have a
docker container ready which we can
deploy to host tomcat apache so it's a
template which is having all the uh
particular instructions in order to
build a docker image you require a file
called dockerfile which is uh of course
having all these different uh
instructions embedded in that so when
you run the dockerfile it acts like a
build tool so whatever the instructions
you are putting up over there all those
instructions are getting uh processed
and you are able to get a end result
then these docker images are actually
comprised of multiple layers so multiple
layers are available there so step by
step so you will be first of all having
a base layer from which the image starts
on top of that another layer for example
you did the installation of jdk so
another layer will be there and then you
did the configuration
of of the tomcat apache and then another
layer will be there so it's a
multi-layered in uh component which is
available and these layers are in
incremental order so definitely the
oldest one will be known as the base
layer and then on top of that all the
latest changes will be done in the
latest layers there so this is an
example now here you can see that
there are four instructions and these
four instructions are also known as the
four layer docker image so whatever the
final docker image you will get in there
you will be able to see four layers of
uh the docker image here now the very
first is ubuntu so ubuntu 18.04 we are
pulling up and then we are pulling like
uh the file over here and uh then we are
running the make utility and uh once
that is done then we are running that
file dot
python file over here in this one so
these are four instructions which is
available right so uh which will
definitely help us to do that how
exactly we can make or we can
perform the different activities right
from the base so in this case the base
layer will be like uh the one two one so
one to one will be the base image and
the moment the final cmd attribute or
cmd
uh
attributions are processed and executed
after that you will be able to get a
final full-fledged docker image over
there so this will be a full uh complete
docker image or docker container which
you will get once the whole build
process is completed
now in this ways you have
you can see that the previous docker
file which we processed so the base
layer is ubuntu 18.04 we are not
building that actually it's
automatically so it's by default getting
downloaded as in full base layer after
that only we have like layer 1 layer 2
layer 3 added up because those
modifications we are doing it after the
because from does not means that you are
doing any kind of layer modifications
it's just like you are importing some
base operating system or base image so
the modification or adding up the layers
is only done after the base layer there
so whenever a user creates a container a
new layer is something which is stopped
on top of the image these layers are
known as the
containers layers so one two one the
very first instruction does not
comprises it it is it's not a kind of
container layer we can call it as an
base image layer there so every
container has a separate read write
container layer and any modification in
a container is reflected upon the
container layers only so layer one may
be having some different of
instructions later maybe having
different instructions so like that it's
a diff a step-by-step processor
in case
you know whenever a container is deleted
the top layer also gets deleted over
there in that one so if i delete some
particular containers and that is
something which is gone so it was
suppose having like three layers so the
top layer will be simply deleted because
the container is also deleted for that
particular part now docker uses a copy
and write strategy with both docker
images and docker containers so whenever
we
perform any activity or whenever copy on
uh write strategies and strategy to
share and copy files for better
efficiency so
it's something which is being used to
increase the overall performance of the
docker containers it also makes docker
efficient by reducing the uses of disk
space because whenever uh required okay
whenever is needed only at that moment
of time it's actually performing the
copy and uh it definitely reduces the
overall disk utilization and this is
very important also because when you
have so many docker containers up and
running so you have to worry or you have
to make the utilization of a disk or
your disk users or resources also
minimum so that is also you need to make
sure that it does not exceed a
particular value
so once the utilization is also less
then definitely the overall performance
will also be better and improved over
here in this case
so uh let's talk about some of the facts
here so the base layers are something
which is purely read-only format so you
cannot do the modifications union file
system saves the memory uh you know by
avoiding the duplications of the files
uh the layers can be combined in a union
file system to create a single image so
all these layers are combined and got a
final product or called a you know you
can call it as docker image or docker
containers
and this allows a file system to appear
as a write table uh which is known as
copy on right so copy and write strategy
is being used so to do the changes or to
do the perform the modifications of this
union file system while creating the
different different layers
so
now let's talk about the docker stream
very important component because even if
you prepare the docker image locally
and you don't have the collaborative
tool or you don't have the uh tool where
you can share these images definitely
it's not easy for you to port these
docker images from one system to another
so docker register is very important for
the portability feature of docker so
docker registry is a service to host and
distribute docker images among users so
uh it can be built up by one user and
multiple users can use it for example
i'm using a jenkins one so
jenkins uh image is prepared only once
but it's being used by different people
as such docker registry uh again it's a
repository is a collection of docker
images so in a repository you will be
having like different different uh
docker images as such
so in registry a user can distinguish
between the docker images with their tag
names so uh for example jenkins is an a
kind of a single image they might be
different type of images there let's say
that okay let's talk about uh jenkins uh
jdk so there will be image called
jenkins the name of the image will be
same but the tags will be different so
one tag would be like jdk8 one tag would
be like jtk9 and one tag would be
dedicated so the difference between all
these three darker images is that that
jdk81 is prepared on jdk8 it's running
on jdk8 and if you want to use jtk9 in
that case you have to pull down the the
darker image of jenkins with the jdk 9
installed so depending on the frameworks
or depending on the runtimes so with
these tags different tags are processed
so you can have the distinguish between
the uh
docker images and whichever docker image
you feel you want to use you can
implement according to your requirement
and docker
by default is having its own uh
cloud-based registry called as docker
hub which gets automatically connected
when the moment you do the docker
installation but in case you are working
into your private infrastructure so in
that case uh you may use the
repositories uh docker repositories on
the uh specific jfrog artifactory or the
private repositories also can be hosted
but docker hub is something which is
having a public and private repositories
both so you can create either the public
and private repositories you can use uh
push and pull activities to interact
with these docker images you want to
download a docker image so you can run
pull if you want to push your docker
image to the docker registry in that
case you can run the push activity so in
both the cases you are doing the
interaction with the
docker hub so when you run some build
process or when you run the containers
there may be some docker containers
which is getting pulled down from the
specific registry from the docker hub
and uh if that specific image and tag is
available definitely pull command will
be successful but in case of push
command you are pushing your custom
docker images uh you cannot push the
ready-made docker images which is
available you can
publish your own docker image only to
the docker hub and then you can further
on do the pull and push activity
accordingly to those repositories so
whatever the ready-made and third-party
images which is available you can only
do the pull activities to them you
cannot do the push activities push
command scenario will only come when you
are looking when you are interacting
with your custom docker image next one
is the docker container now dropper
container is an executable package of an
application and its dependencies
together so when we prepare a docker
container we actually combine both the
dependencies and the
application source code inside it so the
docker container don't have to look for
the dependencies on the host machine on
the server so this is one of the benefit
where we see that the portability is
very easy because whatever i'm building
up on one system everything is inside
the docker container so i don't really
need to do any further activity on other
machines
so whatever works on one system can be
easily worked on in the system
so it's very lightweight also so it can
be easily deployed and executed on you
know on their particular uh servers
because it does not take that much
utilization like a virtual machine so if
you are looking forward for having your
application hosted into your local
system
you can easily do it within the docker
container so the utilization is very
less as compared to the virtual machine
so you don't have to worry about your
operating host operating system and the
qualifications
so docker containers can run in totally
isolation just like a virtual machine so
there is no interaction or there is no
interference so they share the os called
uh kernel but uh the thing is they don't
have the interface as such over there so
it works totally in isolation uh two
different containers will not have any
interaction unless and until we do we
set up that the containers to have the
interactions
now there is uh data volumes where which
can be shared and uh be used among the
multiple containers so um you have the
uh capability over here that you know if
the there is some unused uh space that
can be easily shared across the multiple
containers here so uh it is uh built
using the docker images so uh using the
docker images the docker containers are
built up and uh docker run is a specific
command which is used to build a docker
container so if you got a docker image
let's say that i have prepared a docker
image a custom docker image using the
docker file now if i need to create a
docker container out of a docker image i
have to run a docker turn command so
docker run command is nothing
but it initializes or creates an
instance of a docker image now next
component is the docker compose
now typically when we work with the the
darker containers so we have to run like
if i want to run like five six
containers i have to initialize like
five six times or i have to run docker
and commands five six times there so um
and if you want to create a relationship
between the containers then definitely
that is something which you need to
manage using the docker commands but
sometimes it's not an easy task for you
to run those commands manually or
remember those commands so docker
compose is a utility over here using
which you can actually run multiple
containers with a single service
you just got off
a kind of a single file you just run it
and all the containers definitions and
relationships everything is inside this
docker file here so you want to run two
containers that's totally fine instead
of running two commands now you just
have to run one file and that will do
take care of that now
you may be having more than two
containers five six seven whatever
number of containers you have that can
be easily deployed without any um manual
activity or without any maintenance onto
the server
so uh these containers totally run in
isolation but yes you can establish the
interaction that how they want to uh
interact with each other and that
interaction you can put up in these uh
docker compose files so docker compose
file is something which is written in
environment format and in this you
define that okay i need two containers
and this in this image should be there
these are the parameters which you need
to run and if you want to have the
interaction or the linkage between the
images that also you can establish
within this yml files or this in within
this docker compose file here right so
let's say for example i want to have an
application which requires apache web
server and mysql database now i can
create a docker compose file which can
run both containers and uh without you
know you don't require to restart or
start them separately or initialize them
separately so i will be having a final
docker compose file which is having like
uh
you know containers like apache
containers and mysql containers both
inside a single docker compose file here
so that's the benefit you're going to
get because now you don't have to run
them separately separate apache and
separate via mysql so you can get it
done with the help of a single docker
compose file here now what exactly is
the docker swamp now docker swamp is a
inbuilt or it's a default
uh orchestration tool which is being
provided by the docker itself it's a
service
for containers which allows the it
administrators and the developers to
create and manage a cluster of smart
nodes so
in a typical world when you do the
installation of docker there is a
limitation that you some of the features
like high ability multiple uh instances
or scalability all these things are not
possible as it is with the core docker
now on top of that you require the
organization tools like docker swamp
where you have a swam of node machines
uh five six known machines are there on
which you can have your highly available
application infrastructure implemented
now this one means that if i want to run
my uh applications five containers six
containers and seven containers for that
purpose we are using the docker spam so
each node of docker swim is having a
docker daemon uh which is uh used to for
performing the interaction so there will
be a master node which is available so
uh it will be interacting with all the
known machine on the all the client
machines and this interaction will be in
such a way that it will let them know
okay i want to deploy the container or
onto the note 3 so it will perform that
activity and the container will be up
and running on the note 3 there so a
swamp consists of two type of nodes one
is the manager node and one is the
worker node so manager is the master
node which you can refer
and the worker node is the one which is
actually doing most of the work so uh
the manager node is not something which
is expected to host uh anything apart
from the main component but yes
you can always configure
if you feel that you want to only deploy
the container on the worker node so that
also you can
do during the deployment of the
containers so manager will keep on
connecting to the different worker nodes
there and whenever new request comes in
so it will basically try to connect and
see that okay i just want to go ahead
and deploy a container so it will do the
deployment of the container on the
worker node so the main work will be
done by the worker nodes and manager is
just doing the management of all these
resources the worker nodes will be
definitely receiving the request from
the manager and
it will be proceeding and performing
those activities and uh
if for some reason worker node is not
active or online so the master node will
not be able to deploy the containers on
that server so right now let's talk
about a demo in which we have to create
a docker image using a docker file on
the open220 so uh you want to use a base
operating system as an ubuntu 20 there
and using that we will we are going to
create a custom docker image
so let's connect to our virtual machine
and see that how we can do that okay so
as part of this demo here we are going
to prepare a docker image and uh in that
we are going to use a base image of
ubuntu so uh let's take an operating
system of ubuntu 20 20 is the latest
version of the undo operating system so
i have got a server so let's see so
first of all we have to install the
docker.io package which will install the
docker package and then we can
enable the
service we can make sure that the docker
service is up and running because if the
service itself is down then we will not
be able to perform any activity and then
our sample if you run docker run hello
hyphen volt so that is going to pull a
docker image from the docker hub and a
particular activity will be done to you
so once that is done so we can say that
okay the container is up and running and
everything is got uh you know over there
up and running and then you can also try
some of the ubuntu uh docker image also
if you feel that you want to try you can
do that but the main uh demo which we
need to do over here is that we need to
prepare a custom docker image and in
this one we will be having like we will
be using an ubuntu base operating system
on top of that we will be installing php
engine x all these different components
so we are going to have a php based
website hosted onto the apache web
server as an nginx and then we will be
able to access that application so the
very first thing which we need to do is
that we need to create a folder uh let's
say that i just create a particular
folder called nginx iphone image and
then i create a docker file over there
so docker file uh content we are going
to take from this one so let's go to the
server and see that how we can go ahead
with the activity
now uh what we can do is that uh what uh
we have got a server over here now in
this server what i'm going to do is that
i'm going to proceed with the
installation of docker first now when i
do the docker installation first so what
will happen that i will be able to have
my docker installation completed and
then further on i can take the further
steps of having the accessibility of uh
going through the understanding that
what is this uh particular platform or
how to prepare different different kind
of containers so
i have got a particular container over
here so what i can really do is that i
can simply say that okay i have got a
server so this is a one-two server so
i'm going to run the command called app
update first now this will do the update
locally so all the links and everything
will be updated now the whole idea about
doing the updates is that so that i will
be able to ha establish the fact that
i'm trying to connect i'm trying to uh
connect with the 2.2 url so that at any
moment of time i should be able to fetch
on the latest packages now once that is
done so i'm going to run the command
called apt install docker dot io now the
moment i do this what will happen that
it will try to download some packages it
will ask for the confirmation you can
give your confirmation
and i can say yes the moment you give
the confirmations the download of the
packages will proceed over here step by
step it will download the packages and
the installation will go on now once the
installation is done so what you can do
is that you can see that docker is
deployed into your system or not you can
run docker version command or you can
also use the service command to check to
make sure to ensure that the docker
service is always up and running if the
service is not up and running you have
to make sure you have to enable it you
have to start that service so these are
some couple of steps which you need to
do in order to make sure that your
connectivity or your
environment is ready for with the docker
installation and once the docker
installation is done then only you will
be able to proceed further with the
further activities like preparing the
containers preparing the images and all
that stuff but if you don't have the
docker installed prior to that then
definitely it's going to be a problem so
just make sure that before even doing
any kind of activity before even doing
any kind of steps we ensure that the
docker is fully up and running so it's
going to take some time to download the
packages and we will wait for that and
once the installation is done we will
continue further on that part
okay now once the installation is done
so you can run the command call service
docker status and when you do that uh it
will let you know that whether the
docker service is available there or not
so uh you can start the service
in case you don't get uh the proper
response
and uh
now you can see that it's showing up
that a process is running so earlier it
was not uh up and running it was
inactive but now it's active and you can
see here that dark ride is the process
which is running over here as an uh
process to initialize the docker daemon
so docker demon is up and running now
and we are good to go here so now uh if
we go and say like docker
run
hello hyphen vault so we are doing a
validation to our docker instance that
whether our docker instance is working
fine as expected or not because uh if
there is any kind of problem with the
docker demon and docker demon is not up
and running properly we would be able to
get an error message over there but
right now there is no error message
which represents that uh yes you are
pretty much running the docker image and
it's giving you the proper response so
you will be able to see the uh
docker images when you run so you will
be able to see that the docker image is
pulled down to your system and
definitely you have executed that and it
got you the response now the next thing
which we need to do is that we need to
run a particular
ubuntu one so for example if i go for
docker
run
iphone it
open to bash so what exactly we are
doing in this one is that we are pulling
down a ubuntu docker image and we are
running the bash executable on top of
that the whole purpose of doing that
activity is that so that if i want to do
some uh process or i want to perform
some activity i should be able to
connect to that docker image so the
moment i do this first of all if this
docker image is available locally that's
great it will immediately create the
container if the docker image is not
available locally the very first thing
which it will perform over here is to
pull down the docker image the correct
one and as you can see here that it uh
definitely pulls down the docker image
and once it is done so it got a terminal
for you now you can see it shows that
root at the id root and the rate of one
id is there this id is nothing but it's
a container id which we are getting here
so definitely you are inside the docker
container and when you run the docker
when you run the exit command you will
see that you have come out of the docker
container over here and the moment you
run docker ps hyphen a command you can
actually see also that how many
container you deployed so far so you ran
hello world you ran the one to one both
of them are stopped there you can see
the exit zero in the status over here
because both of them are something which
you ran in the interactive mode so they
are done so if you want to keep your
container up and running you need to
have a container which runs in the dash
mode and always up and running but for
that you have to
go ahead to the level where we need to
create a custom docker image and do the
setup accordingly so let's see that how
we can do that now i'm going to create a
particular folder called nginx hyphen
image
you can pretty much give any name
whatever name you feel you want to
perform you can do that now in this one
i'm going to put up a file called docker
file so let's see that what content we
need to put as such when we talk about
the docker file because whatever content
you put over here that is what according
which the docker image will be prepared
now here
we have to talk about so first we have
to see a base image so we are saying
that okay 0.220.04 is what i want to use
then we are giving some labels now these
labels are used to give some information
like
what is the version who is the
maintainer
what is the description uh you can do
the customizations to this one so
these labels are actually defined and
utilized so that i will be able to give
an information that okay so and so
developer is something which we can
contact so if there is any kind of
problem with the uh dockerfile or will
this build script we have to reach out
to that specific person so this is what
we typically do with the labels here now
um we also have to uh set up a parameter
like deviant underscore printed as in
non-interactive because whenever we talk
about any build process in dockerfile it
it cannot be there in the interactive
session it should be there in the non
interactive and definitely a typical uh
scenarios like you can run app update
command and then we are installing the
php engine x super supervisor all these
things we are doing we are doing the
installation uh we are using the run
attribute run a particular step and in
there whatever the commands are executed
these
statements will be executed when we will
be doing the build process and then we
are using some environment variables
okay so engine xp virtual host php
underscore conf engine extenders for
conf and supervisor and disco cons these
are the different environment variables
which we configuring over here now next
thing which we have is that uh we have
to transfer some files like probably
nginx and the virtual host file we may
have to transfer from our linux server
to the destination to the
docker container so for that we are
going to run some copy commands copy
statements so that we can do that stuff
and uh then definitely we are
transferring the supervisor
configuration file also to the server so
that we can have that configurations uh
setup over there and uh these are config
uh supervisor underscore conf and all
these different variables we have
already established where we are seeing
that what exactly configuration we are
looking forward over here and then we
are uh you know creating some folder
structure we had www html folder
structure we are creating so that we
will be able to push some content over
there and then we have the volume
configurations so uh whatever the volume
configurations are there we are putting
up so that um you know we will be able
to have all the uh specific direct
directories mounted on the host machine
on the whole server so that we can even
talk about locally also and then the
star.search is something which we need
to run because that's uh that will go
into the command statement which needs
to be executed because when you want to
run your process when you want to run
your nginx process or your docker
container some process should be up and
running that's where uh if any
interactive process will run then only
the docker container will be hold up
so that's what you can
do or you can configure over there so
i'm going to copy this whole content now
this whole content represents the
complete docker file so uh we have
already gone through this content one by
one but uh if we combine all these
content together till the exposed part
that's where we come up into these one
so expose we are doing 80 and 443 over
here
right after this one we have to create
the uh host file virtual host file
supervisor d file and the star.search
file so let's go back to the server here
now
in this one you have to uh you can use
whatever editor you feel you want to use
you can do that
so this is what i will my
master file will look like you can see
i'm running some run commands uh these
are the environment variables i'm using
then further on these variables i'm
using just to define the paths okay so
you can see that this default file we
are copying from the
host machine from the server to the
docker container and then second file is
super uh wiser d not con file and then
we have star dot sh file so these are
the different files which we want to
configure here so once this file is
prepared we have to
type in or we have to create a default
file over here in this current directory
so in this current directory we have to
put up a file called default now in this
one we will be having the default
virtual host configuration config so we
need to put our server attribute
saying that we have to look forward for
index.html or index.php and these kind
of files from the www.html directory
there so i'm just going to copy this
content
and
put it up into this one
so this is how my final file look like
so i'll save it
and uh then we have a supervisor d dot
com file so
so i'll just copy the content of this
one
i'll copy it and we have to create a
file called
super supervisor d.confile
now names we can double check because we
are referring these names into our
docker file so
we can double check that
so once this is done
save it
and we can check the docker file we can
grab
so you can see okay this one
so super
wiser d so the name is correct that's
cool so we got default we got supervisor
d now we have to create the star.sh file
because in this one we will be
configuring that how we want to start
our process of this nginx or this web
server so in this one again we have to
run the uh supervised process over here
and a configuration file so we are going
to put this one
and we'll go here and put this content
right so we got the supervised config
also available so that's also there and
the moment is done so you are going to
give the execute permission to this one
because uh you can see that into our
docker file that we are having the
attribute where we want to run this into
the dots
slash there so if you want to refer in
that mode you have to change the
permissions in case that
change mode you have to give the execute
permission to the start dot sh here now
once this is done
so what you got is that you got a
particular components like you got a
some couple of commands you have uh you
know uh got docker file super isd.com
default all these files are there now
the only thing which we need to do next
is that we need to build with the build
process
so uh if we look forward for the build
process what happens that docker build
is the command which we need to use and
uh nginx iphone image is the name which
you want to refer now you can totally
use this custom name you whatever name
you feel that you want to use you can
always use that there's no restriction
on that part and once that is on
so you will be able to list down those
images that you got a new custom docker
image here so you can see that you got
the ubuntu as a base image which is
built down and the nginx iphone image is
also prepared over there
and once that is done so you are going
to create a web root folder and uh you
can run the docker run command to see
that if you really got connected with
that particular one so let's go back and
uh see that how we can create uh the
docker custom docker image here so the
moment i do this
so it will pick up the docker file over
here and start performing the activities
uh the package installations all those
configurations ones will be performed
over here in a non-interactive mode
there is no confirmation which will be
asked from the user because you cannot
put that confirmations so the command
should be in such a way that it should
not take any kind of confirmations at
all from the
end user so because tomorrow you may be
putting up these things in the jenkins
so that will not be a feasible thing for
you to put up the commands and put up
the confirmations during the execution
so so it's trying to run do the package
installation for the php so fbm packages
are getting installed and um
here we go so we caught the successful
message now you can see it says
successfully tag this one this means
that there is no issues at all with the
docker image and when you run the docker
images or docker images ls you can run
these two couple of commands so when you
do that you got a 203 37 mb of the size
of this image that represents that this
docker image is fully ready to run to
execute
so now what we are going to do is that
we are going to map a volume over here
with the bad wwe html directory during
the execution of this container because
i really want to deploy some pages some
web pages there if you have the web
pages now as part of the build process
as part of the docker file you can do a
git clone also of some repository but i
don't want to do that uh during the
preparation of docker image i just now
got an environment where the nginx is
set up properly and it's up and running
there now it should be upon me that how
i want to put up my content and all so
that's the reason why i'm putting up a
kind of a folder structure over here and
sharing it with the docker container so
that the moment i put the html files or
the php files into that local folder i
should be able to get some web page up
and running there so that's what i'm
going to do over here in this one so i'm
going to create a folder structure
saying slash
web root here okay so there is a folder
structure which is created now in this
web root i will be putting up some files
and then same files will be redirected
inside the docker container with the
help of docker volume so let's go back
to the document now here
you have to run uh the uh once like i
said that
you are going to connect on that part
okay so uh you can use this port as an
at also but here 880 is used so whatever
port you feel you want to use you can do
that and we are giving the container
name as test an iphone container that
also you can change nginx hyphen image
is the one which we are using so if you
use some different uh particular image
you can also use that and uh you can see
that the web root is something which we
are connecting with the where www html
directory so the moment you put some
file in the web root the same file will
be reflected into the
ww html directory there so i'm going to
run this command and once this is done
so you can see that for the testing
purpose we are putting up some content
in the html one so i'll come to that
point also and we'll validate as of now
we should be having our container up and
running over here in this one now i'm
going to copy that command
okay and hit on so if the at port is
used so you have to make sure that photo
gets uh you know gets stopped
automatically or it should not be up and
running so just double check whatever
port you're using that should be free
now when you run the docker ps command
so uh you will be able to see a docker
container up and running but if you see
like docker psyphony that gives also the
stopped and running both the containers
are there but the main thing which we
want to run is that we want to run the
docker ps command and you can see that
this is a container which is running so
8080 is the container which is running
and test hyphen container is the name
now you got a container up and running
so you can actually do a call on
localhost colon 8080 so
this is a way to get the content
you can get the public ip also and uh in
the browser you can put up and you can
have the content there but right now uh
we are getting the response at least uh
it's showing his 403 error forwarding
error but that's fine we will be putting
up some web pages there in the rwb html
directory or we can say in local web
root directory so that we will be able
to have some content so what we can do
is that we can have some echo commands
executed so that we can have some added
some content added up into the uh
particular uh files there so let's see
that what different contents we can do
so uh you can use the vi mode also to do
a uh you know couple of files so uh i'm
just using this echo command
so um
the moment i go for this execution so
what happens that a file will be created
into that uh slash web route there so um
i'm expecting that i have put up a
index.html page so if you feel that you
want to put some different page you can
always do and the moment you do the curl
now you will be able to see the same
response so whatever the things you put
up in the index.html file the same
content is going to pop up when you run
the curl command now um you want to use
some php files you want to put up some
php content all that stuff you can do it
now what i'm going to do is that rather
than just a html static content i'm
going to put some php content that
is going to help me to get a file so my
web root will have now two files so um
if if you feel
uh that index.xml file should have some
meaningful content you can always do
that you can pull some of the websites
also you can put that into the you can
do a git clone in the web root and the
whole application will be started and uh
now
if you feel that i got a info.php file
so i can use the nut name into the url i
have to modify the url because uh
index.html file is the what as in
default name page you do if you want to
put up some different name you can
change the server configuration of nginx
and according to that it will work
so um when i do this so you will start
getting the output so this is the php
content output which is there it's a
complete information now it may look
like a very bulky content to you but
when you put up this one into the
browser into the web browser that will
be a meaningful information probably in
terms of some tables or something like
that right so um let me scroll to the
top here so you can see that it's
showing an error sorry it's showing in
the output and this output represents
that you got a particular php content
here so this is how we will be able to
have a container and uh you know this
container is up and running you can
modify to at any level you feel that you
want to prepare a darker image with the
code embedded also uh you can have the
git clone or you can have this
configuration into some git repository
have the source code also there and then
prepare a complete bundle altogether so
this is what we have in this demo how we
can deploy a container and a container
up and running in case of the docker
here
hello this is matthew from simply learn
and today we're going to cover what is a
docker container why you would want to
consider using it in your devops
environment so let's have a look at what
we have in our current environment so
today when you actually have your
standard machine you have the
infrastructure you have the host
operating system and you have your
applications and then when you create a
virtual environment what you're actually
doing is you're actually creating
virtual machines but those virtual
machines actually are now sitting within
a hypervisor solution that sits still on
top of your host operating system and
infrastructure and with a docker engine
what we're able to do is we're able to
actually reduce significantly
the different elements that you would
normally have within a virtualized
environment so we're able to get rid of
the the bins and the so we're able to
get rid of the guest os and we're able
to eliminate the hypervisor environment
and this is really important as we
actually start working and creating
environments that are consistent because
we want to be able to make it so it's
really easy and stable for the
environment that you have within your
dev and ops environment now critical is
getting rid of that hypervisor element
it's just a lot of overhead so let's
have a look at a container as an example
so here we actually have a couple of
examples on the right hand side we have
different containers we have one
containers running apache tomcat and
with java a second container is running
sql server and microsoft.net environment
third container is running python with
mysql these are all running just fine
within the docker engine and sitting on
top of host os which could be linux it
really could be any host os within a
consistent infrastructure and you're
able to have a solution that can be
shared easily amongst your teams so
let's have a look at an example that
you'd have today if a company is doing a
traditional java application so you have
your developers working in jboss on his
system and he's coding away and he has
to get that code over to a test and now
what will happen is that tester will
then typically in your traditional
environment then have to install jboss
on their machine and get everything
running and cool and hopefully set up
identically to the developer chances are
they probably won't have it exactly the
same but they're trying to get as close
as possible and then at some point you
want to be able to test this within your
production environment so you send it
over to a system administrator who would
then also have to install jboss on their
environment as well yeah this just seems
to be a whole lot of duplication so why
go through the problem of installing
jboss three times and this is where it
things get really interesting because
the challenge you have today is that
it's very difficult to almost impossible
to have identical environments if you're
just installing software locally on
devices the developers probably got a
whole bunch of development software that
could be conflicting with the jboss
environment the tester has similar
testing software but probably doesn't
have all the development software and
certainly the system administrator won't
have all the tools that the developer
and tester have their own tools and so
what you want to be able to do is kind
of get away from the challenge you have
of having to do local installations on
three different computers and in
addition what you see is that this uses
up a lot of effort because when you're
having to install software over and over
again you just keep repeating doing
really basic foundational challenges so
this is where docker comes in and docker
is the tool that allows you to be able
to share environments from one group to
another group without having to install
software locally on a device you install
all of the code into your docker
container and simply share the container
so in this presentation we're going to
go through a few things we're going to
cover what docker actually is and then
we're going to dig into the actual
architecture of docker and kind of go
through what docket container is and how
to create a docker container and then
we'll go out through the benefits of
using docker containers and then the
commands and finalize everything out
with a brief demo so what is docker so
docker is as you'd expect because all
the software that we cover in this
series is an open source solution and it
is a container solution that allows you
to be able to containerize all of the
necessary files and applications needed
to run the solution that you're building
so you can share it from different
people in your team whether it's a
developer tester or system administrator
and this allows you to have a consistent
environment from one group to the next
so let's kind of dig into that
architecture so you understand why
docker runs effectively so the docker
architecture itself is built up of two
key elements there is the docker client
and then there is a rest api connection
to a docker daemon which actually hosts
the entire environment within the docker
host and the docker demon you have your
different containers and each one has a
link to a docker registry the docker
client itself is a rest service so as
you'd expect a rest api and that sends
command line to the docker daemon
through a terminal window or command
line interface window and we'll go
through some of these demos later on so
you can actually see how you can
actually interact with darker the docker
demo then checks the request against and
the docker components and then performs
the service that you're requesting now
the docker image itself all it really is
a collection of instructions used to
create a container and again this is
consistent with all the devops tools
that we have the devops tools that we're
looking to use throughout this series of
videos are all environments that can be
scripted and this is really important
because it allows you to be able to
duplicate and scale the environments
that you want to be able to build very
quickly and effectively the actual
container itself has all of the
applications and the dependencies of
those applications in one package you
kind of think of it as a really
effective and efficient zip file it's a
little bit more than that but it's one
file that actually has everything you
need to be able to run all of your
solutions the actual docker registry
itself is an environment for being able
to host and distribute different docker
images among your team so say for
instance you had a team of developers
that were working on multiple different
solutions so say you have a team of
developers and you have 50 developers
and they're working on five different
applications you can actually have the
applications themselves the containers
shared in the docker registry so each of
those teams at any time check out and
have the latest container of that latest
image of the code that you're working on
so let's dig into what actually is in a
container so the important part of a
docking container is that it has
everything you need to be able to run
the application it's like a virtualized
environment it has all your frameworks
and your libraries and it allows the
teams to be able to build out and run
exactly the right environment that the
developer intended what's interesting
though is the actual applications then
will run in isolation so they're not
impacting other applications that's
using dependencies on other libraries or
files outside of the container because
of the architecture it really uses a lot
less space and because it's using less
space it's a much more lightweight
architecture so the files the actual
folder itself is much smaller it's very
secure highly portable and the boot up
time is incredibly fast so let's
actually get into how you would actually
create a docker container so the docker
container itself is actually built
through command line and it's built of a
file and docker image so the actual
docker file is a text file that contains
all the instructions that you would need
to be able to create that docker image
and then we'll actually then create all
of the project code with inside of that
image then the image becomes the item
that you would share through the docker
registry you would then use the command
line and we'll do this later on select
docker run and then the name of the
image to be able to easily and
effectively run that image locally and
again once you've created the docker
image you can store that in the docker
registry making it available to anybody
within your network so something to bear
in mind is that docker itself has its
own registry called docker hub and that
is a public registry so you can actually
go out and see other dock images that
have been created and access those
images as your own company you may want
to have your own private repository so
you want to be able to go ahead and
either do that locally through your own
repository or you can actually get a
licensed version of docker hub where you
can actually then share those files
now something that's also very
interesting to know is that you can have
multiple versions of a docker image so
if you have a different version control
different release versions and you want
to be able to test and write code for
those different release versions because
you may have different setups you can
certainly do that within your docker
registry environment okay so let's go
ahead and we're going to create a docker
image using some of our basic docker
commands and so there are essentially
really you know kind of just two
commands that you're going to be looking
for one is the build command another one
is to actually put it into your registry
which is a push command so if you want
to get a image from a docker registry
then you want to use the pull command
and a pull command simply pulls the
image from the registry and in this
example using uh nginx as our registry
and we can actually then pull the image
down to our test environment on our
local machine so we're actually running
the container within our docker
application on a local machine we're
able to then have the image run exactly
as it would in production and then you
can actually use the run command to
actually use the docker image on your
local machine so just a you know a few
uh interesting tidbits about the docking
container once the container is created
a new layer is formed on top of the
docker image layers called the container
layout each container has a separate
read write container layer and any
changes made in that docking container
is then reflected upon the particular
container layer and if you want to
delete the container layer the container
layer also gets deleted as well so you
know why would using docker and
containers be of benefit to you well you
know some of the things that are useful
is that containers have no external
dependencies for the applications they
run once you actually have the container
running locally it has everything it
needs to be able to run the application
so there's no having to install
additional pieces of software such as
the example we gave with jboss at the
beginning of the presentation now the
containers are really lightweight so it
makes it very easy to share the
containers amongst your teams whether
it's a developer whether it's a tester
whether it's somebody on your operations
environment it's really easy to share
those containers amongst your entire
team different data volumes can be
easily reused and shared among
multiple containers and again this is
another big benefit and this is a
reflection of the lightweight nature of
your containers the container itself
also runs in isolation
which means that it is not impacted by
any dependencies you may have on your
own local environment so it's a
completely sandboxed environment so some
of the questions you might ask us you
know can you run multiple containers
together without the need to start each
one individually and you know what yes
you can with docker compose docking
compose allows you to run multiple
containers in a single service and again
this is a reflection on the lightweight
nature of containers within the docker
environment so we'll end our
presentation by looking at some of the
basic commands that you'd have within
docker so we have here on the left hand
side we have a doctor container and then
the command for each item we're actually
going to go ahead and use some of these
commands in the demo that we're going to
do after this presentation you'll see
that in a moment but just you know some
of the basic commands we have are
committing the docket image into the
container kill is a you know standard
kill command to you know terminate one
or more of the running containers so
they stop working then restart those
containers but suddenly you can look at
all the image all of the commands here
and try them out for yourself so we're
going to go ahead and start a demo of
how to use the basic commands to run
docker so to do this we're going to open
up terminal window or command line
deploying whether you're running linux
pc or mac and we're going to go ahead
and the first thing we want to do is see
what our docker image lists are so we
can go sudo docker images and this will
give us well first we'll enter in our
password so let's go enter that in and
this one that gives a list of our docker
images and here are the docker images
that have already been created in the
system and we can actually go ahead and
actually see the processes that are
actually running so i'm going to go
ahead and open up this window a little
bit more but this will show you the
actual processes and the containers that
we actually have and so on the far left
hand side you see under names we have
learn simply learn the underscore cool
these are all just different ones that
we've been working on so let's go ahead
and create a docker image so i'm going
to do sudo
docker
run
dash d
dash p
0.0.0.0
go on
80 colon 80
ubuntu and this will allow us to go
ahead and run
an ubuntu
image and this will run the latest image
and what we have here is a hash number
and this hash number is a unique name
that defines the container that we've
just created and we can go ahead and we
can check to make sure that the
container actually is present so we're
going to do
and this actually shows some there so
it's not in a running state right now
but that doesn't mean that we don't have
it so let's list out all the containers
that are both running and in the exit
state so let's do sucker ps dash a and
this lists all the containers that i
have running on my machine
and this shows all the ones that have
been in the running state and in the
exit stage and here we see one that we
just created about a minute ago and it's
called learn
and these are all running ubuntu and
this is the one that we had created just
a few seconds ago
let's open it up and
there we go so let's change that to that
new dock container to a running state so
scroll down and we're gonna type sudo
docker
run
dash
i t dash dash
name
my
[Music]
um
so this is going to be the new container
name it's going to be my docker so this
is how we name our docker environment
and we'll put in the image name which is
ubuntu
and dash bin dash bash
and it's now in our route and we'll exit
out of that
so now we're going to go ahead and start
the new my docker container so sudo
docker start
my
and we'll get the container image which
will be my docker
my docker
return and that started that docker
image
and let's go ahead and check against the
other running docker images to make sure
it's running correctly so sudo docker
ps
and there we are underneath name on the
right hand side you have to see my
docker along with the other docker
images that we created and it's been
running for 13 seconds
quite fast so we want to rename the
container let's use the command sudo
docker
rename we can take another docker image
this to scrub this one and we'll put it
in rename
and we'll rename
and put in the old container name which
is image and then we'll put in the new
container name and let's call it
purple
so now the container image that had
proved something called image is now
called purple
so do sudo docker
ps
to list all of our docker images
and we scroll up and there there we go
purple
how easy is that to rename an image
and we can go ahead and use this command
if we want to stop containers so we're
going to write sudo docker
stop
and then we have to put in the container
name
and we'll put in my docker the container
that we originally created
and that image has now stopped
and let's go ahead and prove that we're
going to list out all the docker images
and what you see is that it's not listed
in the active images it's uh not on the
list on the far right hand side
but if we go ahead and we can list out
all of the docker images so you actually
see it's still
there as an image is just
not in an active stage it's what's known
as in an exit state
so here we
go and there's my docker it's in an exit
state so that happened 27 seconds ago
so if we want to to remove a container
we can use the following command
so sudo docker
rm
will remove
my docker
and that will remove it from the exit
state
and we're going to go ahead and we're
going to double check that
and
yep
it's not not let's sit there under exit
state anymore
it's gone
and there we go
there that's where it used to be
all right
let's go back
so if we want to exit a container in the
running state so we do sudo kill and
then the name of the container
i think one of them is called yellow
let's just check and see if that's gonna
kill it
oops no i guess we don't have one called
yellow so let's find out name of
container that we actually have
so pseudo docker
kill
oh we're gonna list out the ones that
are running oh okay there we go now
yellow isn't in that list so let's take
i know let's take simply learn and so we
can actually go ahead and let's write
sudo docker
kill simply learn
and that will actually kill an active
docker container
boom there we go
and we list out all the active
containers you can actually see now
that's the simply learn container is not
active anymore
and these are all the basic commands for
docker container
hey guys welcome back to simply learn
did you know before docker and
containers were introduced companies had
been deploying their software either on
a bare metal or in a virtual machine
but they had been facing a lot of
challenges in managing orchestration of
services instant deployment of services
on different platforms and maintaining
multi-host applications
all these issues were solved with the
help of docker and its containers
in this docker and container tutorial
session we will give you the conceptual
exposure to docker and its containers
we will focus on why is docker container
essential
what is docker container what exactly is
virtualization
then few significant differences between
vm and docker container
then some of the benefits of using a
docker container
architecture of docker
next how docker container works in the
docker ecosystem
and finally a step-by-step process in
how to create docker containers
let's begin with the first topic do you
know why docker containers are essential
in an organization
consider an example where a company
develops a code on oracle weblogic
software
in the company a developer installs
oracle weblogic software on his computer
system
once the application is developed he
shares it with the other team for
testing the code
now the tester repeats the weblogic
installation process which was done by
the developer earlier on his system
later the same application file is
shared with the production team
to host the application the system admin
must install oracle weblogic on his
system
let me ask you an important question
here
have you noticed that the same weblogic
installation process was done thrice
but what could be the reason behind it
due to the difference in computer
environments web logic doesn't work on
the other systems so installation is
done separately on three different
computers
but this process of installing the same
software on different systems consume a
lot of time and effort
in order to avoid these problems docker
containers were introduced before we
start with the concept of docker
containers let me explain you what a
docker is
docker is an open source platform that
helps a user package and application and
its dependencies into a docker container
to develop and deploy software docker
provides suitable frameworks for
different applications
since every application has a framework
with an appropriate version this space
also can be utilized for a new software
application along with its required
framework
as a result docker makes more efficient
use of system resources
containerization includes all
dependencies frameworks libraries etc
required to run an application in an
efficient and bug-free manner
with docker containers applications can
work efficiently in different computer
environments
after this let's talk about the benefits
the benefits of docker containers show
up in many places
containers are widely used because of
their services
since it's lightweight it can be easily
deployed and executed on other computer
environments regardless of their host
operating system or configurations
containers take up less disk space and
relatively faster in executing
applications
containers run applications in isolation
and also share the operating system
kernel with other containers
by default containers are entirely
secure
container policies ensure all
applications are highly secure including
the docker infrastructure containers are
highly portable and can run anywhere
across the docker ecosystem
multiple software can be encapsulated in
a single container and can be easily
deployed to different platforms
as soon as a container is created it can
be deployed into any other system where
docker is already installed
on that system the application will
perform exactly as it did in the
previous environment
containers take less boot up time
these containers save time in the
deployment process of an application
here comes the next important concept
virtualization
virtualization is the technology of
running a virtual instance of a computer
system or running a virtual version of a
computer resource like hardware software
storage devices and computer network
resources on the cloud
a virtual machine is an isolated
computing environment that allows
developers to use an operating system
via a pc or computer system
let's now talk about some of the
significant benefits of using docker
containers
the first benefit is the lack of
external dependency
containers have no external dependency
for applications to run
containers will just be used to host and
run the applications
as containers are lightweight they are
quickly shipped to other computers and
executed in different computer
environments regardless of their host
operating systems
containers are lightweight they share a
kernel across containers and therefore
use less memory space the next benefit
is the volume
volumes are also a convenient way to
share data within the docker ecosystem
volumes can be more safely shared among
other containers
and the last one is isolation
containers run application in isolation
and share the operating system kernel
with other containers
in containers the host operating system
provides isolation along with the
applications microservices can also be
more easily isolated
next comes the most important topic of
the session that is
containerization versus virtualization
containerization and virtualization are
two different ways to deploy
applications and microservices in a
computer environment
in vms a hypervisor is a firmware layer
that enables multiple operating system
to run side by side
a virtual machine has unstable
performance as multiple running vms run
simultaneously on the same machine
also the efficiency of hypervisors is
not as good as that of the host
operating system
due to the extra layer in vm an
application takes quite a long time to
start
as you can see there are two
architectures on the screen
on the left hand side is vm and on the
right hand side is the docker
on the left hand side as you see there
is one host operating system a
hypervisor and guest operating system
shared by all containers along with
their dependencies
in vm guest operating system occupies
more space and leads to unstable
performance guest operating system makes
virtual machines less efficient than the
physical machines
guest operating system makes a vm slow
because they access the hardware
indirectly
on the other hand docker is efficient
unlike vms docker doesn't have a
hypervisor or guest operating system
docker consists of containers
these containers are efficient and are
easily portable across different
platforms
in vms the hypervisor has a scalability
issue the hypervisor creates a security
risk as well
well
do you know that according to vitana the
chances of experiencing a data breach
while using virtualization are high
well that could lead to a major problem
for companies who are still using
virtual
machines next
let's have a closer look at the docker
containers
in case you are unsure what kind of
applications can be added to a container
then look on the right hand side
a container can package apache tomcat
and its dependency that is java
programming language in a single file
later a user can ship the container to
another computer environment and run the
code without any issue it's usually
challenging to understand the
differences between container and vm
so let me explain to you the differences
in layman terms
as shown the virtual machine is compared
to a bunglock and the container is
considered as an apartment
in a bungalow amenities like water lift
roof etc cannot be shared with the
neighbors
likewise vm is less efficient it doesn't
share its resources with other
applications
on the other hand containers share their
amenities binaries and libraries with
the neighboring containers just like a
person who resides in an apartment
the bang law is owned by a single person
it cannot have tenants
likewise virtual machines cannot run
multiple applications
on the other side docker runs multiple
containers just like numerous tenants
reside in a single building
next let's look at the table in which we
have made a direct comparison between
virtual machines and containers
in docker containers data volumes can be
shared and reused among multiple
containers
either docker cli or docker api manages
the volumes
also the volume drivers give the
facility of storing volumes on remote
hosts or cloud providers
vm is a container based model it
utilizes user space along with the
kernel space of an operating system
so data volumes cannot be shared
containers have a better performance as
they are hosted in a single docker
engine
docker provides the most substantial
default isolation capabilities among the
other configuration tools making the
performance better
virtual machines run multiple vms at a
time which leads to unstable performance
docker is much more efficient than
hypervisors
docker enables developers to wrap
ship quickly and run applications as a
lightweight and portable container
on the other hand virtual machines are
less efficient
docker containers can run multiple
containers on a system but virtual
machine can run only a limited number of
vms on a system
multiple software can be encapsulated in
a single container and can be easily
deployed to different platforms
containers are easily portable across
other platforms but virtual machines
have compatibility issues while porting
others across different platforms
moving on to the next one
let's have a look at the architecture of
docker a docker or docker engine
consists of two major components
docker client and docker daemon
these two components are connected to
each other with the help of the rest api
now let's take a look at the
architecture
a docker client has no components but a
docker daemon consists of a docker host
docker daemon docker registry and docker
images
docker client is a service that uses
rest api to send commands to docker
demon through cli commands
rest api is a primary mode of
communication between docker client and
docker daemon
docker engine or docker is a client
server application that builds and
executes containers using docker
components
docker daemon checks the client's
request and communicates with the docker
components to perform a service
docker engine or docker is a client
server application that builds and
executes containers using docker
components
docker image is also one of the
essential components of docker
a docker image is a file of instructions
that are used to create containers
a docker image is built using a file
called dockerfile
a docker image is a template of
instructions that is used to create
containers
coming to containers
a docker container is a portable
executable package that includes
applications and their dependencies
docker containers are lightweight
because they do not require an extra
layer of a hypervisor and run directly
on the host operating system
there is a service in docker called
docker compose
a docker compose is used for running
multiple containers as a single service
in compose service each container runs
in isolation but can interact with each
other with no limitations
talking about docker registry it is a
service used for hosting and
distributing docker images among users
docker registry is a service to host and
distribute docker images among users
let's move on and understand how to
create a docker container
first ensure to set up your development
environment then you can begin to
develop containerized applications
for that you need to create a docker
image a docker image can be created
using a dockerfile a docker image is
created using a build command
you must build a docker image that
contains the code of what your
application needs to run
in simple terms our docker image
contains all the project's code
with docker image you can run the code
to develop docker containers
once the docker image is created ensure
to store it in the docker registry using
the docker push command
once a docker image is created you can
either store it in a docker hub or in a
repository
docker also has its default registry
called docker hub
there are multiple docker images
available in the registry and all can be
retrieved through the dockable command
as soon as a docker image is retrieved
from the docker registry you can build
new containers
moving on to the next one let's
understand how docker containers work
in docker a dockerfile is used to build
the image using the build command and
that image is stored in the registry
using the push command
when you run the pull command docker
image is retrieved from the registry
while a single container is built using
docker image through the run command
did you know that a new layer is formed
on top of the docker image layers called
the container layer when a container is
created
this new layer consists of the
application and its dependencies
in docker each container has a separate
reader write container layer
any modifications done in a docker
container are reflected upon the
container layer
suppose a container is deleted the
container layer also gets permanently
deleted
this was the simple functionality of
docker and containers
welcome everyone to this topic on docker
files here in this one we are going to
see that how we can make use of the
docker files to prepare a docker image
and uh using which we can create a
docker container so uh we are going to
talk about what is the docker what is a
docker file what is this index of docker
file and how to build a custom docker
image with the help of docker file and
in the end we are going to see a
particular demo related to the docker
files over here now let's talk about
what is the docker now docker is in
configuration management tool which we
are pretty much using to prepare the
automation of the deployment of the
software of the applications now in this
case we make use of the docker
containers using which we can host our
applications and within this docker
containers we are typically hosting both
the application source code and the
defenses all together so both the links
are getting packaged all together into a
single unit called docker containers and
getting hosted onto the server
these containers are very efficient in
work because they are not taking that
much utilization and resources and at
the same time they can be shared across
different environments also so the same
container can be easily deployed across
different different
uh environments as such
now it helps us to maintain the isolated
application it uh helps in having a high
productivity there and it also you know
helps us to see to resolve all the
problems which is related to the uh
dependencies for your software because
we are packaging up both the source code
and the dependencies all together in the
single unit in the single entity and
that's where you will be able to get a
particular final solution called as in
docker container over here so docker
container is in complete package using
which you can have like both the
applications and the dependencies bundle
up together into a single entity and
that's where we call it as in docker
container
now what exactly is an uh docker that uh
you know let's see a particular
difference between the virtual machine
and the docker here now if you see on
the left hand side we have the host
operating system uh which is available
there let's say i have a laptop in this
one we have a windows 10
now we have a hypervisor on top of that
like how hypervisor is in software which
is used to manage the virtual machines
it's a software which is available there
which takes up all the requests from the
virtual machines process it and then
give the response back so hypervisor
acts like a medium between the virtual
machine and the host operating system
resources so
it's going to give that a particular
virtual environment to the virtual
machines and then we have a virtual
machines where in fact a guest operating
system is there then application
binaries then the application is hosted
so this guest operating system actually
takes up a lot of utilization
and this was the old mechanism where we
used to uh
follow this mechanism for hosting our
applications
so all the applications are pretty much
getting deployed in the same manner on
the form of the virtual machines here
right now
if you talk about the new method which
we are talking about right now is in
docker so here we have host operating
system but instead of hypervisor we have
now the docker engine which is available
there now this docker engine is
something which is making sure working
in the same way that how the hypervisor
is behaving but it's much lighter as
compared to the hypervisor so docker is
very lightweight as compared to the
hypervisor here and here we don't have
the concept of
the heavy duty guest operating system
over here so the guest operating systems
which we are using in case of docker
containers are very small in size
the size of guest operating systems is
is in gb's in case of virtual machine
but in case of docker containers it's
pretty much available in the mb size
which is there so the size of the guest
operating system in case of the virtual
machine is really small as compared to
the virtual machine
and that's a biggest benefit because
again it will
help the containers to have a low
utilization low consumptions and that
improves the overall performance of the
overall mechanisms and how exactly the
new method of application deployment
really helps us to go for an a
particular advanced mechanism so that
can brings on a very good and the
efficient
uh
way of doing the deployment of the
applications
now let's talk about what exactly is in
docker file here now uh docker file is a
concept which is being used as in build
script so it's being used so that we can
have a build a script there
so this will definitely helps uh to see
that how we can go for a build of a
docker image a custom docker image
now when we are using the docker file uh
concept so it really helps to uh prepare
a kind of docker image
so doc image is the end result when you
are going for the mechanism when you're
going for the docker5 build up oh yeah
so dockerfile is a build script which is
available for preparing the custom
docker containers because not every
docker image is available on docker hub
so some containers you have to use some
images you have to use to work on that
part
now docker file is a very simple
straightforward text file which is
available there and it's basically used
to build up custom docker images so
docker file is basically used to prepare
a once so when you're running the docker
build so it's actually going to build up
a particular custom docker image and
that will be given to you
so docker uh image is the whole build
process which is being done
so it's a custom
process which is available and being
done over here in this case
so you got a docker file you run the
docker build command and that's how you
will be able to get a docker image so
whatever the steps you are having in the
docker file that will be processed one
by one and as a end result you will be
able to get a full flesh docker image
over here in this case
right now let's talk about the syntax of
the docker file so docker file is equal
to commands commands and the arguments
so whatever the things you want to put
up so in the docker file you can do that
and as a part of the execution so you
will be able to get a particular end
result
now it's a kind of a mechanism where we
feel that how the execution and the
modifications can be done so uh the uh
comments which we are trying to do over
here is that you know we can put up the
whatever the comments we want to put in
the case of docker files we can do that
comments is a standard process in uh
preparing any particular file or any
kind of code because it helps us to
understand that for what reason we are
preparing that particular line then uh
we have the uh particular run statements
the commands are there so you can see
that we are running a particular command
called eco so using the run attribute we
are basically going ahead and running a
particular command into our system as
part of our docker file over here
now how to build up the docker images
using the docker file so um you know
docker file is uh just a template which
is available there where we are putting
up that what are the different steps we
want to follow and these steps when we
follow one by one step by step so that's
where we will be able to get a
particular final docker container over
here so docker image is getting
converted as a docker container and we
are getting a docker container as an end
result now um docker file is being built
up and uh stored in the version control
system and uh this particular docker
files when we are processing so it
prepares a respective a specific
image layer over here and this image
layer is something which is uh
benefiting us that how the executions
can be done and how we can manage on
that part
so
that really helps us to see that how the
executions and the things can be managed
and that can help us to see that how the
management of the things can be
performed as such
so uh docker file is a very good concept
which is there using which you can
prepare any kind of custom docker image
and it can be very easily handled also
and it's in fully automated mechanism
you can use it inside the cicd pipelines
for automating the docker images
right now it's uh docker image is a
layer by layer mechanism which is there
in which we have multiple layers each
and every layer we are doing some
specific
entries some specific tasks or some you
know changes we are trying to deploy in
part of our these layers right so uh
you can use the uh particular docker
build command to perform the executions
and you will be able to get any
particular response an output will be
given back to you so docker file is
basically helping you to see that how
the executions can be done and you will
be able to get an end result over here
so the docker image is the final result
which we are getting when we are talking
about the docker file here
right so these are all read only formats
which are available you cannot modify
these directly but yes with the help of
docker file you can do whatever the
changes you want to deploy on these
docker images
right so uh this is a small example
where we are using a base image as an 1
to 18.04 so we are using the from
attribute to specify that yes we are
going to use the ubuntu 18.04 here then
we are pulling our the file into the uh
directory we are transferring a
particular file inside the docker
container and then we are running our
make command and then cmd attribute is
there using which we can run the command
on the runtime on the docker container
so these are a very a basic example but
eventually when we are done with this
darker image we will be able to get a
four layer uh darker image over here
because there are four steps and then
hence it will be providing you a
particular four layers in your final
docker image over here so layer by layer
these changes will be done during the
build process and in fact using the
docker history command you can see that
layers these layers information also
right so layer one is ubuntu 18 1 0 4
layer 2 is pull and uh the third layer
is there where we can run the uh make
command to you know run this file which
we have pulled on and then the finally
the last one is there where we are
running like using the cmd parent so the
difference between run and cmd is that
cmd will run only when you run a docker
container so run attribute will be
executed during the docker build part so
this is a pretty much is a way that how
we can go for the execution of a docker
file and how you know we can go for the
uh build up of a custom docker image
over here so these are the for some
couple of attributes which we are using
in the docker file here
right now let's talk about the entry
point over here now entry point allows
you to specify a command along with the
parameters right so uh let's say that
you want to run a particular command uh
over here in the docker container so
entry point is something which you can
use to refer to that so application is
the command which you're trying to run
and then you can give some arguments to
that and argument one is what you're
trying to run over here so entry point
is very important because that
eventually helps to see that how the
executions can be done and the
implementations will be done over here
in this case
right so you can see like you can run a
command called eco and then you can use
the parameters also it's not like only
the commands can be used but you can in
fact use the arguments also now add is
an attribute which is available in the
docker file which is primarily used to
see to uh transfer the files from the
host machine inside the docker image
now let's see that you are trying to
prepare your own custom docker image
apart from the dependencies you need the
source code also right so the source
code needs to be transferred inside the
docker image and for that reason we can
use the add attribute so add attribute
requires a source and destination source
will always be the path on which on the
destin on the host machine the files are
present so we can give that
and destination is the folder which is
available inside the
particular docker container where we
want to store the files so you can use
the example over here just like this you
can use and you can give two entries one
is the source one is the destination and
once that is done so you will be able to
see your files being stored up in the
destination directory once the final
docker image is prepared
then we have enb attribute uh now enb is
something which is used to set up some
environment variables which is required
of course for the docker image for the
application which is running inside the
docker image now environment variables
are something which you can hardcore
during the docker build one but using
the when you are running like when
you're creating the docker container at
that time also you can overwrite the
these environment variables so
environment variables are very important
because uh first during the build
process you can hard code some values
but if you really want to change them
during the runtime that also is being
supported by the environment variables
so
most of the times we use it as an kind
of a keep value pair just like in in
linux we use uh we used to set up a
particular environment variable so the
key value pair is being used in case of
enb attribute
maintainer is there where we can
describe that what is the details about
the author these are the fields which is
available in the top so where we can
give the the author name and the author
you know details like email id and all
so that we know that who is the person
who is maintaining this particular file
and we can reach out to them in case any
issues are there for the docker files am
right so that is what we have here in
this one so now we are going to see that
how we can go for a small demo and
docker file and we can go for the
implementation of this particular docker
file and prepare a custom docker image
so let's just wait on that part
so let's see some demo here now in this
one we have got two examples one is the
python one is the notice one so first of
all what we need to do is that we need
to process the python one here so this
is the sample docker file which we have
got here for the python now all this one
requires a python file which is already
present on the server and we are going
to transfer we are going to copy this
content over here that this is the
specific docker file content which is
available to us and all we need to do is
that we need to put this content across
the server so that we will be able to
build our custom docker image so let's
go back to the server so here we have
already got the python file which is
present so we have to create a docker
file here which will have the steps
related to the docker image preparation
over here so we will be including some
steps over here that these are the
different steps we want to configure we
want to set up over here in this one so
python 3.6.4 is the version of the
python which we want to configure and
then we are going to transfer some files
into slash app we are also setting up
the working directory as slash app and
ultimately we are running a command
called pip install flask to do the
installation of flash package and then
we are starting the uh specific
applications on that part so i'm going
to save this file and once i save this
file so all we need to do is that we
need to create a custom docker image
right so right now there is no image
which is available over here and it's in
complete md instance so i'm going to run
a command called docker
build
hyphen t
python hyphen am dot so docker build is
the typical command but hyphen t is for
the tag that what kind of docker image
you want to build and then we are giving
a image name and then we are specifying
dot over there now once we are done with
that so it will pick up all the things
one by one the basic docker image is
being pulled down
then some sequence of steps is being
executed so it's a step-by-step process
which is happening over here in this
case and we are then transferring some
files in the slash app and then
ultimately we are going for the pip
install flask so it's installing those
packages and at the end the final docker
image will be prepared and will be given
back to us so we will be able to get
this uh docker images over here when we
run that command we will be able to find
out that we got our custom docker image
also available and as you can see that
the basic darker image is also available
in this one but yes we have added up
like around 10 mb of work we have added
on top of this python uh base docker
image here so that's how we are able to
do the processing over here in this case
in this setup so that's what we uh can
do to prepare a custom environment of
python with the help of the docker file
here now let's see that we will be uh
proceeding on with the node.js to see
that if the node.js kind of setup also
can be done now for node.js again of
course we got uh the uh specific docker
file which is present so we can process
that but let's create a new folder over
there so i'm going to create for a new
node.js folder so that we can create the
work all together in this one so i'm
going to run a command called npm minute
which is the command to initialize any
empty project in case of node now you
can typically bring down some real code
also or you can say that i want to
process
an empty a project so you can give the
configurations you can give the custom
names but i want to process with these
as default name itself so ultimately
it's going to create an entries like uh
you will be able to see like all these
uh values which we are not providing
these standards value will be picked up
for the uh specific code and at the end
you will be able to get a package.json
file created over here in this one now
you can actually bring down the steps
that how you can perform or you can
build up a custom node.js based docker
image now these docker files is giving
you the capability that you can convert
a full-fledged application which is
deployable on the virtual machine you
can actually convert them in the format
of the docker containers over here in
this one so that's what we are going to
get over here with this uh particular
setup are these mechanisms
so let's go back to the document and see
that what exactly we can copy the docker
file
so we have got this a docker file over
here so all we can do is that we can
copy this one so once we copy this uh
specific file here so all we can do is
that we can transfer uh these uh files
into the onto the server we can convert
it into the docker file there so that we
will be able to set up the
configurations and we can perform the
setup around that so docker file is
again we want to create and we want to
set up on that here so let's go back to
the server
so here we want to create a docker file
and we want to set up the files inside
that these are the different files which
is being available which is being
configured over here in this one so we
are running like node server.js which is
a master file so we are doing an expose
of 8080 then of course we have copy
commands which is there then npm install
command is there and then package.json
file is also there now what you need to
really do is that you need to go for a
server.js file which is available in
which you can configure that how the
setup needs to be done and how the
configurations should be performed
because that's a command that's a script
which is going to be executed within the
container so let's copy the content now
i'm going to copy this content over here
which is like a sample node.js code
which is available so i'm just copy this
one and transfer it to the server
so server.js file we have to create here
just like we did in case of the python
because this is the source we want to
transfer inside the docker container
so this is what we have got now i'm
going to uh transfer like uh i want to
change this port value from 5000 to 8080
because that's what it's configured in
the docker file of course you can
configure 5000 also depending on your
requirement you can do that
configurations
now you have got these two files over
here in this one so all you need to do
is that you need to run like docker
build
hyphen t node.js hyphen app and dot so
it will automatically pick up like what
exactly it will uh you know go for the
node.js basic docker image over here so
that will be processed over here in this
one so step by step it will be able to
do the configurations
so first of all it will download the
basic docker image which is um quite uh
more in size over here in this one once
it's downloaded onto your system then it
will proceed further with the build
activity on uh processing the docker
file performing the execution so all
that stuff will be performed with this
help of this docker build process over
here so it's going to process it one by
one in this one
and it's going to the next step where
it's transferring some of the files like
creating some working directory
transferring the files uh putting up
there and running the npm install
command
and uh then ultimately it will expose
the port and then it will have the
cmd attribute configured over there so
this is basically typically trying to
portrait it how a particular docker
image can be built up and of course once
the build is successful you can validate
it with the help of docker images here
so this is the app docker image which
has been prepared of 911 mb and uh we
have got it like a final package where
the runtime is also there and the code
base is also available now you can
pretty much
experience it like with other actual
source codes like you can generate the
download some pre-configured node.js
websites or the source codes here and
you can try to run them onto the docker
container so that you can get the full
uh the complete idea about that how it
goes on but right now the uh these are
the basic docker image which you can
prepare and you can build up over here
in this one so that's how it really
works on for you today we're going to
dig into docker swarm so what we're
going to do in this session is we're
going to go through what a docker and
docker container is and why you'd want
to use it we'll then break out what are
the characteristics and structure of a
docker swarm environment and then
finally we'll go through and do a demo
using actual code in the command line
interface to actually run and build out
the main functions and commands that you
would use for a docker swarm environment
so with that said let's get started so
docker is a tool that we actually use to
help automate applications in our
environment so that we have a consistent
way that we're actually building and
testing and validating codes that's been
created think of it as a virtualization
but much more sophisticated and
efficient way of doing virtualization
the thing that you have that's a huge
advantage when you're working with
docker is that it's a very lightweight
software package it allows you to have
all of the tools needed for actually
running the code without having to have
the significant overhead that you would
normally have with virtualization so one
of the characteristics you have with
docker is that you can actually run
multiple docker environments in the same
host environment and for you to be able
to do this we had to figure out how this
would actually run and so to actually do
this we actually do what's called a
docker swarm and a docker swarm is an
environment where you can actually have
multiple docker images running on the
same host operating system so you can
have running in each of those docker
containers different solutions so let's
dig into what a docker swarm is so a
docker swarm is essentially a tool that
allows you to very easily create and
schedule
multiple docker nodes so really two or
more docker nodes and you can have quite
a large number of docker nodes in a
single swarm
each node itself is actually a docker
daemon and that demon is able to
interact with the docker api and have
all the benefits of being a full docker
environment one of the other advantages
you have is that the each dot container
within the swarm can then be deployed
and managed but as a node in that entire
clustered environment so what we have
here is a breakdown of the five key
elements within a docker environment you
have the docker container you have the
daemon the docker images and the docker
client and docker registry so the docker
demon itself is what does all the work
interacting with the actual host
operating system to be able to manage
the docker containers so if we look here
here we have set up an environment where
we have three docket containers being
run with docker and what we want to be
able to do is be able to interact with
the environment because what would
happen if we actually have something
changed in our environment so we have
the environment set up as a docker swarm
and one of our containers fails what
we're able to do is use the swarm to be
able to correct that failure so the
docker swarm manager is able to come in
and reschedule containers and as you
would imagine the actual swarm note has
full backups and full redundancy for any
kind of failures that would happen and
we would do all of this work through
command line interface so let's go
through some of the features that you
have within the actual docker swarm
itself so
a key feature for docker swarm is that
it is fully decentralized which means
that it makes it very easy for teams to
be able to access and manage the
environment as you would expect as well
is that the communication that happens
between the manager and client nodes
within the swarm is highly secure and of
course this is really just a fundamental
that you should have for any kind of
solution but it is good to know that
docker swarm has that built in there is
also auto load balancing within your
environment you can actually script that
into how you write out and structure
your swarm environment and that load
balancing then also allows you to then
convert that swarm environment into a
highly scalable infrastructure
and then rollback task allows you to be
able to roll back environments to
previous safe environments so say
something does get pushed out and
something breaks you're able to
immediately roll back into a safe
environment so each of the containers
are pushed out and and are controlled
using services and they actually happen
to be breast services which make it very
easy for you to be able to integrate
within your environment
and each of the different services
contains a group of containers of the
same image now by having this structure
it allows you to be able to scale your
application appropriate to the demands
on your service so if you have a service
that needs to have a significantly
larger number of services for it to run
you can actually scale that
appropriately and they can be either geo
or demand based one of the requirements
for setting up a docker swarm is you
must have at least one node deployed so
the way that the architecture is set up
is that you have a manager node and a
client node and there must be one of
each for the entire environment to be
able to work effectively so you know
here we are just jumping ahead of sales
a little bit we have two types of nodes
in the docker swan we have the manager
node and we have the worker node which
is the client that does the actual
execution of the tasks the manager node
very similar to other systems that we've
talked about on simplylearn allows you
to actually control and manage the
actual tasks that are being executed by
the worker nodes and the working nodes
as you can imagine and then actually
execute the instructions that the
manager are sending out to it so here we
have a situation where we can illustrate
what would happen with a manager node
sending out commands to different worker
nodes the manager is fully aware of the
status of the entire swarm environment
at all times this is because of the
two-way secure communication that's
going from the manager to the worker
environment the workers as you'd expect
are accepting tasks that are being sent
from the manager so the manager sends
out a task saying that you need to be
running as a my sequel environment then
the worker node will then convert to my
sequel environment and all of these
environments are scripted and controlled
by you as the manager the actual worker
nodes themselves actually have a client
agent and that client will then
communicate all different states of the
infrastructure back to the manager so
that any time the manager node is in
full control of the entire swarm the
manager is the controller of this
environment and so you always want to be
able to ensure that the manager has full
access to all the work that's happening
within the swarm and this allows you as
the manager to be able to control your
swarm and very quickly be able to react
to any changes without having to rely on
manual installations of software and
hardware and as we covered earlier on
there is a rest api that uses the
communication over http from the manager
to the worker node it's interesting to
note that it is a rest api because if
you wanted to you could actually
integrate that api into custom
applications and even then create
automated docker images to be created on
demand from third-party solutions that
you may want to create so one of the
things that's a really a big advantage
with having a swarm is that once you've
actually created the swarm any of the
services um that you create can be
accessed by any node of the same cluster
one of the things you do have to do
though is you have to specify what
container image that you're gonna use
when you're creating a new service and
you can do that either through a
centralized docker hub environment or
through your own private docker hub
environment one of the things that's
interesting is that you can set up
commands and services to be either
global or replicated a global service
will allow you to run a service
consistently on every node within the
swarm whereas a replicated service will
only push out functionality and tasks to
specific worker nodes within a swarm so
you may be asking yourself hey isn't a
service and task the same thing no
they're they're kind of not in the
docker world and the difference is is a
service is a description of a task for
the state whereas the actual task is the
work that needs to get done and that's
the differentiator here so what you can
do as a docker user is you actually
create services and then you can then
define when you want them to start as
tasks now what's interesting is that
when you do assign a task to a node that
same task cannot be assigned to another
node also what's interesting is that you
can actually have multiple managers
within a docker swarm environment if you
do however go down this path you have to
elect one manager to be the primary
manager and the other managers to be
secondary managers in many ways those
secondary managers are really
similar in concept to worker nodes in
which they have the capability of a
manager but they are dependent on that
single primary manager to be able to
provide the right instructions and for
services and tasks to the entire swarm
environment so if we kind of recap some
of these we have a command line
interface which allows us to create and
connect via apis and that those apis
that we connect to in our small
environment allows us to do
orchestration via tasks and services the
task allocation allows us to allocate
work to tasks via their ip address which
allows them to execute them on the work
and then the worker nodes themselves
have to connect to the manager node to
be able to check for when tasks come in
so that they are keeping a consistent
communication back and forth across the
entire swarm and then the final stage is
to actually execute the tasks that have
been assigned from the manager node to
the work node so that you have a
successful execution of the solution
you're looking to build all right so
with that said let's go ahead and we're
going to do a demo
so we're going to go ahead and do a demo
and showing how you can run docker swarm
for this you'll need to have both a
virtual environment running your manager
and your working environment so here we
have our worker and
here we have our manager so we're just
going to open up terminal window and
we're going to go into the manager for
terminal window
so the following command here is used to
initialize docker swarm which is going
to type this in so sudo docker swarm
init
and we push the ip address for the
network we're connecting to
and we'll put in our password
and here we have now connected
and this is our manager node and what we
want to be able to highlight is the
specific token which identifies the
docker swarm environment and this is our
token right here so i'm going to copy
that
because we'll need to use that for our
worker environment so here we are in the
work environment and we'll use the token
that we just copied um as a way to be
able to connect to the manager and
connect to the docker swarm environment
and so sudo
i'll paste in the docker swarm and we'll
join that
and now here we shows that we have
joined the swarm environment as a worker
and now
we're in the manager we can actually
show that we actually have
that worker in the environment so
there's docker node ls to list out all
of the items in that environment
sorry we actually did that in the wrong
area so we're on the right pseudo docker
node ls to list out
all the nodes in the swarm
and there you are you see we've actually
connected the
worker to the manager node and both
are active and the manager is the leader
and the worker virtualbox is in the
swarm
okay we're going to go ahead and create
a new service so docker swan create and
we're going to just change the name
to hello world for the new service and
we use the alpine image from docker.com
takes just a moment for it to run
there we go
and there we go services converged
so what we have now is a new service
that has been created
let's go ahead and we'll list out the
services
and here we have our new hello world
service
and we go ahead and check the duck in
containers and we're going to do
docker ps and
here's our alpine it's running the
latest image
and that's the docker container id
and we can see that it was just updated
and so we're going to do is use the same
command in the worker node
and make sure everything is working over
there
so go over to our worker
paste that in
so what we see here is there is no image
or container created because it's not in
the worker node it would be in the
manager node
so we can go ahead and create the new
service
and we'll make the mode global and that
way the service is available across all
of the swarm
so we're just going to execute that work
takes a moment
and
there we are
done work has been completed and we have
the two different ids which shows that
two different services are running and
if we go back to the worker mode and we
run sudo docker ps again and there we
are now we see that we have the hello
world new virtual environment has been
added with the image of alpine and we
also have the new token id for that
if we want to kill a node from the swamp
we can use the following command which
is pseudo docker leave dash dash force
and that will force the nodes to leave
the swarm today we're going to cover
docker compose so in this session what
we're going to do is we're going to go
through what docker is and then by
extension what docker compose is and how
it improves the performance of docker
what the benefits of working with docker
compose is we are going to cover as well
what the difference between docker
compose and docker swarm is because the
two products are similar but they have
two different types of job and at the
end of this presentation we'll take you
through some basic commands that allow
you to get up and running working with
docker and docker compose finally after
this presentation we'll do a brief demo
that allows you to get up and running
using some of these commands to do your
own docker compose environment so let's
get started with docker compose so first
of all we have to kind of cover what
docker is so docker has come as an
evolution of technologies that started
with virtual machines vm machines and a
vm machine allowed you to run a complete
operating system and complete operating
system and its environment on your own
computer in your own operating system
without it interfering the problem was
is that it's very heavy and complex and
in contrast docker is a much more
lightweight and more flexible
environment that you can automate with
scripts so we have to remember that the
container itself is just software and it
has dependencies that run within that
application that are managed by docker
so we have a look at the way docker is
broken out first of all we have the
docker image and we have the docker
image created by a docker file and the
docker file is a text-based script and
that text file within docker file
actually has all the commands that allow
you to run the appropriate technologies
within the docker image so the docker
image allows you to be able to have a
wide group of people and consistently
run the same environment and if you want
to be able to share that docker image
effectively you would do so by uploading
to docker hub and docker hub can be
available either publicly uh through the
the public docker hub website or you can
actually set up your own private
enterprise docker hub to share your own
images across your own network and then
from docker hub people can then pull
their own docker image and build new
containers that are consistent on the
original docker container that you
created so it's a great way of being
able to have your entire team scale up
easily and effectively so one of the
questions that will come up though is
what if you want to use two containers
in a single service and an example this
might be like a web server that is using
a database but the database may be in
one container and the web server may be
in another container which is very
typical for your own web and database
infrastructure so very similar scenario
but how would you do this with doc app
so by using just docker itself it's
actually very difficult to do this you
can do it but it's just very time
consuming and just not a very good use
of your productivity but with docker
compose you can actually do the whole
process quite quickly and easily and
hence the reason why we have docker
compose to allow you to have two or more
docker containers running in the same
environment being able to communicate as
if they were running in a production
environment so let's dig into what
docker compose is so let's consider a
scenario that you'd have today so
mintra is a
fashion website similar to amazon and
you'd go to mentor with your web browser
and
on that website you would go through a
number of activities such as logging
into your account browsing a catalog
you'd have your checkout application
server and you go through the
process of building out an application
behind each of these services are
different products such as you know have
an account database you'd have a product
database different checkout processes
and these would all be run behind the
scenes and each of these can be
considered a micro service so the more
microservices you build into your
environment the more complexity you're
adding and the more of value it would be
to have each of these services in their
own container but as a developer you
want to be able to jump from one
container to another container so your
login account can then be passed on to
your product catalog and then be able to
move through the whole process so the
environment that you would see today
would be small like what we're showing
right now where you'd have your server
and your database and you may have a
server running on apache tomcat or a sql
server you'd have different databases
and you'd want to be able to have each
of those in their own containerized
environment so the way that duck compose
runs is that it works as a single
service so you have the docker compose
running multiple containers but the
perception is of a single service run
the thing that's great though is that
each of those containers will run in
their in isolation and but they can
interact with each other so unlike a
normal docker environment where you have
multiple docker images running
completely in isolation of each other
these are images that will run in
isolation but can interact with each
other the docker compose files are very
easy to write they're all written with a
scripting language called yaml and yaml
is an xml based language it actually
stands for yet another markup language
but it's an xml based language and it's
very easy to use the great thing about
learning yaml is that a lot of open
source tools in the devops environment
use yaml as the scripting lane and then
finally in docket compose as a user you
can actually go and and trigger all your
services within the containers to start
with a single command as you can imagine
this dramatically reduces the amount of
work that you as a developer have to do
so let's take an example of if you're
running a container one with a ninjx
server and one with the redis database
uh you can create a yaml docker compose
file that actually has the instructions
on the containers needed to build out
both environments and then you can run
each of those environments separately
but have them connected as a single
service so the benefits of dock and
compose is that you have a single host
deployment environment you can run this
all on one piece of hardware you can
have a quick and easy configuration
using yaml scripts the productivity that
you get as a developer significantly
increases because you're not having to
have time wasted trying to configure
just traditional docker containers by
themselves you now have a way of being
able to interact with those containers
and then finally security is at the
center of all of these containers so
each of those containers are completely
isolated from each other and they are
controlled with the same level security
that you'd have with a traditional
docker image but there is a question
here around docket compose isn't it
similar in concept to docker swarm
because at a high level it kind of seems
like both do the same thing and the
answer is well actually no they're
different there are similarities but
there are also differences and
particularly for a developer these
differences will really start coming out
in scale as you start working on your
solutions so let's look at docker
compose so docker compose will allow you
to create multiple containers on a
single host and that's the important
part having a single host which is maybe
your development pc with docker swarm it
also allows you to create multiple
contains however you have to manage
those multiple containers on multiple
hosts which makes a lot of sense if you
are running an operations environment
but not so much if you're doing a
development environment and docker
compose is scripted with yaml which is
very easy for you to be able to control
your scripts docker swamp doesn't have a
scripting technology like yaml so it's a
little bit harder to work with so what
we have here is just some basic commands
that allow you to get up and started
working with docker compose and in our
next demo we're actually going to take
you through how to use all of those
commands so we're going to go ahead and
do a demo on how to use docker compose
um the first thing you want to do is
check that you have docker installed so
what we're going to do is we're going to
open up the command window and we're
going to type in docker you'll be able
to see now that we have docker installed
if you don't have docker installed go
ahead and install docker you can go to a
google search to install docker and
they'll give you the instructions for
that we also have videos that we've
already done if once you have dock
installed then you want to do a google
search on docker compose or go to the
docker.com website and select for the
compose section and look for the install
docker compose instructions so we
already have another tab which has
the instructions already installed
you'll see on the left hand side there
are a number of docker tools you want to
expand the docker compose section select
install compose and then on the right
hand side you'll have different install
options for mac windows and linux if
you're installing on those platforms
make sure you're copying the correct
command line so there's a couple command
lines you want to
copy copy the first one over and we
paste that in it's going to go ahead and
download all of the files for compose it
takes a while but uh we have to get
another file so while it's downloading
we'll go get the other command line just
go back and grab it real quick it was a
little faster but we'll copy that over
there was a second command instruction
and post that command yep there's the
command right there and that will apply
the appropriate binary and once you've
done that you can actually go ahead and
validate that you have the correct
version of docker compose installed and
for that you want to write the command
docker dash compose space dash dash
version and that will then give you a
version build once you know that you
have a version built that means that you
have everything installed correctly on
your machine so you can see here that we
have a version number which means we
have everything installed you might see
a different version number depending on
how old the video is when you're
watching it but we're using real content
at the moment let's just go ahead and
clear the screen and now what we're
going to do
is create a folder where we're actually
going to install the ammo file that will
have the instructions for our docker
components environment so we're moving
the cursor to the desktop and on the
desktop we're going to create a new
folder and using the mkdirf command and
we'll call this one docker compose f for
file and then we'll move the cursor into
that new folder by using cd command and
now we are in the folder called docker
compose f and you can go look at your
desktop and you'll see it's there and
now you want to select um pound touch
docker dash compose dot yml and that'll
actually create the new yaml file for
you and you can use the ls list command
ls docker compose.yaml and they'll allow
you actually now to step in and edit
that file so let's go ahead and hit
return and that us to go in and edit the
file so now i'm in the editor and i'm
going to write some instructions um so
i'm i'm going to put a couple mistakes
in these instructions so we can see how
dr pose catches those mistakes
so but most this is going to be fairly
correct so you can just type this out so
we're going to start with surfaces colon
then we do web colon and then we create
image colon and we'll do nitrix and then
we'll do a database colon and we call
the image redis and so what you can see
because we have two reference images
we're actually calling two different
images two different containers that
will be created by docker hub so what
we're gonna do is uh where we can
actually show you um how that's pulling
in you can go to docker hub and you can
actually see the references to the
images that we've just created so go to
dockerhub which is hubhob.docker.com
and you'll see that and nijix
redis those are the default names for
the images so you could do
other images like http for apache web
server if you wanted to there are a lot
of images in docker hub so suddenly have
a lot of fun building uh tools from that
environment so we're gonna save those
files um in the docker image and we're
just gonna do colon wq to exit this
screen i save the text and let's go and
run our yaml file and you'll see the two
different error messages that will come
up so we can do cat docker dash compose
dot yml and here we have a display of
the text that we just wrote
and now let's go check the validity of
the file that we just corrected so we'll
do docker dash compose config and we
should get an error message and there we
are error message and the reason why we
have an error message is because the
spacing is not correct in the yaml file
itself so let's go to the actual yaml
file we created let's go through and
we're going to use uh just the file
finder and you'll just open up the yaml
file in your text editor your favorite
text editor and here we have um the code
that created it and that's use the
correct
spacing so that everything is spaced out
appropriately in the image and so this
is the spacing that you'd expect to see
a space a line between surfaces and the
first image and the first image is a tab
in and then it referenced what the image
is and let's go ahead and clear the
screen and we'll see whether or not
we've got that all correct it click um
let's clear the screen and we're going
to check that everything is running
correctly and we're seeing we're still
getting an error message and the reason
why we're getting another error is that
there's still a config error in this the
actual yammer file so one of the things
you have to do when you're creating a
yaml file for docker composers you
actually have to have the appropriate
version
number in there so what we have to do is
we have to go and find which is the
appropriate version and there are three
major versions one two and three
depending on the age of docker that you
have installed on your computer uh so if
you have the very latest version of
docker 18 and newer you would put
3.7 as the version number and what we're
going to do is we're going to just check
on the version that we have installed
and so just clear the screen and then
we'll just do docker version and what we
have is our version of docker's
17.12 now this is the version of docker
not docker compose uh it's your main
docker environment and so if we go back
to our web browser we'll actually see
that version 17 should align with
version number 3.5
yep there we are version 3.5 so what we
want to do is go back into our yaml file
and the very first line that we want to
put in above the services is the version
number and that version number we're
going to put in is 3.5 so we type
inversion version and we put colon and
then version number is in brighton
quotes and you save that and now what we
can actually do is we can actually go
ahead and use the single line
instruction to run both of these uh
two images that we've created because
everything is configured correctly or
just one note you'll see that the
version number is actually at the bottom
of the list and that's just the way that
docker compose works it pulls out the
services and the images that you'd
create and then put the image the
version number at the bottom of the list
so in the presentation we talked about
how you can use one line to trigger two
or more images and so to do that we're
going to do sudo docker dash compose up
dash d and it's going to create the two
environments we have the web environment
and the database environment and let's
use sudo docker ps to actually list out
that all the processes that are running
right now and there we are we actually
see all of the images that are running
we have the names the commands the
images and everything's up and running
and if we want to close both of those
images we can actually use a single line
of command as well and that command will
be sudo docker dash compose down and
that closes both of the images and we
can see that all the databases and the
web services images have been closed and
sudo ps will actually list that there is
nothing running and that's how to use
docker compose welcome everyone to this
topic on docker networking here so in
this one we are going to talk about that
what exactly is in docker uh why the
docker networking is important uh what
is the docker networking all about
features of docker networking container
network modes uh network drivers and
then we will be having a demo on
creating a bridge connector a bridge
network and we will see that how we can
run our custom docker container on that
custom docker network so let's go ahead
with this activity what is the docker
all about so docker is an os level
virtualization software platform which
helps the user to develop deploy and
manage and run applications inside a
docker container now the best part about
this is that not only you store the
source code you also put up the
dependencies inside it so if i have a
java based application so apart from the
java code base i will also be putting up
the dependencies like jdk and also
inside the docker container so it's a
complete package which you're going to
prepare and inside this package you will
be having all the dependencies and
whatever the binaries you require you
will be having it inside a docker
container now if you see the diagram
over here you have a infrastructure on
top of which you have the host operating
system then on top of the host operating
system you have the docker engine now
docker engine is the main component here
which takes up all the requests which
make sure that all the containers are up
and running and it actually gives an
interface or kind of a runtime to the
docker containers so that they can run
their specific applications so this is a
basic component basic architecture of
the docker now docker container is a
very lightweight software package okay
usually inside this docker containers
you will be having all the dependencies
all the software packages everything is
included in this site these docker
containers so it's a complete package if
i'm looking forward for a jenkins
application container in there
everything will be there right from the
base operating system to the jdk and
then on top of that the jenkins
application running there so the moment
i go there and run the docker container
of jenkins i will be able to have a
full-fledged jenkins application
available which i can access through the
url and through our specific port 8080
so docker container is a kind of a
package where both the dependencies and
the source code and the libraries are
available why exactly the docker
networking is important let's talk about
some scenario over here so my
application is something which totally
works perfectly fine into my system and
there is no issues on there i ran it
perfectly fine and i got the response
i'm able to interact everything i'm able
to do but the same application does not
works on the other person's system now
what could be the issue because it's
working on one machine and it's not
working on another machine now the
application does not work on another
system because there is a difference in
the computer systems maybe one system is
having a different machine and another
system is having a different machine and
you may be having some of the
differences maybe in the uh term of
hardware maybe in the terms of software
so the differences are possible in two
different machines so how we can get a
solution that uh we don't get this kind
of problems and once the container is
prepared it should be able to run it
across different systems so docker
networking is the ideal solution for
this uh problem over here with docker
networking the application works totally
fine and
it's uh something which can work on any
system you don't have any dependency
that it will run only on a specific
machine or a particular system so what
exactly is in docker networking all
about so docker networking enables a
user to link a docker container to as
many as networks you know he or she
requires so you can actually connect a
docker container to a specific network
the docker networks are used to provide
complete isolation to the docker
containers so you can have it like okay
i want to run some couple of containers
in a different network and another
containers i want to run it into a
different networks so you can do that
isolations and the whole purpose of
doing that isolation is so that we will
be able to have a proper networking and
proper executions and all that stuff so
docker networking is a very important
concept when we talk about or when we
come up with the interaction on having
the docker containers isolated so it
resolves most of the problems okay so um
you can have like a multiple containers
in running in same network you can have
a different uh particular networks also
there so a specific network
have its own uh attributes and then you
can use those attributes to connect to
that containers and to access that
containers but the whole idea is that
the containers are something which is
specifically running in a set of
servers or in a set of
platform so whenever i'm trying to look
forward to that particular container
it has to be there into a network if you
don't run it into your custom network
then whatever the default network
present it will be hosted in that
network there so how does the docker
networking actually works so you got a
decker file so using the dockerfile you
got up a custom docker image and from
this docker image you have to actually
go there and uh you know put up like the
docker container so um you can also
store this docker image to the docker
hub so that the same docker image can be
shared across different users and they
can also pull down their docker image
and they can have the container running
in their systems so for the
collaborating the docker image you
require the docker hub and the container
is the ultimate thing or object which we
need to create out of the docker image
when we go with the particular process
when the whole process goes on over
there so what happens that uh the
instead of the docker hub you can use
your own private repositories also
that's something which totally relies on
to you that how exactly those things
works on so a dockerfile creates a
docker image using the build command
a docker image contains all the project
source code all the dependencies uh
using this docker image you can actually
run the source code in order to get a
docker container the moment you
initialize or running stance of docker
image you will be able to get a docker
container you can actually use the
docker hub for collaborating or for
sharing the docker image so you can
store the docker image on docker hub and
then different people can actually go
ahead and download or pull this docker
image onto their system and they can
also run their specific containers so
what are the different advantages we get
with the docker networking very first
one is the rapid deployment portability
better efficiency a faster configuration
scalability and the security over here
so these are some of the advantages
which we get when we talk about the
docker networking here now let's talk
about the container network model here
so what is the network model we are
looking forward from the containers
perspective now this is a kind of
architecture here now in this one let's
see that how it actually works on now
you have a docker engine which is a main
component which takes up all the things
and all the important components are
actually integrated with each other now
the network sandbox is the one in which
you will be having your container
running up and running now every network
is having its own attributes the uh
particular different gateway ips the ip
addresses the range of ipads the cidr
blocks also everything it can be
different to for two different networks
so the whole point is that you will be
defining okay if you don't define that i
want to run this uh particular container
into a specific network then definitely
that's going to run into default network
which is which gets created the moment
you do the installation of dockers but
anyhow any network is required for
running a docker container so there are
different network drivers which is
available there so if you feel that you
want to create a network so you have to
choose a particular networking or the
connectivity over there and it really
helps us to understand how the
configurations and how the different
modifications and those changes can be
really done here so a lot of changes are
actually going on and uh you know
performing there and this really helps
us to understand that how the things are
being done as such over there so network
is something which is very important
from the containers perspective so the
network sandbox is in kind of a isolated
sandbox that holds the all the network
configurations of the containers so you
will be requiring a at least one docker
container network if you want to run a
container inside in that particular
sandbox so sandbox is created when a
user requests to generate an endpoint on
the network so that's where the sandbox
gets created uh it can have several
endpoints in a network as it represents
a containers network configurations like
ip address mac address dns name so every
container will be having its own unique
ips right so that can be a particular
endpoint to connect to that container
and it can have it like different
endpoints and different different
networks so that's always the
possibilities which is available there
now the endpoints
establishes the connectivity for the
container services with other services
also so the moment you work on the uh
particulars uh endpoints so that can be
used for having okay there is a service
running in a container so how you can do
that so if you in order to connect that
you require these endpoints so that you
can establish the connectivity with the
container services whatever running
inside these docker containers
right now the network is something which
provides the specific underlining
network attributes like the networking
support to the docker containers because
these uh network sandbox
boxes will definitely have a requirement
of the network so how you're going to
get that that you will be only able to
get when you go okay i will be looking
forward for the connectivity and i can
go for the communications and i can give
the hardware because although it's a os
level virtualization but still you
require some interaction with the
hardware from the networking perspective
and then docker engine is a the base
engine which is installed on the host
machine and it's actually the main
component which make sure that the
docker containers and the corresponding
docker services are always up and
running and the uh using the network
drivers you can actually create multiple
networks onto your system and you can
have those uh configurations
now the network architecture is
something which helps us to provide the
connectivity among the endpoints that
probably belongs to the same network and
uh it's something which is a kind of
isolated network so different different
networks can be isolated uh networks and
we can have the endpoints to them so uh
there are different ways in which we can
establish the connectivity and this is a
complete network architecture which is
there so you have a network drivers you
have the networks you have the network
sandboxes in which internally the docker
containers are running and then these
network sandboxes are having their
respective endpoints there to access
them to establish the connectivity now
let's talk about the network drivers now
there are five type of network drivers
which is available first one is the
bridge
host none overlay and mac vlan so these
are the different uh particular network
drivers which is available over here
first one is a bridge it's a private
default network created on the host if
you go there if you go to the
installation of a docker this is the
default driver which gets installed onto
the system onto the host the containers
linked to this network will have an
internal ip address through which we
they can actually communicate with each
other on the same machine also you can
establish the connectivity you can
connect to the containers using that
private ip address but outside the
server you will not be able to have the
communication but internally you can
connect with the containers and
containers can also interact with each
other they can also communicate with
each other with this one uh the docker
daemon creates the uh docker zero so if
you run the ipconfig config or if config
on the system you will be able to see a
docker 0 kind of ethernet bridge network
which is created using which you can see
that okay this is the network which is
created by default it's a default
installation or default configuration
which automatically happens the moment
you set up a docker instance so you
don't have to go into the configurations
or in the setup of there it will be
already available on that particular
installation board there and the next
one is the host one so it's a public
network so when we go with the public
network it's actually uses the host iprs
and uh tcp port in order to uh interact
with the service running inside the
docker container so if you are looking
forward that i want to reach out or i
want to connect to the container but i
want to use an
ip address which can be accessible from
outside world probably some other server
should be able to resolve that in that
situation the host network driver comes
into the picture so it
effectively disables the network
isolation between the docker host and
the docker containers which means that
using this driver a user can actually
run multiple containers you know it's
it's not possible for the user to run
multiple containers on the same host
because of the fact that you are using
the host ip address now when we were
talking about the bridge connection at
that moment of time we were getting the
private ip addresses which was totally
isolated and totally unique so there
were actually if you create a using the
bridge connection multiple containers so
you will see that if there are five
three containers everyone will be having
a different private ip address but the
moment you go for the host one so in
that situation the ip address is not
going to change so you get some
restrictions okay because the
combination is of ipaddress and port so
ips and 8080 can happen only once it
cannot happen multiple times so that's
the limitation that you cannot run
multiple containers on the same host due
to this restriction and the next one is
the none so in this network driver the
docker containers will neither have any
access to the external network or it
will not be able to communicate with the
other containers also total isolation
and total private containers are being
done when we use this driver so if you
these options are usually used when you
want to
disable so this is not doing nothing but
disabling the total networking of
functionality for a specific container
that's what it happening over here next
one is the overlay so this one is
utilized for creating an internal
private network to the docker nodes in
the docker swamp cluster so overlay does
not comes up in case of a standalone
docker installation the moment you go
with the particular docker swamp cluster
at that moment of time the overlay type
of network is created so docker uh swam
is an orchestration tool so
that requires overlay kind of uh
driver which can
you know help them to achieve the
networking in case of cluster because in
case of docker spam you have a master
node manager node worker nodes different
different machines are there so in that
situation overlay is the
main component or is the main type of
driver which is used and then we have
the mac vlan so it simplifies the
communication processes between the
containers
this network assigns a mac address to
the docker containers with this mac
address the docker you know servers will
route the network traffic to a router so
it's it's not on the basis of ip address
it's actually on the basis of mac
address so on the specific mac address
the network this docker server will
redirect the network to a specific
router
right it's usable when a user wants to
directly connect the containers to the
physical network rather than the docker
host so that's where this communication
works on so it's a direct connectivity
between the host network and uh the
docker container so there is no
virtualization which is happening over
here so uh it's something which is you
know giving a direct access to the
networks but it's definitely on the
basis of mac address which on which the
communication is happening now let's
talk about the networking implementation
and we'll see that how we can go for a
particular bridge network implementation
there so let's go back to the virtual
machine so i am connected to a
particular system here so i can check
that if the docker is available to me
and i can just run the docker version so
it says that okay the client and the
server component both is available there
now we are going to see that what are
the different uh containers which is
what are the different docker containers
network which is available there so i'm
going to run a command called docker
network ls now the moment you do it over
here you will see that none host and
bridge these are the different
containers uh network which is available
there and uh you can see their network
ids the names the drivers but drivers is
also very important because that's what
we are going to use here so it's a very
good one here so the default one you can
see that the bridge is available and uh
it's a default one whenever you create
any container by default whether you
give the container attribute or not it's
something which gets created into the uh
terms or in the
basis of the container only in the
default network only so how we can get
that we can always get that part by uh
you know having the understanding that
what network we are using so i'm going
to run a couple of containers a small
container and we can see that how
exactly uh the containers can be
executed and can be done over there
right so let's see so i'm going to run a
command
docker
run hyphen d id
iphone iphone name
alpine1
alpine
image is what i am going to use
and usage
so it uh pulls down the alpine image
that's what it happened and the same
thing i'm going to run but this time i'm
going to run uh alpine 2 because
i want to create two containers
right so with this one what will happen
that i will be having
like two containers available here so i
can say like darker ps so i can see that
two containers that are in ink one is
the alpine and one is l pine two right
so now what happens that we will see
that how the connectivity happens and uh
what are the network details so what i'm
going to do is that first of all i'm
going to do an uh inspect over there
onto the uh bridge connectivity so that
i can get the detailed information
so um this is the name of
the particular ones of the network so
this is the network which is available
and this is the default one so if i
scroll up you can see that this is the
name of the bridge connectivity and uh
even if you run the docker network list
so uh you will be able to see that the
id also so id also if you compare so uh
e65 that's the one which is available
now this one is something which is using
a driver called bridge and here you can
see the subnet information now if you
scroll down you can see that two
containers are available here so i did
not provide any kind of network details
but uh definitely what happens that the
two containers which i deployed are
basically running inside this network
okay and you can see that uh the bridge
name docker zero is the internet or
network which gets created uh which
during the installation of docker gets
uh configured now
you can see that uh this is the ip
address this is the ip address here this
is the mac address and this is also a
mac address here so uh the ip address
you can see this is a
3.0.3 in the last and this is dot two
over here so you can see that the
increase the sequence is there so alpine
one was having an
ip.172.17.0.2 and uh alpine two is
having an incremented ipad as like a
different one as in three so you can see
that these different ip addresses are
there and uh represents if you want to
access them if you want to connect on
them you will be able to have the
connectivity accordingly so uh even if
you go inside these containers you can
actually see that what exactly uh the
connectivity you want to establish or
the connectivity you want to perform
here
right so this is the way that how the
network usually works and uh the
networks which you are using over here
is the bridge once which definitely
helps us to understand that how the
configurations can be done now so uh
what we are going to do over here is
that we will try to see that how exactly
uh we can
go ahead and uh we can connect on there
and we can also see that if we are able
to communicate with each other because
probably uh if i run like ping command
over here
and i'll put the containers like two
and i'm able to reach out there is no
problem in reaching out to these ips
because these are the private ip
addresses and i will be able to reach
out to them without any problem and
without any concerns so from the current
uh connectivity perspective there is no
problem as such and i have a connection
available over here but let's see uh
we'll go uh back to the containers we
will see that how exactly we can talk
about we can reach out to the one
container with each other so i want to
connect alpine one within pine two so
how we can do that so i'm going to use
like docker
fine one
okay now i got a terminal so what i can
do is that i can go for the ipa in this
show
so with this one what will happen that i
will be able to know the ipad is so dot
to is the one which is available over
here okay so this is the ip address now
i can uh simply do the uh small ping
command so i can say like ping
google.com so that will show me that if
i have an internet connectivity so that
is great so i got a connectivity with
the internet uh over there so i will be
able to reach out any websites or any
kind of that order now i have another ip
so dot three is remember we were using
three different ip so i can actually do
a ping also here so ping hyphen c five
five request will put and uh three will
do here now we are trying to reach out
to the alpine two over there so although
we are connecting to the alpine one but
we have the connectivity with alpine two
also so from alpine one you can connect
to the alpine two containers so that
shows that since both of them are
running in the same container so they
are having the automatic
uh connectivity and you can easily reach
out to them and without any issues you
can do that and similarly the same thing
you can do it uh in case of uh
alpine two also so you get it connected
to the alpine two and uh you can
just follow the same thing so you can
connect it uh with the if you go to the
alpine two you can connect to the alpine
one also so if you come out the
containers i will be always up and
running and you will be able to have the
mechanisms there so the whole idea about
these things is that it will be
basically helping you to understand that
how the executions can be done and how
we can perform the activities as such
over here so this is the way that how we
deal with the networkings and how the
containers gets created into a network
and then they can interact with each
other welcome to this session on docker
versus virtual machine
did you know the famous global
researcher gartner predicts by 2023 more
than 50 percent of the companies will be
adopting docker containers
however a serverless container like
docker will have a rise in the revenue
from a small base of
465.8 million in the year 2020 to
944 million in the year 2024. in this
video we will be doing a side-by-side
comparison of the docker containers and
the virtual machines but before that
let's have a look at the objectives of
this lesson in this session you will
have a good understanding of what a
virtual machine is and what a docker is
followed by that we will have a major
difference between
docker
and the virtual machines also we will
discuss some of the key differences
between docker and virtual machines and
finally a use case on what made bbc to
use docker
so the first one what exactly is a
virtual machine it is an isolated
computing environment that enables a
person to use an operating system via a
physical machine virtual machines
provide the functionality of a physical
computer as you can see on my screen
there is a virtual machine and this is
how a typical virtual machine looks like
now let's look at what a docker is
docker is an operating system level
virtualization software platform that
enables software developers and it
administrators to create deploy and run
applications in a docker container with
all their dependencies
and a docker container is a lightweight
software package that includes all the
dependencies like frameworks libraries
and many more which are essentially
required to execute an application
this is the architecture of docker tool
now let's move on to our next main topic
for the discussion that is docker versus
virtual machine
when it comes to comparing the two we
could say the docker containers have
much more potential than virtual
machines
as you can see on the left and right
hand side
both the images look similar now let's
define the layers of virtual machine
from the bottom up let's begin with the
infrastructure
infrastructure could be a computer
system a laptop or a virtual private
server such as an amazon ec2 instance or
as your virtual machine or gcp virtual
machine instance
on the top of the infrastructure runs
the operating system an operating system
is a software that manages hardware and
software resources for the computer
programs
on your laptop this will be likely
windows mac os or linux flavored
operating system such as ubuntu next
comes the hypervisor a hypervisor is a
firmware that builds and runs virtual
machines there are two types of
hypervisors
type 1 hypervisors are hyperkit for mac
os hyper-v for windows and kvm for linux
operating systems and type 2 hypervisors
are virtualbox and vmware then we have
the guest operating systems consider an
example where you want to run two apps
on your server in total isolation
this process would require two guest
operating systems which will be
controlled by a hypervisor
virtual machines come with many
dependencies where each guest operating
system will at least occupy 512 mb of
your ram
this is worse because each guest
operating system needs its own cpu and
memory resources eventually this will be
expensive
then on top of that each guest operating
system requires its own dependencies
such as binaries and libraries since
every application has different
dependencies it requires its own set of
libraries
finally it's the application this layer
consists of the source code for the
application you've built
this was all about the virtual machine
on a server here's what the same setup
looks like when you're using docker
containers
here you'll notice that there are a lot
fewer layers docker doesn't require a
bunch of massive guest operating systems
let me break it down from the bottom up
again
infrastructure and host operating
systems are the same as we discussed for
the virtual machine coming into the
third layer instead of a hypervisor
docker uses docker engine
docker engine or docker is a client
server application that builds and
executes containers using docker
components
next we have our dependencies
just like on the virtual machines here
dependencies are built into a template
called docker images as you can see on
the screen each application is still
isolated and occupies less space
now let's have a look at the significant
differences between docker and virtual
machine
let's start with the operating system
first
docker is a container based model where
containers are software packages used
for executing an application on any
operating system
on the other side virtual machine is a
container based model it utilizes user
space along with the kernel space of the
operating system a kernel space is where
the core of the operating system runs
and provides its services to the user a
user cannot modify the space and user
space is the portion of the system
memory in which the user's processes run
docker containers share operating system
kernels with other applications and
result in a higher server efficiency
hence docker provides the most
substantial default isolation
capabilities among the other
configuration tools
on the other hand virtual machines do
not share the operating system also it
does not provide isolation in the host
kernel
in docker multiple workloads can run on
a single operating system but in virtual
machine each workload needs a complete
operating system or a hypervisor
the next significant difference between
the two is the performance in the case
of docker they use the same operating
system without any additional software
like hypervisor
in case of virtual machines performance
issues are a major problem it can be due
to the several reasons like cpu
constraints memory allocation network
latency and many more running multiple
virtual machines lead to an unstable
performance
docker containers can start up quickly
and result in less boot up time whereas
virtual machines do not start quickly
and lead to a poor performance now let's
talk about the next difference which is
portability with docker containers a
developer can build an application and
store it into a docker image later he or
she can run it across any host
environment
but when it comes to virtual machines it
has portability issues
virtual machines do not have a central
hub like docker dust and it requires
more memory space to store data
docker containers are smaller than
virtual machines due to which the
process of transferring files on the
host file system is easier on the other
hand dependency on the host operating
system and hardware makes virtual
machines less portable while
transferring files virtual machines
should have a copy of the operating
system and its dependencies due to which
image size is increased and becomes a
tedious process to share data
the boot up time between the both is
very different the application and
docker containers start without any
delay since the operating system is
already up and running on the other hand
virtual machines take much longer time
than it takes for a container to run
applications
these containers were basically designed
to save time in the deployment process
of an application whereas in virtual
machines to deploy a single application
virtual machine needs to start an entire
operating system which would result in a
full board process
so those were the major differences
between docker and a virtual machine now
let's discuss the minor differences
between them
docker is not always in a running state
it stops when the stop command is
executed whereas the virtual machines
are always running in the background
which will result in huge ram
consumption talking about snapshots
docker has a lot of snapshots a snapshot
is an image that you can upload on a
private repository to access it on
another host but virtual machines do not
consist of any snapshots in docker
images can be version controlled just
like git they have local registry called
docker hub where users store and
distribute container images on the other
hand virtual machine does not have a
central hub they are not version
controlled
docker can run multiple containers on a
system users can connect multiple
containers using user defined networks
and shared volumes multiple containers
can be accessed on the same machine and
share the operating system kernel with
other containers each container is
isolated in user space also docker
containers occupy less space than
virtual machines and start instantly
virtual machine can run only a limited
number of virtual machines on a system
since each virtual machine requires a
certain amount of cpu ram memory and
other resources your physical systems
will have less space
multiple containers can be started at a
time on the docker engine the isolation
environment allows a user to run and
deploy several containers simultaneously
on a given host virtual machines can run
only a limited number of virtual
machines on a system since each virtual
machine requires certain amount of cpu
ram memory and other resources your
physical systems will have less space
now that i have told you the differences
between docker containers and virtual
machines let me show you a real-life
case study of how pcc uses docker
bcc news is a british news channel over
500 developers working across the globe
pcc news delivers broadcast in almost 30
different languages and with over 80 000
daily news in english alone the news
channel ran more than 26 000 jobs with
more than 10 continuous integrations
with sequential scheduling the company
had issues with identifying a way to
unify the coding process and monitor the
continuous integration consistently also
the existing jobs took up to more time
that is up to 60 minutes to schedule and
perform its task
docker allowed bcc news to eliminate job
wait times and run jobs in parallel it
also gave the users the ability to work
in a more flexible ci environment where
entire core processes were unified and
stored in a single place however docker
succeeded in spreading up the whole
continuous integration process welcome
everyone on this topic of the docker
commands over here in this topic we are
going to talk about what exactly is the
various docker commands which we can use
to interact with the docker docker
images docker containers and some core
components of docker is what we are
going to talk about in this uh
particular topic here now let's begin
with what exactly is in docker because
we are trying to explore that what are
the different docker commands we can
eventually run to interact with the
docker because uh you have the command
line interface which is available there
using which you can run some couple of
docker commands and internally you know
you will be able to have some particular
processing which is done at the docker
end now docker is in configuration
management tool it's being used as a
configuration management tool just like
the other configuration management tools
uh in the industry in the market now
it's pretty much used by the developers
to make sure that they
wrap or they package an application with
all its dependency
now normally in a virtual machine what
we do is that we host or we install the
dependencies separately and then on top
of that we host our web applications or
whatever the application we have we host
it on that particular framework or
platform
but here in this scenario we are talking
about like how we can wrap an
application all together with its
dependencies all the dependencies are
getting wrapped are getting uh packaged
up into a single entity
and you know that's what we call it as a
docker container so docker is in
configuration management tool and the
containerization tool which is there
which helps us to wrap or package both
the dependencies and the source code
within a single unit called docker
container and this is the docker
container which the developers use to do
the deployment across multiple
environments
so um as part of the process um when you
are working on the uh hosting of your
application onto your docker so
ultimately you are looking forward for
an entity called docker container so if
you see if you go through the diagram
over here so in this one
this is in kind of a basic way uh
architecture that how the docker is
being a architect and is getting
deployed
so initially you have an infrastructure
like a physical infrastructure is there
you have the uh particular cores memory
infrastructure all those things are
available there now on top of this
infrastructure you are hosting up a host
operating system
this host operating system is
responsible for taking up all the
requests and interacting uh providing a
particular interface between the uh
particular docker and the infrastructure
the core hardware so it acts like a
medium over here
so after the host on operating system on
top of that you are going to install the
docker engine docker software it's just
like you got a virtual machine on linux
and on top of that you are installing
the docker software
once the docker engine is installed then
docker engine will take care of
management of the docker containers you
don't really have to do a lot of work
docker engine is going to take all the
internal work uh the communication
between the operating system and the
infrastructure so that needs to be done
by the docker engine so docker engine
make sure that the different container
gets uh up and running and you can see
that in this scenario in this diagram we
have container one container two and
container three and all these containers
are actually having its own applications
and the dependencies binded up together
so that's the reason why we are saying
that with the docker we are getting a
complete package end-to-end package is
being given to us in which we have both
the uh particular source code and the
binaries and the executables embedded
inside that so it's a complete package
which is getting created in the form of
docker container and the developer is
responsible for preparing this docker
container so that these containers can
be deployed on the docker host and you
can get your application up and running
so this is what we have docker into our
particular and the architecture of the
docker here now let's see that what are
the different commands we have for the
docker here now the very first one is
that what are the different images
related to commands which is available
there the very first one is the
command which we typically use to
prepare a custom docker image now i can
easily go to the docker hub and i can
pull down a docker image which is
available there but let's assume that
you are working on application source
code so you want to prepare a docker
container for that now that docker
container you will not be able to have
it on the docker hub you have to prepare
on your own
right so in order to prepare your own
docker image all you have to do is that
you have to run docker build command now
in this case we
have to prepare a docker file which will
act like a docker a kind of a docker
build script just like in case of maven
we have power xml file and in case of
and we have built.xml file so here we
have the dockerfile which is available
there and this dockerfile make sure that
whatever the steps are mentioned in this
dockerfile in the build script it's
going to perform a series of steps and
the build will be done so docker build
is the command hyphen t is the tag that
what exactly name uh
you know whatever the image you are
building so what exactly tag name you're
trying to provide over here so here we
are using a tag name called my image and
then after the column we are providing
that what version we want to go here 1.0
2.0 5.0 so whatever the version you feel
that you want to uh you know refer you
can do that
now this is the exact way that how in
the actual world the docker images are
getting built up by the uh respective
vendors let's say that jenkins is born
and jenkins wants to prepare a docker
image so they will be preparing the
docker file in the same manner and
prepare these docker images and publish
it to the docker hub so all the docker
images are built up the custom docker
images are built up with the help of
docker files so docker build is the
command which will process the docker
file and give you a particular docker
image in the end
now how to list down all the docker
images so docker list uh ls is something
which is there so this will eventually
help you to list down all the docker
images which is listed on or which is
available into your system so that will
be listed out over there for you
if you feel that you want to remove a
particular image in that case you can go
for docker image rm command and uh
whatever the image you want to remove
you can give the respective image name
and the tag name there so docker image
rm command is there using which you can
actually see that how the image can be
deleted from the host over here in this
one right so whatever the ways whatever
the you know mechanism is there so we
are making sure that how the image can
be built up and how we can go for the uh
built up and a particular image can be
deployed over here in this case so in
order to delete it in docker image so
you can go for docker
image rm command to remove a docker
image completely from the docker host
so these are some couple of commands
which is available there using which you
can actually interact or manage the
docker image because in order to prepare
in order to run a docker container we
require a source and that source we are
going to get it from the docker image so
now we are going to see that how we can
execute these commands so first of all
what we need to do is that we need to
see that how docker build works for that
we require a docker file so i am going
to have a simple docker file over here
in which we are going to have a basic uh
docker image selected as an ubuntu after
that we are going to go for the one
attribute where we are going to do the
installation of a specific package like
lets say git and accordingly you can
whatever software you want to prepare
you want to set up you can do that and
put up the commands over here in this
docker file so i'm going to save this
file and after that what i need to do is
that i need to run like docker images to
find out that how many images are there
there is no images present so i'm going
to build a docker image over here with
the name of
simply none or whatever the uh name you
want to give you can uh give it over
here in this case it's not any kind of
restricted word so you can give the
actual docker image name also that what
for what purpose you are preparing this
image and with that what will happen
that it will take up the uh
values whatever attributes you have put
up into the docker file so that will be
processed and that will be picked up and
once that uh docker file has been
processed has been uh you know prepared
you will be able to see that yes a final
product or a final docker image is
finalized and prepared over here in this
one so we just have to wait for the
whole process to complete and once my
docker image is prepared i will be able
to have a particular setup done or
achieved over here so that's what we
require over here in this one to be
performed
now once the installation is done so you
will be able to see like the final
docker image is being prepared over here
so it says successfully built which
means that the docker image is prepared
now if you run like docker images you
will be able to find out that this image
is available over here in this one now
you are seeing like two images because
one is like the basic image which is
being pulled on because we are using a
docker file to do that to process that
one there
now in case you want to remove it so all
you need to do is that you need to run
like docker
image
rm and simply learn
so if you do that what will happen that
your docker image which is related to
simply learn will be wiped off from your
system and in case you want to do like
removal of the ubuntu also so that also
you can do over here with the help of
docker images
ubuntu and that will be removed from
your system so your docker images will
be removed from your system using the uh
particular command called docker um
image and then rm command to remove the
docker image from your system from your
host here so that's how you deal with
the different docker images uh commands
over here in this one now let's go back
to the document now the next section
over here is the docker container
commands over here so all the commands
related to docker containers is what we
are going to talk about over here now
the very first one is the uh particular
container so in order to create a
container so you can run the command
called docker create and the image
because for a container you require a
docker image that's a pre-request so
once the docker image is prepared you
can just simply run docker create
command and that will help you to create
a container onto your system now if you
want to run a particular um you want to
create a container and you want to run
it also at the same time so in that
situation you can go for a docker run
command the main difference between the
docker create and docker run command is
that the docker run command is going to
uh run a container and uh it's going to
give you a response from the command but
the docker create command is going to
create only the container so once the
container is up and running so that's
only being done by the docker create
command but the docker run command is
going to actually do the
uh preparation of the container also and
at the same time you are being given as
in particular response also like you
know what a command you want to run so
that response also you will be able to
get here and if you feel that you want
to rename an existing container so for
that you can go for the docker rename
command so existing container you can
rename it with the new container and
that's how the particular rename of an
existing container will be done with on
to the docker host here so docker rename
is the command using which you can
rename an existing container and you can
get a new container over here in this
case
so these are some of the options some of
the ways that how you can interact with
the containers how you can manage them
onto your docker host over here so you
can run it you can create it and you can
rename the containers also so now what
we're going to do is that we're going to
see that how we can work on this
particular container commands here so
first of all i'm going to quickly pull
down uh jenkins image so that i can
create a container out of that so it's
in kind of a 600 round mv docker image
which is available there now you can
also have a custom docker image prepared
using the docker file or you can have a
ready-made docker image pull down from
the docker hub also so this is going to
pull the latest version of the jenkins
from the docker hub so that we will be
able to proceed further on that and we
will be able to continue with the
hosting so we will be converting or
running this uh specific docker images
in the form of docker containers so that
we will be able to have a instance of
docker container over here running in
this one so that's what we are trying to
do here
so we will just wait for this pull
activity to complete because it's an uh
heavy docker image so it may take some
time to download and once it's download
you will be able to see
that docker
images is showing a specific docker
image of jenkins here now you're going
to create a container out of that so
you're going to run a command called
docker
create and jenkins over here
so that will help us to do uh the
creation of a docker container and once
that is done so you will be able to see
like using docker ps command that if any
container is up and running and if you
go for docker psyphony you will be able
to see that yes a particular docker
container is in
created mode now this is not in running
mode because you see that when i ran the
docker ps command it was not showing it
in the running mode because i just
created a docker container here and the
created status also shows that yes the
docker container is created but it did
not run over here
so if
you want to run it so definitely you can
say like docker start
and
you can give the container name and that
will help me to
start my container over here but of
course you if you feel that you want to
directly
create a container and you know you
don't want to create the container only
you want to start it also so in that
case you can go for the docker run
command so docker run command is
something which can be used instead of
doing the execution so you can say like
docker
run
jenkins
and what it will do it will definitely
help you to get the
container created onto of the jenkins
over here in this case it's not like
only creating a container but in fact
it's actually starting the container
also so you can see that it started over
here into your screen itself that whole
jenkins gets initialized over here in
this one so this is the way that how
you can initialize or you can create a
container now i can just do a control c
over here because it says that and
jenkins is up and running so you can
start using this one according to your
requirement over here right so i'm just
doing ctrl c so that it can be stopped
over there
right now
so this is the way that how uh typically
we can create the containers now we got
like two containers over here and uh one
is up and running and one is something
which i just closed just now over here
now if you feel that you want to rename
a container let's say like this is a
container which is available but it's
not having a meaningful name now i want
to convert into a meaningful name like
dev underscore chain things so that you
can easily do with the help of a docker
rename command because that will rename
the docker container name so that you
will be able to connect on to that and
you can go for the processing so that's
what we can get over here in this one so
this is how you can do the
various management of the resources over
here so let's go back to the main
content
now if you feel that you want to remove
all these top containers because what
happens that sometimes we simply stop
the container but we do not remove it
from the
docker hose because
we are not going for the cleanup now
clean one cleanup is very required
because these containers are actually
taking up the disk space also so we need
to make sure that we should be using we
should be having like minimum amount of
disk space utilization so for that what
we need really need to do is that we
need to run docker container prune
command so this will basically help you
to uh prune or do the cleanup uh purge
of all the containers which is running
on the host machine here
and that will definitely help us to
remove all the containers which is in
stop status so that will be simply
removed over here in this one so uh this
really completely removes all the
stopped containers onto the docker host
over here in this scenario
now second one is that it creates a new
image from a containers file changes now
the
way what happens that normally what we
follow is that we use the docker build
command to do the build process right so
docker build command is being used in
that particular way now if you really
want to go for a preparation of a new
you know image so all you need to do is
that you need to create a new image from
a container file
so you can run the command called docker
container commit command and you know
whatever container is there so that will
be saved or preserved as a docker image
because sometimes we also do some ad hoc
changes or modifications on the fly
inside the docker container by going
inside the docker container and doing
the steps so we really need to preserve
those steps and that is the reason why
we are converting a docker container in
the form of a docker image here so
that's what we are trying to perform
here so docker container is something
which is uh being uh done over here in
such a way that whatever the steps
whatever the changes we are trying to do
so that needs to be performed over here
in this case so docker container uh
commit command is being used so that we
can get a particular you know final
image as part of the container so the
container will be converted in the form
of a docker image over here
and the last one is that how we can
remove an existing container so we can
go for the docker rm command which is
available there using which you will be
able to go ahead and you can get a
particular container removed from your
existing system so docker rm command is
pretty much there using which we can see
that how we can remove an existing
container from your system as such
what exactly now we are going to see
that how we can perform the various
commands
on the containers here
so the very first command which we want
to do here is that uh you know in order
to see that how we can actually remove
all these top containers but for this
one what we really need to do is that we
need to first of all run some couple of
containers so i'm going to quickly run a
container called docker
run hyphen d httpd
so i'm going to run a particular web
server over here and
it should be able to give me a proper
container up and running so i can just
double check or value that it as with
the help of the
docker ps command
so docker ps command should give me the
proper confirmation that whether the
container is in up and running over here
or not so you can see that it's up and
running from last 11 seconds here now we
got a command where you know for example
we have got some stopped containers but
again you have to manually remove them
one by one now if you don't want to do
that stuff if you feel that whatever the
stock containers which is available that
should be automatically removed from
your system then we have a command
called docker container prompt now for
this what we really need to do is that
we need to actually stop this container
because again it will be only picked up
like whatever the containers which is
available in these top setters only
those will be picked up
so i have copied the container name here
in this case and i need to stop it so
that i will be able to
remove it with the prone command over
here in this one and then i can run like
docker
container
print command which will basically
remove all the containers which is in
these top status and once that is done
you will be able to see like that is
something which is completely gone from
your system so this is a way that how it
can not only take care of these top
containers but it's actually being done
so that you can remove the multiple
containers with the single command
itself over here so this is not
something which will be executed one by
one on a different container but yes it
will definitely take care of doing the
uh changes and performing the activities
now another thing is that how we can
actually do the uh commit of a
particular docker image let's say that
we got a docker container which is uh
running and there are some changes like
some dynamic changes which is available
there so you want to save this uh
particular container as a docker image
so that whatever the changes temporary
changes are there so that will be also
saved as a docker image so all you can
do is that let's say that again
run a particular container
of http here so this will help me to get
a particular container from the http
perspective available of to us so docker
ps command will give me the option
now here i have got a container in which
it's running now if i want to save this
container let's say that i went inside
it did some modifications did some
temporary changes i want to refer it i
want to use it so how you can do that so
for that what you really need to do is
you need to run like docker
commit that's a command or you can say
docker because you're going to do a
docker container commit over here so the
commit of the container is what we are
going to do so docker container commit
and then we are going to say like what
is the container so for container we
will be
yes again copying
that particular container id and we'll
say like custom
image colon version one so we will be
giving a custom name or a name of a
docker image and a tag over here in this
one so this will basically save my
docker container which is available in
this one in the format of a particular
docker image in a format of a docker
image over here in this case
so as you can see that almost both of
them are having the same change but
the container which we got uh over here
in this one so this whatever the changes
uh you want to wish you want to do you
can do that and you can then put up into
the uh form of a docker image a final
docker image and at large if you want to
remove it so docker rm and container id
now this again docker arm will come
remove only those containers which is in
stop status so if you want to forcefully
remove it so you will be able to use it
with the help of hyphen f which is the
force will remove which will remove the
container completely from your system
and once it's removed from your system
you will be able to see like there is no
container running up and running over
here in this one so docker ps hyphen a
is not something which is up and running
over here in this one so they completely
completely got uh wiped out from your
system so that's how you basically work
on these commands on this uh particular
uh container related commands here so
let's go back to the main content
right so these are the commands where we
can actually do the management like how
to stop the containers how to remove the
containers and how to get a new you know
docker image out of the container here
now let's see that how we can list down
all the running containers if you feel
that you want to list down all the
running containers then you can go for
the docker containers ls command and
that will eventually help you to list
down all the containers which is
available there which is uh being there
into your system
then docker stop command is there to
stop a container
so whatever container which is there in
the running status so that will be
stored with the help of the docker stop
command and then the restart command is
there using which you can do a restart
of a container into your system
right so once the container is restart
so whatever the application running
inside the container so that will also
be restarted over here in this one so
these are the different options which is
available using which we can explore
over here in this one somewhat more
commands about the container so again i
am going to run a container over here of
http here so that i can show you some
couple of more commands over here now we
can run like docker ps or you can say
like docker container less will which
list down on all the containers which is
available to you which is being uh you
know present in this case now if you
want to do any kind of operations like
let's say if i want to stop it
now the moment you do the stop over here
so you will be able to uh stop the
container which is up and running for
you and
you can come
you know whatever the application is
being deployed that will also not be
available to you because that's simply
uh completely gone for you now you can
see that the docker container list is
not able to show you that particular
option that whether it's
being shown or not because it's in stop
status so in fact you can do a you know
start or you can do a restart so both
the operations you can pretty much do
over here so that you will be able to
have a complete activity implemented so
restart is also something which is
available which can definitely help you
to see that how the things really work
and how you can go for the container uh
you know the management over here in
this case so you can do
container dock container ls command to
list down what are the containers which
is available
then you can do a restart you can do a
stop also infect start is also there
which can help you to see that how the
containers is are really available so
this is the way that how you can manage
like you know even the restarts and all
because this really helps you to even do
the restart bounces to the application
which is present inside this container
so that also you will be able to see
with this particular component here
so that let's go back to the main
content
and then uh you know killing a running
container so if you really want to kill
a container so for that we can go for
the docker kill because rocket stop is
also going to stop the container but if
you want to forcefully kill it so in
that case you can go for the docker kill
command to do that particular
kill on the containers and then if you
really want to go inside the container
and you want to attach your terminal so
for that you can go for the docker
attach command and with this what will
happen that you can go
inside the container you can do whatever
the changes you want to perform you can
do that and you can again come back
outside that also so normally typically
we use it so that we can see some errors
of
in the logs which is coming up in the
containers and if any kind of issues are
coming up for the applications we should
be able to know that part now the last
one is the uh particular weight docker
weight is there so that will block a
container and uh it will go in the
weight status so docker weight and the
container id or the container name you
can give so with that the particular
container will go into the block status
let's see somewhat more uh commands over
here so we can run like docker container
ls again to find out like what container
is available so you can see that this
particular container is available over
here in this one now if you see like if
i want to get uh attached to this
container if i want to attach my input
and output uh stream with this container
so you can run like docker
attach and the container id so your
terminal will be stuck over here because
it's taking up whatever the progress
which is going to be done in the
container that will be in you know a
kind of attached to your terminal over
here and you will be getting the output
but the moment you come out of this like
you say control c so you will see that
you know it's basically sending the
request to the container that it's
getting stopped so you will be able to
see like the docker container list it's
not going to show you because the
container is in stop status so again you
have to do the restart of the container
to make sure that the container is up
and running
right so the attach one will help you to
go uh and attach your standard input and
output with your container with a
running container but when the moment
you comes out you will be able to uh
disconnect or shut down the container
and again i had to restart that
container over here in this one then
again of course we have like docker
weight
then container is there so this will
basically put the
container into a block status because
all the requests and all will be not
sent to the container and it will be
blocked and
if you really want to like
consume or if you want to make use of
the container you will not be able to do
that so docker weight command will us
kind of block the container and you know
if you again uh try to come out of that
so
again the request to the container will
be uh
resumed and they will be able to use on
that part so docker read command is
being used to block the container and
then we have docker attached to attach
to the container the standard input and
output and lastly is the docker kill
which is going to kill the container and
you will be able to
see that the container is in simply
killed status so it's uh you know it's
not like a stopped over here if it's
gracefully stopped then the exit code
definitely will be zero but in this case
since it's being killed the particular
status is 137 over here in this one so
that's a non-zero status code so that's
how where you will be able to manage the
containers on different aspects let's go
back to the main container so these were
some of the commands which was there
from the docker containers perspective
let's talk about some of the commands
from the share command perspective so
how we can share the docker images
so we have a typical pull push mechanism
which is there using which we can
actually interact with the docker hub or
a docker registry so uh if you really
want to pull the docker image so in that
case you can go for the docker pull
command
if you want to push an image to the
registry so you can use for the docker
push command if you want to execute a
command inside a particular running
container or you want to uh execute a
command or a script or something like
that so you can go for the docker is a
command and with that the execution will
be done and you will be able to get a
response so that will make sure that yes
whatever the execution you are trying to
do so that will be done over here in
this mechanism now let's see that how we
can do a pull and push activity to a
darker image so first of all the pull
command is pretty simple all you need to
do is that you need to say that okay i
want to pull a docker image
uh if let's say that our docker image is
already present then it's just going to
say that it's already up to date it's
already available there but if in some
cases you feel that the docker image is
not available and you want to pull it so
all you can do is that you can give that
a docker image name and that you can
give the tag also but in this case we
are using the tag as in latest
so that's the reason why even if you
provide or you don't provide it doesn't
really matter so i'm going to give like
a docker pull a mysql over here and the
moment i hit on this one what will
happen that it says this a particular
docker image is not available into my
system it's going to download it and
once it's going to be downloaded you
will be able to see that into your local
system so docker images is something
which is going to help you with the
commands and it will give you the
particular ways that how the docker
image is available so i can run like
docker images over here to see that what
are the different docker images which is
available in this manner
now if you really want to move any of
the docker image then of course you have
to do a docker login
and uh you will be doing the
uh you know the connectivity to the
docker hub and then establish the uh
connectivity and all so what you need to
do is that you can run the docker login
command we will also see this command in
the next particular slide but right now
we are just doing it because we want to
showcase that how the push really works
so uh you can actually give your
username that uh what username you are
holding up so the password does not
shows any activity but yes still it will
let you know that whether the login is
successful or not so in this case it
says login is successful so all you need
to do is let's say like i got this
custom image and i want to push it to
the docker hub so
you need to rename or you need to do a
tag over here because the same if you
run
docker push
custom
image
colon version 1. so if you do that it
will not be pushed into this
particular docker hub so it's going to
throw e error over here that the access
is denied so all you need to do is that
you need to do a tag here
so you have to rename it in such a way
that you should be able to uh use uh add
your username over there because
dockerhub will identify that if it's
there with your username then only it
will be pushed otherwise it will be
simply rejected over there so that's
what you need to do you need to rename
your docker image uh the same docker
image which you have you have to append
your username of the docker hub and once
that is done so all you need to do is
that you need to just run like docker
then push is there
then this image name and then version
one
so the moment you do this what will
happen that it will start transferring
those docker image to the docker hub you
see this uh specifies that yes this is
going to the docker hub docker dot io
where my username is there and this is
the custom image which is available
there so if i refresh my page on the
docker hub i will be able to see like
this public repo which is available
there but again this one just requires a
credentials and the login which we did
in just a last command where we ran the
docker login command to do the login to
the portal and after that only we are
able to do the setup and the
modifications
over here so that's how you do the login
and you are able to connect on that now
these are some of the pull and push
operations but let's say that if you got
a container which is up and running like
this is uh
right now we are not getting any
container which is available over here
so you can say like docker run
hyphen d httpd like i'm just running a
dummy container over here so that i will
be able to
show you this command now if you for
some reason want to go inside the
container and want to see some
processing and want to see some content
so you can run the command called docker
azik
iphone id and there you can give the
container id this is nothing but the
full format of the container id which is
given to you so you can use this one
also or you can use the shortened also
shortened value also you can use and
then the last we can say like bash
the moment you do this you will be going
you will be going inside the container
you see that this is the hostname which
is being shown as the container id you
can do a like psiphon ef command and it
will uh throw an error that the ps
command is not available because you are
running this command into the docker
into the docker container so using these
kind of commands which is not available
in container will help you to identify
that yes you are not on the host machine
you are in fact into the docker
container so that's the reason why you
can do it because for you the parts and
all everything is same the terminal is
also same so you may not be able to
differentiate in that part so that's the
reason why it's preferred that we use
that uh commands which is going to fail
but that's okay it will give you that
okay this command is failing because i'm
into the docker container right now so
that's what we are performing over here
right and you can come out of that but
still the docker container is going to
be still up and running over here in
this case so the container is not going
to
be down over here in this one so that's
how we manage the container we can go
inside and we can check some
informations and get some files there
so these are some of the commands where
we can interact now in order to log into
the docker hub because before doing the
docker push you have to log in you have
to get a credentials and the
connectivity with docker hub so you can
run the docker login command where you
can see that how the execution can be
done now using the docker login command
you can interact with the particular
docker hub you can set up the
credentials once the credentials is
being set up so what you can do is that
you can go ahead and say that okay the
configurations is done and we can go
ahead and we can perform the execution
so docker login is the command where you
can give the credentials docker info is
the command using which you can get the
information about the docker tool so
whatever the docker info is available
there so those things you can actually
get it over here in the case of the
docker info so docker info is going to
give you complete information that what
exactly you have the information
available over here on this one
and then we have the docker history so
using the docker history you can see
history of the docker image that what
exactly uh the mechanisms or what are
the different image ids are available
there
so this is basically giving you the
complete history on how the
docker image is prepared all the
commands is available there and that
will help you to eventually go and
understand that how the images can be
going on and you can manage on that part
so these are some of the couple of
options which is available there where
we can see that how the executions can
be done and we can go ahead on that
particular part so docker history is the
command again which will help you to see
that how you can go for the particular
mechanism and you can listen on on the
things over there so docker login was
already done previously when we tried to
push the image but again if you try to
run docker login you will be able to do
that now docker info is something which
will give some additional information
about the docker and all the
informations about the docker will be
given back to you over here in this one
so the complete clarity
uh then let's say that you got a docker
image called uh
httpd now you want to check the history
of this image that how this image is
prepared what are the different layers
which is available how many layers are
there how much size is being modified in
each and every layer so you can see that
we got a layer where we have a
particular changes of 7.838 mb but
pretty much the uh company from the
complete size of this httpd the major
portion is actually of the uh this one
the basic operating system which is
being implemented and then of course
there are some packages which got
deployed due to which this uh 60 mb and
7 mp size is coming up there so this
actually gives you the complete layer
wise mechanism that what are the
informations which is available that how
the modifications actually got modified
and got changed over here in this one so
this is the additional uh help which you
can get from the docker to
manage the containers here
so these are the ways where you can
interact with the docker hub if you
really want to create a volumes for the
container so you can go for the docker
volume create command so docker volume
create command is there using which you
can create the docker volumes and you
can pretty much do that uh setup so
docker volume create is the command
which is available there for that
particular part it will create a volume
for you now let's see that how we can
actually work with the volume so you can
run the command called docker volume ls
to find out at what are the different
volumes which is available there now if
you really want to create a volume over
here in this one so you can say like
darker volume create and you can go for
the volume name here
now the moment you do that what will
happen that a volume will be created and
you can validate it with the help of
docker volume ls command that whether
the volume is being created or not over
here so this is the way that how you can
manage the volumes onto the docker host
now let's talk about some of the docker
swamp commands here now docker spam
commands is there to set up a particular
mechanism where you can see that how you
can perform a setup you can actually go
ahead and see that how the setup and
modifications can be done
so docker swamp is there where we can
see that how the execution needs to be
done so
you can go for the command called docker
spam init command this will actually go
for an initialization of our docker
swamp cluster and once the docker spam
cluster is initialized then you can
pretty much go there and perform
whatever the executions you want to
perform you can do that and you can
execute as such over there so docker
swap init is a command using which you
can actually see that how the execution
needs to be done
and how we can perform the uh you know
mechanism and the changes over here so
docker sam init
hyphen fn advice uh adr address is there
which helps you to see that how the
executions can be done
now joins you have the docker swamp join
command which is available there now if
you go for docker spam join command so
you can have a particular host so
dockers swam join command is there which
you can run on the node machine and in
that case what will happen that node
will be a part of the docker spam
cluster
and then if you want to leave
from the swamp cluster then you can go
for docker swamp leaf command and it
will be simply removed from the docker
swamp cluster there some of the couple
of commands which using which we can
initialize or we can uh remove from the
docker spam cluster here so docker
spam is already being initialized or is
being created when the moment you do the
installation of docker so docker swam in
it is the command using which you can in
the last analyzer docker container now
once you analyze over here so after the
initialization you got a command you
which you want to add it like you want
to run it onto the docker spam
cluster
it will act like a worker node so that
you will be able to deploy the
containers on top of that also if you
want to join it as a manager so you can
also get the join token again so it will
give you the proper command
now if you run like docker
node ls so you will be able to see like
what are the different nodes which is
available there and for any reason if
you're not comfortable with that and you
want to reinitialize your docker spam
cluster so all you can do is that you
can say like docker
swamp
leave hyphen f and you will be left out
of the docker spam and now if you want
to run like knock docker node ls you
will not be able to get that output
because it's saying that there is no uh
particular swap manager which is
available so you can run docker spam we
need or you can run the join command to
connect to that specific node but we
have already left it and nothing is
available over here so that's a way that
how you can manage like what are the
different docker swamp commands we can
typically run to manage the docker spam
cluster now let's talk about the docker
compose commands now docker compose
commands is actually there using which
we can create multiple containers it's
not only one container which can we can
create we can create go for multiple
creations of the containers with the
help of docker compose file so docker
compose hyphen version is the u command
which we can give you the version of
docker compose which is being used so
here we use a particular vml format file
which will help us to create the
multiple containers we defined the
services that what are the different
containers we want to create here and
then with the help of docker hyphen
compose dot ml file we can create or we
can have that particular docker compose
file set up over here in this case so
docker hyphen compose.vml file is used
to do the setup and the modification so
that you will be able to have the
modifications done and you will be able
to find out a particular
multiple containers gets created all
together so docker compose is there is
the way that how you can do the setup
how you are going to run the docker
compose file so in that case you are
going to run the docker hyphen compose
up command which will help you to set up
like how the compose can be done and
once you are done with the docker hyphen
compose up command so using this the
compose will be done and the containers
will be up and running so these are the
commands using which we can manage
multiple containers using the docker
compose one so let's try to run some
commands related to docker compose so
docker hyphen compose iphone version
will let you know that what exactly
version of docker compose is installed
into your system so you can run typical
apt command to do the installation so
docker hyphen composes the package name
which you can install so that the
executables and the package can be
installed into your system onto the
server now all we need to do is that we
need to create a docker compose file so
what we need to do is that we need to
create a docker hyphen compose dot yml
file is the default name of the vml file
which we want to create here that's the
standard name so once you create this
all you need to do is like you need to
put some values attributes the very
first one is the version value that what
version of uh this particular attribute
you want to create here let's say that i
want to create a version too so i will
configure here that yes the version 2 is
what i require i want to set up over
here in this one
now again if i want to configure that
what are the different services we want
to run because services is the main
thing which we will be running on this
machine on the server here so that's
what we require so then we need to put
for a particular service called web so
web service we want to search and we
want to run and then again we need to
take care about the spacing because
that's a very important part
and we need to provide the values of the
image
and
all these configurations here so that
you should be able to set up like how
the uh images and how the docker images
can be built up over here so uh web is
the service which you want to deploy and
then of course the image is the
attribute which is there for the web
that yes engine is the one which we are
trying to build up now you can give the
ports configuration also so you can say
like ports
and inside that you can say like what
port mapping you want to perform so you
can say like
um 8080 so or sorry 80
is what you can dash for the nginx
because it runs on 80 port but now i
have to run like 80 port i want to
attach that port over here in this one
so i can specify that 80 port should be
available in this one so i'm going to
save this one here and i'm going to run
a command called docker iphone compose
up now this will run the containers in
the interactive mode but if you feel
that i want to run in the detach mode so
you can say like hyphen d also which
will of course run these ones into the
detach mode and it will be executed so
it will process your docker compose file
and since you have used a standard name
called hyphen docker hyphen compose dot
primal so it will automatically pick
that docker or details and start
creating the container hi guys in
today's video i am going to show you how
to install ubuntu on kubernetes
kubernetes is an open source platform
used for deployment and management of
containers so let's get started now the
first step is to install the necessary
dependencies using two of the commands
first is sudo apt get update which gets
all the updates
and then you have to enter a password
so this will take a few seconds
that's done the next step is to install
app transport https this is basically
used to make repositories via https so
let's go ahead with that sudo
okay that's done going ahead the next
thing we have to do is to install the
docker dependency using the command sudo
apt install docker dot io
you have to choose why
and this will take a few minutes
okay that's done so after installing the
docker we have to start and enable the
docker using the command sudo system ctl
start docker and sudo system ctl enable
dock
so now the docker is enabled so now we
are done with the first step of
installation the next step is we have to
install the necessary components for
kubernetes before that we have to
install the curl command because current
command is used to send data using a url
syntax let's install the curl command
using the command sudo apt-get install
curve
[Music]
so you have to select y
and this will take few minutes
so moving on the next step we have to do
is download and add key for kubernetes
installation from a url so let's go
ahead with that sudo curl
so this is where we get the key and then
we have to add it using sudo apt key add
and it's done so the next step is we
have to add a repository in a certain
location so before doing that we have to
change the permission of that file so we
do that using c or sudo c h mode command
okay so the permission is changed now
let's go ahead and save this file in
that location first we have to enter
this command into the file
this is a url
save as
so we have to save it in this location
let's rename this to
kubernetes
dot list
now let's see
okay so here it is now moving forward
now we have to check for any updates
available
in the next command we are going to
install the kubernetes components that
is cubelet cubadium cubectyl and
kubernetes cni so let's go ahead with
that
so this is going to take a few minutes
now that's done so the next step we have
to initialize the master node and to do
this we have to first use a swap off
command to disable the swapping on other
devices so let's do that sudo swap of
hyperlink
now let's go ahead with the
initialization sudo
cube adm init
this is going to take a few minutes
okay so before going to the next step to
start the cluster we have to use these
three commands let's just copy paste it
okay that's done
so
moving forward the next step is to
deploy paths using the following command
[Music]
now the pods have been deployed to our
network to see all the parts you have to
use the command sudo cubic till get pods
there you can see the parts that have
been deployed hello and welcome to
simply learn today we're going to be
giving you a kubernetes tutorial will
provide the overview of how and why you
should be using kubernetes but before we
get started don't forget to hit the
subscribe button and the like button if
you want to get notified about
additional content from simply learn and
as always if you have any comments about
the material that you're about to see
and you have any questions please post
them in the comments below we do read
them and we do reply to them so with
that said let's jump in so we're going
to go through a bunch of things today
around kubernetes we're going to cover
what kubernetes is and why you should be
using it along with the features of
kubernetes we're also going to take a
little bit of a look at kubernetes
versus docker swarm as the two
technologies do tend to get referred to
quite frequently and then we're going to
do a deep dive into the actual
kubernetes architecture itself and how
kubernetes runs and operates within your
network and then finally we're going to
look at some kubernetes use cases of how
you can actually apply best learnings
that other companies have used with
kubernetes we'll finish everything off
with a demo where we actually step
through and use some of the actual codes
that you can actually use to run
from your terminal window to actually
activate kubernetes itself so with that
said let's jump in so why kubernetes
well kubernetes is really being built
from allowing you to be able to have a
more reliable infrastructure the tool
itself is designed to manage the
containers you have within your network
it's very modular in architecture which
allows it to be very easy to be able to
maintain and to be able to scale and
meet the demands that your current
customers are offering you today the
actual ability for you to be able to
deploy and update software at scale is
really at the heart and center of
kubernetes is really one of the reasons
why kubernetes was created was to be
able to scale up the deployment of
software into tens of thousands of
networks and servers uh within a data
center and then finally when you start
working with kubernetes really what
you're doing is laying the foundation
for building cloud native applications
and part of this comes from the
architecture and history of kubernetes
which we'll get to in a little bit but
it's good to know that as you're using
kubernetes and containerized solutions
that you're really building out an
infrastructure that's designed for
cloud-centric solution delivery so let's
dig into why what kubernetes is so the
history of kubernetes is that it was
originally developed by google google
actually uh used the precursor to
kubernetes to manage and maintain the
data structured and data infrastructure
that they had within their network they
really liked it and one of the big
benefits that kubernete that google
provided is that they converted their
code into an open source program that
they released as kubernetes in 2014 and
made an open source this means that any
company can use kubernetes there's no
charge for it all you have to do is know
how to use the command lines to actually
get up and running the benefit of
kubernetes being open source is that
most cloud providers now support
kubernetes so whether you're using
microsoft azure you're using google
cloud or aws you'll find that you can
actually use kubernetes and kubernetes
and edit core really helped eliminate
manual processes so it allows for
deploying and scaling your
container-based solutions much more
effortless within a cloud environment so
let's jump into the features of
kubernetes and why you'd want to be
using it and we have a number of
features that we want to kind of step
through again the first thing that
kubernetes is a strong benefit of is
that it eliminates those manual
processes and allows you to automate
them the benefit you have from this is
that you can then scale up your
automation across your entire network so
whether you are managing 10 nodes within
your network or whether you're managing
10 000 doesn't matter you have the
ability to scale that something you
simply didn't have before kubernetes
also will manage the actual containers
themselves um including the security and
the storage and the networking within
those containers the great uh benefit of
working with kubernetes is that uh not
only is it a cloud-centric solution but
it was really built from a core
need of a secure solution so security is
at the heart and center of all the work
you're doing which really helps benefit
any teams scaling out containers your
kubernetes environment will be
constantly monitored and so that when
you have nodes that have your containers
the health of those nodes is being
constantly communicated back to
the kubernetes environment so that the
entire environment is always being
managed and checked so if you have any
um additional hosting and launching that
needs to be done uh kubernetes will help
you automate those manual processes uh
if something does go wrong you can
actually set up your kubernetes
environment to do an automatic roll back
again this is just allowing you to have
that confidence that when you're
deploying a solution that everything is
going to work within that environment
and then finally kubernetes will allow
you to mount and add the storage needed
to run your apps so whether you have
storage such as a local ssd storage
device physically on the hardware or if
you're connecting to storage via the
cloud kubernetes will allow you to
access the storage you need how you're
accessing it so let's look a little bit
into the differences between kubernetes
and docker swarm so if we just step back
a little bit uh kubernetes and docker
often get connected with each other uh
largely because kubernetes manages
containers and docker is really famous
for creating the most popular container
management solution which is called
docker if you're a developer you're
probably already using docker today so
one of the things that kubernetes is
really really good at is that it manages
containers at scale just massive volume
of containers docker swarm is docker's
alternative to kubernetes it's a tool
that allows you to also manage large
number large numbers of containers um
there are differences between the two of
them and right now without doubt the
most popular um open source solution out
there is kubernetes from google it just
has a massive community behind it and
the community uh really have embraced um
kubernetes um yes the original product
was by developed by google but google
has been great steward and they've
allowed the community to drive the
future evolution of the product uh
docker swarm is actually managed and
developed by docker um there is a
smaller community but it is also a very
passionate community and the reason
being is that both products are actually
pretty good and you just really kind of
have to choose which one you want to go
with without doubt there is more
customization and extensions built for
kubernetes simply because the community
is just so much bigger than the docker
swarm community but with that said
docker swarm is really easy to set up so
if you are used to working within the
docker environment you will be able to
set up docker swarm very very quickly
whereas kubernetes does require some
heavy lifting to get up and running now
with that said if you are using
microsoft azure or google cloud very
often those environments will actually
set up kubernetes for you so you don't
have to do it and you can actually then
focus on writing the instructions to
maintain your kubernetes environment uh
kubernetes um has extremely high fault
tolerance again
it's because kubernetes is has been road
tested the foundation for kubernetes is
based on managing sites such as gmail
google.com youtube i mean just
incredibly robust environment compared
to docker swamp which has lower fault
tolerance and and this really kind of
leads into
the final areas where kubernetes does
guarantee um strong clusters and
management just a really reliable
environment dr swarm however is able to
take containers and deploy them into
large casters very very quickly two
interesting differences is that with
kubernetes the load balancing is still
manual and be interesting to watch how
kubernetes matures that skill set uh in
contrast uh load balancing is automatic
within docker swarm so let's dig into
the kubernetes architecture and just
kind of expose some of those key
elements um if you're interested in
actually having a very deep dive into
kubernetes architecture we have already
got another video and we should have a
link in the comments that you can select
that will take you to that video as well
but this will provide you an overview as
well um so the way that kubernetes runs
is that it uses nodes to actually manage
all the individual hardware within a
specific unit and so a node is really a
physical machine
in a data center or a virtual machine
and when you're setting up an
environment on a cloud environment such
as microsoft azure or google cloud or
aws kubernetes will be managing the
containers within that node so it's
important to know that kubernetes itself
doesn't work with the individual nodes
but actually works with the cluster as a
whole and and why that's important is
that it's a tool to manage your entire
environment it's not going to come down
and manage the individual node itself
it's going to match the entire
environment the actual control of data
within a cluster and it's very very
flexible within kubernetes you can have
local storage such as an ssd
card or a traditional local storage or
you can actually connect to the cloud
and use cloud-based storage and the
benefit that cloud-based storage offers
you is that you are increasingly moving
your solution into more of a
hardware free environment cloud-based
architecture
where you're not reliant on a physical
piece of hardware within your data
center and why that's important is that
it gives you the opportunity to scale up
your solutions much more effectively so
if you need to increase the hard drive
space you can do that very easily from
the cloud whereas local hardware is a
little bit harder to manage great news
kubernetes gives you both options to be
able to
choose from and so the the next layer
down is the actual management of the
application that's within a container
and as mentioned earlier docker is the
most popular container solution out
there and again if you're a developer
you're probably already using docker as
it was a natural maturity from using a
virtual machine but kubernetes itself
will actually manage the containers that
you have within your nodes and so you
have a collection of containers working
together and then you pull those
together into what's called a pod and
what's great is kubernetes will actually
manage the health of that part so if a
container or a pod fails kubernetes will
automatically deploy out a replica so
your entire environment can stay running
and being efficient and so the pots
themselves will actually be managed by
kubernetes and you really want to
let kubernetes um do this because it's
allowing you to
step away from the manual management of
pods your environment is just going to
be healthier relying on kubernetes to do
the actual management of all the pods
you have out there so you are able to
allow access to from services outside of
your kubernetes and this is done through
a process called ingress and
going back earlier we talked about how
security is a key part of all the work
that goes into kubernetes and this is a
great example of where you can use an
external service but still have that
layer of security that is vital for your
solution because to be able to provide
the ingress connection uh kubernetes
requires an ssl connection which um
automatically allows for a secure data
transfer absolutely fantastic so here we
have an overview of the actual
architecture on the right hand side we
have our nodes and the pods within our
nodes and within those pods are the
containers on the left hand side we have
the master architecture and the master
architecture is the actual brains behind
the work that you're doing it's actually
managing the schedules the controllers
for all of the nodes and then at the
bottom left hand side we have commands
which are written on a local workstation
and those commands are pushed up to the
master so let's kind of dig a little bit
further into the architecture of the
master um so the master itself is uh
comprised of a number of key components
and again this is the tool that's going
to manage your uh entire kubernetes
infrastructure the key components that
you have are the etcd control manager
scheduler api server and the key four
components are etcd
or the cluster store the controller
manager the scheduler and the api server
the cluster store is the tool where all
the details of the work that you're
doing is stored and it's going to manage
the rules going to manage all the
instructions and this is where you're
going to post that information the
controller is actually going to then
perform the tasks that are stored in the
cluster store and as you'd expect the
schedule is the tool that actually
controls when instructions and tasks are
pushed out to
all the pods and nodes within your
network and then finally you have an api
server which allows you to be able to
control all the operations the actual
operations themselves are all
instructions written um as rest
instructions and which allows you to
take advantage of the security that has
been built into rest and so you end up
with a worker slave architecture and
slaves are all the different nodes and
pods within your network and so a part
itself will have multiple one or more
multiple containers and then each
container and then each pod will have a
docker container uh a kubelet and a
kubernetes proxy and the these are tools
to allow you to communicate back up to
the master layer so the docker is the
actual container itself and this is
going to actually run your application
and
the instructions here are to pull down
the correct container from the docker
images that you have within your library
the cubelet is going to manage your
containers and your container
instructions that will be deployed to
the cubelet are going to be written in
either yaml or json format yaml is just
great if you haven't had a chance to
start working with yaml i certainly
encourage you to do so it's very easy to
pick up if you know any xml you'll pick
up yammer very quickly and finally the
kubernetes proxy is the tool that
interacts with the master environment
within the kubernetes network and allows
all the instructions from that are
pushed to the kubelet and to docker to
be able to perform effectively so let's
have a look at some of the companies
using kubernetes there are a lot and if
you're doing any work today in the cloud
and even if you're just starting off and
doing some simple
work in the cloud there's a really good
chance that you are using kubernetes but
some of the companies that you would are
probably not surprised at using
kubernetes are spotify sap ebay um and
of course uh some of the the big
companies out there google with their
entire network of solutions and
microsoft with office and their tools so
let's take a a step into a youtube now
let's have a look at a kubernetes use
case and in this example we're going to
look at the new york times and how they
use kubernetes to solve a problem that
their iit department was struggling with
so when new york times started working
after their data centers their their
actual deployments were small and the
applications were managed across vms but
the problem is is that as new york times
became more of a digital company they
started building more digital solutions
and at some point they realized that uh
what they needed to do was to embrace
the cloud and move all their solutions
to the cloud however their first step of
using the cloud and this is i think
typical for a lot of companies is that
they treated the cloud hosted provider
in the same way as they would with a
data center and they at some point they
realized they had to take a change and
this is where the development team came
in and they said look how about we stop
thinking of our solutions as a data
center even though they're being run in
amazon and start thinking them as cloud
first solutions and so what they
proposed and what they ended up doing
was using google cloud platform with
kubernetes as servers um to
provide greater efficiency and so by
using kubernetes they had the following
advantages they're able to deliver
solutions at a much faster speed and in
the world of digital content speed is
everything they were able to reduce the
time for deployment from minutes to
seconds and by doing this they were able
to increase the amount of time that
uptime for the actual infrastructure um
updates began to be deployed
independently and when required so you
didn't have to schedule an event when
you did the deployment it just happened
and there was more unified approach to
deployment from the engineering staff
which just made the whole solution more
portable so the fundamental end line for
the new york times is that by leveraging
kubernetes they were able to
automatically manage their deployments
and scheduling of solutions instead of
having to do solutions through a more
traditional ticket-based system it just
really speed up the efficiency of the
new york times website so let's finally
kind of look into some of the important
terminologies before we take our time to
do a demo so we have six terms that
we're gonna look through um and uh we'll
let you uh uh read through these but uh
we have a cluster which is a set of
machines physical vertical in which
applications are managed and run we have
a node that are the working machines
that run containerized applications and
other workloads there is the pod which
is within a node and is a group of
containers that are deployed together on
the same host we have replication
controllers and a replication controller
is used to define a paused life cycle
rather than to create the pods directly
we have a selector which is an
expression matched label to filter
specific resources uh labels are key
value pairs that are attached to objects
such as parts and the key value pair or
the label can be filter organize and
perform operations on resources
replication sets define how many
replicas of each pod will be running and
managed when you want to either replace
a pod when it dies annotation is a label
with much larger data capacity a name is
a resource as it is identified volume is
the direction which data is accessible
to a container name spaces provide
additional qualification to resources
name and then finally service is an
abstraction of a top-tier pods which
provide a single ip address and dns name
by which the pods can be accessed so at
this time what we want to do is take you
through kubernetes demo actually runs
through some of these basic controls so
i'm going to take you through a video of
how to actually install kubernetes um
and to use some of the basic
instructions so kubernetes is the most
widely used platform for
container management the first step is
to actually install the necessary
dependencies so let's see if there's any
updates first so the first so to check
if there's any updates we use the
command sudo app dash get update we're
entering our password and this looks
like it's going to take a few minutes
because we've got a few updates that
need to be running all right we're done
all right next we're going to write sudo
apt-get install dash y apt dash
transport dash https and this will
install all the dependencies we need to
actually start installing the solutions
needed for kubernetes all right that was
quick now we're going to put in the
docker dependency and the way we do that
is write the command sudo apt install
docker dot io i'll go to typo correct
that quickly and put in y so for yes and
we continue and it's going to take a
while because we're going to download
and install docker off the internet and
it's quite a large installation now
would be a good time to go get a cup of
coffee because it'll take us about a
minute to get this all done once we
actually have docker installed we'll let
you go ahead and we'll start docker and
enable docker using our sudo commands
all right so that's all done so let's
start to enable docker we're going to
using so we're going to use sudo system
ctl start docker and sudo system ctl
enable docker this would be quite quick
so the next step is to install all the
components for kubernetes and we're
going to uh install the curl command and
then kuberlette cube c
and then cube adm and we're going to
install all the necessary tools we'll do
the curl command cubelet cubic c2 and
cube adm and so let's go ahead and put
in the sudo apt-get install curl we're
going to get a prompt we can say yes for
that
and then after this we'll go ahead and
install kubernetes so the first what
we're going to do is we're going to
actually put in the kubernetes key so
that's going to be sudo curl dash s and
then we have
long url which is https
packages.cloudgoogle.com apt doc apt
dash key dot gpg
sudo apt dash key there we go and create
my typo there okay now we have to go
ahead and change permissions of a folder
so we do that with sudo chmod
777 slash etc
apt
sources.list.d all right we're good okay
now you want to go ahead and open up
your text editor and we're going to make
um an actual edit
and we're going to create a simple file
and so what we're going to type in is
the following command db http
dot kubernetes dot io slash kubernetes
dash xenial
main and we're going to save this file
in the etc folder and then look for and
then
apt which is going to be down a little
bit and there we have it and we're going
to save it in the
apt-get updates and we're going to name
this file as
kubernetes.list and we'll save that and
then we can close out the notepad and go
back to the terminal window and let's
look and see if there are any updates
again so we're going to go ahead and run
apt-get update and it's going to run any
updates from what we've created and we
want to check what's in the folder and
so we do
cat slash accept
etc
apt sources.this dot d slash kubernetes
dot list and there we are it shows what
we have in that text file and so we're
going to go ahead and we're going to uh
install uh cubelet cubic cubic 2 and
cube adm but first we're going to have
to initialize the master i'm going to
show you what an error you would get if
you were to install cubelet um and the
other files too quickly you get the
following error
all right so we have installed cubelet
qbadm cubex tool and kubernetes cni and
so we're going to go ahead and use sudo
swap
dash hyphen a and now we're going to
initialize the master node and we're
going to do that with sudo cube
adm in it and this will take a few
minutes for it to initialize
all right so that's all done all right
so we're going to deploy the pod to a
network and we have two commands that
we're going to use we use sudo cube
cube ctl apply and then we have a
long
pathway to type out which is dash f
https raw githubs
content.com courios final master
documentation cube dash
yml
what we we have to do is we have to
actually go ahead and deploy the nodes
first so we're going to do that by
creating
mkdi dash p
and then we have
dollar sign home dash dot cube we'll
create that new directory and sudo cp
dash i and then the path will be uh etc
slash kubernetes admin dot conf and then
dollar sign home slash dot cube dot
slash config
and then final one will be
sudo
chow wn dollar sign open paren id
all right now we're going to go ahead
and deploy and uh let's see
oh yeah i think i have a typo in my
command here yep oh yeah i did have a
typo and so um i've got that incorrect
now so documentation is actually spelt
with a t not an s and then we're going
to go ahead and we're going to put in
the next
line which is pseudo cubic uh cube ctl
apply
dash f and then we're just going to
change a little bit of the
actual link here and that runs great and
now we want to be able to see all of the
parts that we have in our network and so
we're going to do that by
writing the command sudo qbec ctcl get
pods dash all dash dash name spaces and
it should list all of our pods we only
have one
there we are there's all of our content
now we're going to so there's only one
node so let's see what we have here so
we're going to use the command sudo you
know cubic tl get nodes there we are
just one node so our final step is to
actually go ahead and deploy a service
and so what we're going to go ahead is
deploy the nginx as service and we're
going to do that with the command sudo
cubex ctl run dash dash image equals
nginx and we're going to put this into
port 80 so it's going to be nginx
app dash dash port equals 80
environment or emt equals uh ubun cone
open quotes so domain equals cluster
close quotes
and we're going to write one more
command which is sudo cube ctl expose
deployment nginx dash app dash dash port
equals 80
name equals nginx dash http and once
we've done this we'll be able to then
run the command to actually see our
services and there'll be quite a few of
them
and our final command is sudo docker ps
dash a
and we have quite a lot of lists quite a
lot of services listed so there you are
that's the instructions on how to get
docker up and running and uh with some
basic commands um it it's worth going
through a few times to
get right um but uh once you actually
have um the uh kubernetes environment up
and running and managing your docker
environment and containers it's
extremely powerful welcome to kubernetes
architecture from simplyland we're going
to take a deep dive into the kubernetes
architecture if you're new to kubernetes
we already have an introduction that
goes and provides an overview of
kubernetes and we have the link below so
you can go straight to that if you want
to have a refresher otherwise hang
around and join us in this presentation
and if you want to see more of these
videos hit the subscribe button and if
you want to get notified hit the
notification bell and every time we post
up a new video you'll get the
notification right onto your phone or on
your desktop that the new video has been
uploaded and as always if you have any
questions please post them in the
comments below we do read the questions
and we try to respond to all of them as
quickly as we can with that said let's
jump into kubernetes architecture so
we're going to break out the
presentation into the following areas
we're going to cover what kubernetes is
and why you want to be using it we're
going to introduce the actual
architecture and provide an overview of
how it contains the containers and the
other components that you'd have within
the architecture we'll also compare
kubernetes with docker swarm and one of
the things that you hear with kubernetes
almost in the same
breath as darker and we have to be
careful not to confuse docker from a
container point of view and docker swarm
which is a container management tool and
kubernetes is also a container
management tool so compare the two of
those and then we'll look at the
hardware and software components and
then finally do a deep dive into the
architecture of kubernetes and provide a
case study of where kubernetes has been
used successfully in the past so let's
jump into this so what actually is
kubernetes so kubernetes is a tool that
was designed to actually help manage and
contain large groups of containers it
was developed originally by google out
of the google book solution and then
open source by google the actual
environment allows you to manage large
groups of containers so if you're a
developer in devops and you're working
with docker then you're used to the
concept of the container and you'll also
know that containers and cloud
technologies tend to be almost breathed
in the same breath so the work that
you're doing with kubernetes is to be
able to manage large groups of
containers inside of the cloud the thing
that's great about working with
kubernetes is that it is incredibly
flexible and allows you to have
incredibly complex applications run
efficient efficiently so let's step into
why you'd want to use kubernetes so a
couple of key points uh kubernetes
itself is an open source solution
originally developed by google but it is
available on most cloud platforms today
so aws google cloud microsoft azure all
of them support kubernetes and what
you'll find is as you're setting up your
infrastructure particularly if you're
using containers you'll see that the
support for kubernetes is floated up
very very efficiently and effectively by
all three vendors it's extremely um
useful for being able to manage large
modular environments and that's really
kind of these i think one of the big
benefits of kubernetes is its modularity
is that it really breaks down containers
into their smaller parts and once you do
that it becomes much more efficient for
you as an administrator to be able to
manage that entire entire environment
the reproductibility of kubernetes is
extremely high you can build up
infrastructures very quickly and have
them being able to manage and have
containers coming on and off and killed
and uh created to be able to help load
balance your entire environment and so
again you know we keep talking about
containers but that's really what
kubernetes is all about is being able to
manage your applications that are
managed through containers and being
able to do that in a virtualized
infrastructure and the thing that's also
really good with kubernetes is it's
really easy to deploy solutions you just
have to use a simple curl call and you
can actually push out your kubernetes
infrastructure so let's have an overview
of the kubernetes architecture so
kubernetes is really broken up into
three key areas you have your
workstation where you develop your
commands and you push out those commands
to your master and the master is
comprised of
four key areas um which essentially
control all of your nodes and and the
node contains multiple pods and each pod
has your docker container built into it
so consider that you could have a really
almost an infinite number of pods sorry
infinite number of nodes are being
managed
by the master environment so you have
your cluster which is a collection of
servers that maintain the availability
and the compute power such as ram cpu
and disk utilization and you have the
master which is really components that
control and schedule uh the activities
of your network and then you have the
node which actually hosts the actual
docker virtual machine itself um and be
able to actually control and communicate
back to the master the health of that
pod and we'll get into more detail in
the architecture later in the
presentation so
you know you keep hearing me talk about
containers but they really are the
center of the work that you're doing
with
kubernetes and can the concept around
kubernetes and containers is really just
a natural evolution of where we've been
with internet and digital technologies
over the last 10 15 years so
before kubernetes you had tools where
you're either running virtual machines
or you're running data centers that had
to maintain and
manage and notify you of any
interruptions in your network kubernetes
is the tool that actually comes in and
helps address those interruptions and
manages them for you so the solution to
this is the use of containers so uh you
can think of containers as that natural
evolution from you know uh 15 20 years
ago you would have written your code and
posted it to a data center and more
recently you probably posted your code
to a virtual machine and then move the
virtual machine and now you actually
just work directly into a container and
everything is self-contained and can be
pushed out to your
environment and the thing that's great
about containers they're isolated
environments very easy for developers to
work in them but it's also really easy
for
operations teams to be able to move a
container into production so let's kind
of step and back and look at a competing
product to kubernetes which is docker
swarm now one of the things that we have
to remember is that uh docker um
containers which are extremely popular
um built by the company docker and made
open source and docker actually has
other products one of those other
products is docker swarm and docker
swarm is a tool that allows you to be
able to manage multiple containers so if
we look at some of the uh the benefits
of using docker swarm versus kubernetes
and one things that you'll find is that
both tools have strengths and weaknesses
but it's really good that they're both
out there because it helps keep it
really kind of justifies uh the
importance of having these kind of tools
so a kubernetes was designed originally
from the ground up to be auto scaling
whereas docker swarm isn't the load
balancing is automatic on docker swan
whereas with kubernetes you have to
manually configure load balancing across
your nodes the installation for docker
swarm is really fast and easy i mean you
can be up and running within minutes a
kubernetes takes a little bit more time
is a little bit more complicated
eventually you'll get there um i mean
it's not like it's going to take you
days and weeks but it's it is a tool
that's when you compare the two docker
swarms much easier to get up and running
now what's interesting is that
kubernetes is incredibly scalable and
it's you know that's its real strength
is its ability to have strong clusters
whereas with docker swarm its cluster
strength isn't um as strong when
compared to kubernetes now you compare
it to anything else on the market it's
really good um so this is kind of a
splitting hairs kind of comparison but
kubernetes really does have the
advantage here if you're looking at the
two compared to each other for
scalability kubernetes was designed for
by google to scale up and support uh
google cloud network infrastructure they
uh both allow you to be able to share um
storage volumes with docker you can
actually do it with any container uh
with um that is managed by the docker
swamp whereas with kubernetes it manages
the storage with the pods and a product
can have multiple containers within it
but you can't take it down to the level
of the container interestingly uh
kubernetes does have a graphical user
interface um for being able to control
and manage uh the environment the
reality however is that you're likely to
be using terminal uh to actually make
the controls and commands to control
your
either docker swarm or kubernetes
environment um it's great that it has a
gui and to get you started but once
you're up and running you're going to be
using terminal window for those fast
quick administrative controls that you
need to make so let's look at the
hardware components for
kubernetes so and what's interesting is
that kubernetes is extremely light of
all the systems that we're looking at
it's extremely lightweight
it
allows you to have if you compare it to
like a virtual machine which is very
heavy and you know
kubernetes is extremely lightweight and
hardly uses any resources at all
interesting enough though is that if you
are looking at the usage of cpu it's
better to actually take it for
the cluster as a whole rather than
individual nodes because the nodes will
actually combine together to give you
that whole compute power again this is
why kubernetes works really well in the
cloud where you can do that kind of
activity rather than if you're running
in your own data center um so you can
have persistent volumes such as a local
ssd
or you can actually attach to a cloud
data storage again kubernetes is really
designed for the cloud i would encourage
you to use cloud storage wherever
possible rather than relying on physical
storage uh the reason being is that if
you connect to cloud storage and you
need to flex your your storage the cloud
will do that for you i mean that's just
an inherent part of why you'd have cloud
storage whereas if you're connecting to
physical storage you're always
restricted to the limitations of the
physical hardware so let's kind of pivot
and look at the software components as
compared to the hardware components so
the main part of the
components is the actual container and
all of the software running in the
container runs on linux so if you have
docker installed as a developer on your
machine it's actually running inside of
linux and that's what makes it so
lightweight and really one of the things
that you'll find is that most data
centers and cloud providers now are
running predominantly on linux inside of
the um the container itself is then
managed inside of a pod and a pod is
really just a group of containers
bundled together and
the kubernetes scheduler and proxy
server then actually manage what how the
pods are actually pushed out into your
kubernetes environment the the pods
themselves can actually then share
resources both networking and storage so
the parts aren't um pushed out manually
they're actually managed through a layer
of abstraction and part of their
deployment and and this is the strength
of kubernetes you use um to find your
infrastructure and then kubernetes will
then manage it for you and there isn't
that problem of um manual management of
pods if you have to manage the
deployment of them and you that's simply
taken away and it's completely automated
and the the final area of software
services is on ingress and this is
really the secure way of being able to
have communication from outside of the
cluster and passing of information into
that cluster and again this is done
securely through ssl layers and allows
you to ensure that security is at the
center of the work that you have within
your kubernetes environment so let's
dive now into the actual architecture
before we start looking at a use case of
how kubernetes is being employed so
kubernetes again is um we looked at this
uh diagram at the beginning of the
presentation and there are really three
key areas there's the workstation where
you develop your commands and then you
have your master environment which uh
controls the
scheduling the communication um and the
actual
commands that you have created and
pushes those out and manages the health
of your entire node network and each
node has various pods so we they break
this down so the master node is the most
vital component and with the master uh
you have four key controls you have etc
uh controller manager scheduler and api
server the cluster store etc this
actually measures the details and values
that you've developed on your local
workstation um and then we'll work with
the out the control schedule and api
server to communicate that out those
instructions of how your infrastructure
should look like to your entire network
uh the control manager is really an api
server and again um this is all about
security so we use restful apis which
can be packaged in ssl to communicate
back and forth across your
pods and the master and indeed the
services within each of them as well so
um at every single layer of extraction
uh the communication is secure uh the
schedule as the name would imply really
schedules um when tasks get sent out to
the actual nodes themselves now the
nodes themselves are are dumb downloads
they just have uh the applications um
running on them the master and the sperm
is really doing all of the work uh to
make sure that your entire network is
running um efficiently and then you have
the api server which has your rest
commands and the communication and back
and forth across your networks that is
secure and efficient so your node
environment is where all the work that
you do with your containers gets pushed
out too so
a work is really a it's a combination of
containers in each container will then
logically run together on that node so
you'd have a collection of containers on
a node that all make logical sense to
have together within each node you have
docker and this is your isolated
environment for running your container
you have your kubelet which is a service
for conveying information back and forth
um to the service about the actual
health of the kubernetes node itself and
then finally you have the proxy server
and the proxy server is able to manage
the nodes the volumes the the creation
of new containers um and actually helps
pass the communicate the health of the
container back up to the master to see
whether or not the container should be
either killed stop started or
updated so finally let's look at see
where kubernetes is being used by other
companies so you know kubernetes is
being used by a lot of companies and
they're really using it to help manage
complex existing systems so that they
can have greater performance and with
the end goal of being able to delight
the customer increase value to the
customer and enhance increased value and
revenue into the organization so an
example of this is a company called
blackrock where they actually went
through the process of implementing
kubernetes uh so they
so blackrock had a challenge where they
needed to be able to have much more
dynamic access to their resources uh
they were running complex installations
on people's desktops and it was just
really really difficult to be able to
manage their entire infrastructure and
so they actually went and pivoted to
using kubernetes and this allowed them
to be able to be much more scalable and
expansive in the in the management of
their infrastructure and as you can
imagine kubernetes was then hooked into
their entire existing system and has
really become a key part of the success
that blackrock is now experiencing of a
very stable infrastructure um and the
bottom line is that blackrock is now
able to have confidence in their
infrastructure and be able to give that
confidence
as back to their customers through the
implementation and more rapid deployment
of additional features and services and
i welcome you to this short tutorial and
demo on kubernetes kubernetes specific
to aws cloud platform so what's a part
of this tutorial and demo what's in
store for you at offset i would like to
cover the basics of orchestration tools
as most of you would know kubernetes is
one of the most popular orchestration
tools in recent times specifically for
applications which are cloud native and
deployed on some or the other types of
containers but what are these
organization tools why would one need to
use orchestration tools what are the
facilities or features provided by this
orchestration tools that's the first
thing that i'm going to cover after that
i will pick two orchestration tools
specific to container management docker
swarm versus kubernetes i'm going to
compare them with regard to the features
that they provide the use cases that
they cover what facilities that they
provide and when to use what after that
i will get into a little bit details of
the kovernis architecture what exactly
is required for setting up a kubernetes
cluster what runs in a control plane or
a master node what runs as a part of the
worker node after that i will end the
tutorial by running you through a demo
by setting up a three node kubernetes
cluster on aws platform i will use
something called as cops which is one of
the admin tools for setting up
production grade kubernetes cluster so i
will use this to set up a three node
cluster on aws all right now that we set
the context right let me get started so
what are orchestration tools
the application development and the
lifecycle management from the time the
application is developed connecting the
source code to your continuous
integration to testing them all along
your development process and eventually
moving it down to production managing
your production servers the dependencies
that your software has
the requirement that it has in terms of
the hardware the features of fault
tolerance self-healing capabilities auto
scaling all this has complicated over
the last few years as a part of devops
one thing that everyone is interested in
is managing all this application
dependency or lifecycle management using
some or the other kind of a tool so
that's where these orchestration tools
have become very very popular so what
kind of features that they provide is
you'll have to just let them know what
are the kinds of tool sets that is
required what are the fault tolerance
mechanisms that it has to be adopted to
what kind of a self-healing capabilities
that application will have to need and
if at all there is any auto scaling
features that is required if at all you
can bake in all these specific
parameters into your tool your
organization tool becomes a one stop
shop for all your deployment and
configuration management needs that's
where this orchestration tools have
become a very very popular and relevant
specifically these days when people are
more and more interested in adopting
devops practices all right so having
said that about orchestration tools
let's concentrate on two of these
orchestration tools specifically for
container management docker swarm and
kubernetes many of the applications that
are written for these kind of containers
are called or kind of fall into a
category of cloud native where the
application need not know much about the
underlying infrastructure or the
platform where these applications are
running so these two along with apache
missiles there are many other container
management systems but i'm going to pick
docker swarm and kubernetes for
comparing the features that is provided
by these two frameworks for the sake of
comparison i picked up docker swarm and
kubuntes just because of the reason that
both of them operate in the space of
container management they do something
very very similar to containers that's
the similarity that exists between these
two orchestration tools however there's
a big difference that exists when it
comes to the types of containers that
both of them cater to and also the
capacity of workloads they can be used
for docker swamp is a cluster management
solution that is provided by docker
container docker is one of the very very
popular containers of recent times and
in case you have your applications that
is totally powered by only docker
containers if you have a need where you
want to run a cluster of servers which
are running only docker containers
docker swarm should be your choice for
your orchestration tool kubernetes on
the other hand can cater to any other
types of containers other than docker
and including docker as well so in case
you have your applications which have
got docker in them which have got rkt in
them which they have got alex in them or
any other type of container kubernetes
should be your choice of orchestration
too a docker swarm can manage up to 40
50 or 60 max
nodes so in case your application is
totally written in docker containers and
the load or the expected cluster size is
about 50 60 nodes docker swarm should be
your choice of orchestration tool on the
other hand kubernetes is something that
was open sourced by google and the kind
of the scale of operations that
kubernetes can cater to is google scale
so if in case your applications are more
than a thousand nodes that is where
kubernetes comes into play that's the
big difference that exists between
docker swarm and communities putting
those differences aside let me compare
docker swarm and kubernetes based upon
other features which are similar in
nature the first and important feature
that kubernetes provides is something
called as auto scaling if at all the
load on your cluster is too high and
your application is experiencing more
load so kubernetes can add new nodes to
your cluster of course you'll have to
configure kubernetes in order to have
those capabilities where it can spin up
new vms or new nodes if at all you do
that configuration correctly kubernetes
has got the capacity or it has got the
feature where it can bring up a new node
and add it to the cluster on the fly
based upon the load that exists at that
moment on similar lines if at all the
load is not too high it can identify a
few of those nodes which have got less
number of
replicas or less number of application
containers running on it it can move
them to some other node and also scale
down by deleting few nodes from your
cluster so that is the powerfulness of
auto scaling which is provided by
kubernetes and this unfortunately does
not exist in docker swarm the other
feature of load balancing specifically
application node balancing so docker
swarm gives you an application level
auto load balancing however kubernetes
gives you the flexibility of manually
configuring any other type of load
balancer of your choice for application
load balancing installation as i
mentioned earlier docker swarm is a
loose cluster of containers which are
running on nodes it is very easy to spin
up a new node and then connect them to a
swarm and this can be done in a very
very loosely coupled way where you can
create swarms of your choice notes are
allowed to connect to swarms and quit or
leave the swamps on the fly so in and
all the installation is pretty easy and
fast kubernetes on the other hand the
configuration of kubernetes the way to
spin up a big cluster specifying the
size of the node how many masternodes
how many config planes that you want how
many nodes that you want it's a pretty
tough thing to bring up a kubernetes
scalability kubernetes strength is very
very strong they are very tightly
coupled and even they have the
capability where on the cluster size
things or the nodes can be increased on
the fly based upon the requirement on a
darker swarm the cluster strength is
weak as compared to cobra days worker
notes can be added to a swarm worker
notes can be asked to leave us form or
can be taken out of a swarm based upon
the requirement so this is kind of a
loosely coupled architecture for docker
swarm while cuban is the cluster is very
tightly coupled since docker swarm runs
only docker containers containers find
it very easy to share data and lot of
other things with each other because
they all have the same signature they
are all from the same family so it's
very easy for them to share not just
volumes but a lot of other things
however for kubernetes since it manages
containers of different types if your
application has to share some data
across different containers there's a
little bit of a complexity in how you
would want your containers to share data
also when it comes to kubernetes
kubernetes groups containers in
something called as pods while a pod can
have either one container that's the
preferred choice or multiple containers
and the idea of pod is like each part
can run in any other node it's not
guaranteed that you would want to have
two or three parts to be running on the
same node that makes data sharing a
little bit of a different thing compared
to docker's form gui so there's not a
good enough ui tool in docker's form at
least the ce addition of it which will
allow you to get to know what is running
on your containers what is the size of
the containers what is the volume of the
containers and all that stuff there are
some free and open source tools like
proteiner which gives you a good
visibility into your running docker
containers however there's nothing at a
swarm level that is provided by docker
kubernetes gives you an out of the box
dashboard which is easy to configure and
set up you can also club it with some
metrics services and you can also get
information about the size of the
cluster that is running what is the load
on the notes and stuff like that all
this across your cluster in a very
beautiful dashboard perspective so that
way um this is little bit of a good ui
for kubernetes while for docker's form
there isn't anything that is provided
out of the box let me spend some time in
explaining a little bit about the
kubernetes architecture what comprises
of the kubernetes cluster what resides
in a master or a control plane and what
resides in a worker node this is a very
high level depiction of a kubernetes
cluster so this is the master node which
has got something called as a cluster
store a controller a scheduler component
and an api server and these are the
bunch of nodes that are connected or
administered by the master node the
master node can be 1 3 5 typically an
odd number this is as per the typical
cluster management thing where you would
need the master nodes to be in odd
numbers so that whenever there's any
contention in terms of what needs to be
deployed where or where to give the job
to whom and stuff like that all the
masters would cast their vote and they
would decide on the outcome so that's
the master node and there are a bunch of
nodes which can be connected and
administered by the master node cuba ctl
or the command from using which anybody
can assign some workloads to the cluster
can also be run either on the same node
or on a separate node so cubectl is the
command line tool that we will be
installing and using in order to fire up
our commands to our cluster so if at all
i have to put up a job on our cluster if
i have to give out any specific commands
to my cluster all this is done using
cuba ctl there's a bunch of rest apis
which is used by cuba ctl and cubectl
will talk to the api server and fire up
the commands specific to my cluster what
runs in the master node master node
without saying it's the most important
component of any of the cluster if at
all you're running um cluster with only
one master node if your master node goes
down there's no other way that you know
you can or any user can talk to the
different nodes in the cluster so master
node is the most vital component
responsible for the complete kubernetes
cluster there's always one node that
should be running as a master node
that's the bare minimum requirement for
your cluster so what are the other
components in the master node the most
important one is called etcd so this is
nothing but a data store a value of key
value pair which is stored which
contains all information about your
cluster so all the configuration details
which
node is up which worker node is down all
this information is stored in the
cluster store so all the managers would
access this cluster store before they go
ahead and decide any other work item or
anything else that has to be done
specific to your cluster what's in the
controller as the name says controller
is something it's like a daemon server
that is running in a continuous loop all
the time it is responsible for
controlling the set of replicas the kind
of
workloads that is running based upon the
configuration that the user has set in
so if at all if you are aware of
something called as replication
controllers endpoint controllers
namespace controllers all these
controllers are managed by the
controller component if any user asks
for some three replicas of a particular
port or a service to be running and if
at all any of the nodes goes down or the
part goes down for whatever reason the
controller is the one who wakes up and
assigns this particular job or the part
to some other available node by looking
up for the details using in the cluster
store that's the importance of the
control manager or the controller the
scheduler the scheduler assigns the
tasks based upon whoever is asked for
any job to be scheduled based upon a
time frame or based upon some criteria
it also tracks the working load as to
what what exactly is the load who is
running what and in the cluster and
places the workload on whoever is the
available resource at that time all
right epa server this is one other
important component in in our kubernetes
cluster where how would the end user
deploy or give out any sort of a
workload onto your cluster all the
requests come to the api server so this
is an entry point for all your requests
that come into your cluster anybody
wants to deploy something anybody want
to scale up a controller anybody who
wants to bring down a few services
anybody wants to put in a service all
this will have to come in as a part of a
rest api endpoint and api server is the
enter point in case you don't want uh
you know somebody to access your cluster
in case you want only specific people or
a specific users to be running some
specific workloads you can set all those
role-based access control for this apa
server so this is the entry point for
anyone who wants to submit any job to
your cluster so that's a quick overview
about the masternode what what are the
important components of a master node
now let's go over to what runs in a
worker or a slave node as i mentioned
earlier slave nodes are something where
the job that is submitted to your
cluster is eventually run as a board as
a service as a container so in
kubernetes world there is something
called as a pod a pod is nothing but a
combination of a container it is a
wrapper around your running containers
so slave nodes are the worker nodes
typically run these parts so that is
where the whole workload typically gets
run but there are a bunch of other
components in the in the node which also
manages what runs in the pod who has to
have access to the pod what is the state
of the pod is it in a running state is
it going down for some reason and all
the stuff so let's quickly go over those
components that is there in the slave
node the most important component in my
opinion that should be on the on the
node should be the container runtime as
i mentioned earlier kubernetes can run
any different types of containers not
just docker so in case you want to have
a node which wants to have docker
running on it rkt running or lkc running
on it or any other container environment
that is running on it you have to ensure
that the specific container runtime
environment is available on that
specific node so that whenever a job is
submitted description of what needs to
be run as a part of the pod what should
be the image with it should be powered
and what kind of a container to spin up
so that's what you know when the job is
finally assigned to this particular node
it would definitely need a container
runtime to be up and running so that
exists only if at all the container
runtime is installed and running on your
kubernetes worker node okay now that we
know what our kubernetes node can run
how would somebody assign a job to our
node that is using something called as a
cubelet as the name says cubelet or
cubelet is a small subset which talks to
the cube api server so any node which
has to run any kind of a pod all these
instructions are passed around by the
qbps server to the cube line and cubelet
is capable of processing whatever job
that is assigned to it and ensuring that
so many parts and so many services are
spun up based upon the requirement the
last component that exists in the worker
node is the cube proxy or kubernetes
proxy this plays a very very important
role acting as a load balancer and a
network proxy so what typically happens
is whenever the pods are running in
nodes the parts can be typically running
in any node there is no um
affinity towards any node on which these
parts are running because pods or
containers are something called as
ephemeral they can run anywhere so how
would somebody reach out to these
applications that is running in some pod
which is running in one container now
and running in probably another
container another node altogether
tomorrow so that is where your
kubernetes proxy contains a picture and
this component will ensure that any
container that is spun up or any part
that is spun up it keeps track of all
these parts and kind of connects the end
points or acts like a dns server so that
it knows when somebody is trying to
reach out to this particular service
which is the part on which the service
is typically running so that plays a
very very important role by acting as a
load balancer and a network proxy now
that at a very high level we know what
are all the components that make up of
our kubernetes cluster let's go ahead
and create a small cluster we'll spin up
this cluster on aws platform finally we
get to the demo section of my tutorial
now that you guys are aware as to what
is kubernetes what is the use of
kubernetes you also know at a very very
high level what are the components of a
cluster what is a master node or a
control plane what are the components of
a master node and what should be
existing in a worker node you're
probably thinking that it's maybe pretty
hard to kind of set this up so let me
demystify that by running you with a
quick demo of how to set up a simple
pre-node kubernetes cluster using a tool
called cops and i will be doing this
whole setup on my aws cloud okay so what
is cops cops is nothing but a simple
tool this is an admin tool that allows
you to bring up production grade
kubernetes environments as i said
setting up a kubernetes cluster on a
bare metal is little challenging so that
is why i would use something called as a
corpse and i will use this on my cluster
which i'll spin up on my aws instance so
i have an aws account and what i will do
first is i will first spin up an ec2
server i will power this with one of the
linux amis and i will install cops on it
now this will be my starting point from
where i'm going to trigger running up a
big cluster in our case i'll try to keep
it little small i don't want too many
nodes in my cluster i'm going to have
one master node and two worker nodes
this whole operation would be done
programmatically by installing this cops
admin tool so as you may know aws is
little hard for me to programmatically
run other components or rather bring up
servers it's not pretty simple so what i
would do is i will create an iam role
which will attach to my s2 server so
that my ec2 server gets powered with all
the required role so that it can go
ahead and spin up cluster based upon my
configuration that i'm going to specify
all right so once i have my cluster set
up i will also install cubicctl which uh
you would probably know by now is
nothing but a command line utility using
which i can kind of connect to my
cluster give out some jobs put some
parts and stuff like that so i will use
cuba ctl i will also have a pair of ssh
keys so that from this machine i would
be able to successfully get onto the
master node and submit jobs on my behalf
so let me begin by first logging into my
aws account all the steps that i will be
following to bring up my aws cluster
kubernetes cluster will be documented
and i'll be sharing you this document in
a github repository so that in case
anybody wants to try you'll be more than
happy to find all the required
instructions in one place okay now the
first thing that i would need is to
launch an aws ec2 instance now this is
an instance where i'm going to install
cops and i will use it as a base server
from where i'm going to fire some
commands which will bring up my
kubernetes cluster so let me log into my
aws account and um let me stick to one
particular region and let me bring up
some one ec2 instance all right so let
me launch my instance let me choose
doesn't matter in the ways but in case
you want to try it on your free tire i
would recommend choose free tire only
and choose an ami of your choice let me
choose
this instance i will make it t2 micro
that is good for me configuration
instance details all right i don't want
to change anything here that looks good
maybe i will change this 30 gig that's
good for me let me add a tag to my
instance i will name this as my cops
server all right i would need a bunch of
ports to be opened up so what i will do
is i will create a new security group
called open to
the word i would not recommend that you
do this since i don't want to it will
take a long time for me to specifically
uh to pick and choose um the ports that
has to be open for running my cluster i
don't want to do that i will open up all
the http and https ports so that it's
quicker so i will say all tcp i would
say from anywhere just to be on the
safer side also open http and https and
i will make this anywhere and anywhere
this is good for me i will say review
and launch all right so i chose a t2
micro instance just for the sake of
easiness i've opened up all the ports
and um the instant details are you've
seen what is that i've chosen all right
now important part is like i would need
a key pair i need to create a new
keyboard i will call this as simply
learn
keys i will download this
keypair and then i will launch the
instance it will take some time for my
ec2 instance to come up in the meanwhile
what i'll do is i will convert i have
this pen file which is the pair of keys
the ssh keys with which i need to log
into my ec2 instance so i'll need to
convert this because i'm trying to
connect from my windows box i would need
to convert this into a ppk file so i
have puttygen i'm going to load my set
of keys here and convert that key into a
ppk key all right open all right i would
say save hang on save private key yes i
would say simply learn or simply learn
private private key and save this here
and that that's all so this is my public
key which is the pem file and this is my
apk or my private key now using the
private key i will log into my ec2
instance okay now my ec2 instance is up
and running it is running in this ohio
region and this is the ip address of my
public impedance of my machine so let me
connect to it so i use a moba x term
which is nothing but an ssh emulator you
can use putty or any of these sessions
which allow you to do an ssh this is my
ip address of my machine and uh since
i've spun up an amazon ami the user this
is the default user i would need to
specify the private keys for my session
and this is the private key for my
session say okay i am in my
amazon ec2 instance so let me look at
what are the other things that i need to
do all right so as i said i just brought
up my ec2 instance but i would need my
ec2 instance to
run few things on my behalf so that it
can spin up easy to other ec2 instances
it can also talk to an s3 bucket where
i'm going to store the instant state of
my kubernetes cluster also some sort of
an auto scaling group because i want to
spin up more and more instances i also
want to have a private hosted zone using
my route 53 so i would need my ec2
instance to have all these sort of
permissions for my server so what i
would do is i will go and create a
permission a rule in the ec2 rather in
the aws im role and i will attach this
im rule to my ec2 instance all right so
let me go to my iam which is nothing but
the identity and access management i
will create a rule called as possibly
corpse role i will create a role this
role will be used by my ec2 so i'm going
to click on ec2 and say next permissions
they would need a lot of permissions uh
specific permissions to be very honest
and the permissions are all listed out
here s3 ec2 and all this stuff just to
keep it pretty simple what i would do is
i'll create a role with the
administrative access all right so i
don't want any tags i will review i'll
create a role name i will say cops fold
for ec2 alright so i'm going to create a
role which has got administrative access
rules i'm going to create a role so this
would ensure that my ec2 instance from
which i'm going to run my cluster would
have all the prerequisite permissions so
that it can go and spin up instances
talk to s3 buckets and all that stuff
all right now let us have our running
instance get powered by this role so i
will connect this role to my running
instance all right so this is my um easy
to instant that is running
action attach attach attach attach
replace im rolls so there is no rule as
of now i would want my cops roll for
easy this row that i created so i want
this new room to be assigned to my ec2
all right great now my ec2 instance
which is my cop server has got all the
required permissions so that he can
create a cluster on my behalf great now
before this let me do a sudo m update
iphone y so that any of the because this
is a newly provisioned vm i just want to
ensure that all my library system
libraries are all updated so that when i
do install cop and cube ctl and all
those things none of them will fail
because of some dependency or package
issues so i'm just running a sudo update
iphone y so that all the libraries are
updated okay looks like it is done so
let me go ahead and install cops cups is
a pretty simple installation it is
available in a particular location i
have to just copy this and ensure that i
do a curl and i install this particular
stuff all right so it is fetching uh the
cops tool it's installing for me once it
is copied down let me change the mode so
that i can execute it and then also let
me move it to my user local bin so that
it is available for me in my path okay
that's pretty much the corpse
installation let me also do one other
thing let me install something called as
cuba ctl so this is what would be you
know a tool using which i'm going to be
firing my uh commands to my kubernetes
cluster once it comes up right this is a
pretty smaller executable so keep the
ctl all right so i have cuba ctl as well
as cops installed on my ec2 server now
okay now what i'll do next is i'm going
to create an s3 bucket in aws so that
the equivalent is a cluster state is
persisted in this bucket so let me
create a simple bucket with this name s3
bucket with this name so let me go to s3
and let me create a simple bucket with
this name i will just say create a
bucket okay so the simply
learn.kubernetes is the bucket that i
created so this bucket will store all
information about my cluster let me now
go and create a dns entry or a dns zone
or aws route 53 hosted zone for my
cluster so this is required so that you
know i can give a cluster name for my
kubernetes cluster that i'm coming up so
i will create a private hosted zone and
possibility possibly i will call this as
simplylearn.net so this will be my name
of my private hosted zone in case you
already have any other public hosted
zones in your name you can always put a
route 53 hosted zone specific for your
domain name since i don't have anyone
i'm just going to create a simple
private hosted zone so let me head down
to route
53 click on any of these and you'll get
these hosted zones out here so i'm going
to create a hosted zone here i'm going
to create a hosted zone click on create
hosted zone um this would be simply
learn lot in i want to create a public
no i don't want public i want a private
hostess zone and i'm going to associate
my vpc id for this hosted zone since i'm
going to try out all my exercises in the
ohio region i will associate the vpc of
the ohio region for this all right so
this is the one that is specific to the
ohio region so i will say this one i'll
say create a hosted song great now let
me come back to my ec2 box my ec2 is all
powered with whatever it needs in order
to go out with the installation of my
cluster only a few things that i need to
take care of is that you know now that i
put a name for my cluster i also have an
uh s3 bucket that i've configured for my
cluster i will have to ensure that i
need to put in these two configurations
as a part of my cluster building
activity so i will open my
rc file and i'm going to export these
two variables if at all you remember
well these two variables are nothing but
the cluster name which is nothing but
the public uh sorry the private hosted
zone that i created and the s3 bucket
where i'm going to create or rather i'm
going to store my cluster state so let
me copy these two and open up my
bash rc file all right so i will just
add these two and copy these add export
them out as my ah variable i'm going to
save this here now let me ensure that
this gets picked up all right i've got
these two that have configured and i
also ensure that these environment
variables are set now let me create a
pair of ssh keys this is to ensure that
i can log into the box that i'm going to
be provisioning as a part of my cluster
ssh hyphen keygen i don't want to give
any parameters let it go to the home
directory with the default name and
without any passphrase alright so i
created a bunch of my keypair now i'm
all set to go ahead and run my cops now
cops will ensure that this will take
some time for the cluster to come up but
this is exactly how i would define my
corpse command how do i have copied here
so corpse create cluster the state of
the
cluster will be stored in this
particular variable which is what i have
exported out the number of node count is
two node count is the worker node count
if at all i don't specify configuration
for specifying the master or the control
pane as well if i don't specify that the
default one is one so i'm going to
create
one primary or the master node and two
uh worker nodes uh size of my master
node size of the worker nodes uh what
are the zones where i want uh this to be
created and where do i store the cluster
information and uh okay i've already
added this master count this is actually
not required but this is the command
that i'm going to fire off so that i
bring up my cluster all right that went
off uh very fast but um this actually
did not create a cluster it is just the
definition of a cluster and that's why
this came out very fast now that
everything looks good with uh whatever
configuration that i specified now let
me go ahead and create the cluster by
saying corpse update cluster iphone
iphone 8 yes now this will take some
time a good five to ten minutes for it
to because this will actually start
provisioning the servers and as i
mentioned earlier based upon my
configuration i'm gonna come up with one
master server and uh two nodes or the
worker nodes all right so this is the
command for me to validate the cluster
and i'm going to try it out first i'm
pretty sure that it will fail because
all my servers are not up yet it is
taking some time the validation
everything failed but let me try to look
at my ec2 instances and
see how many servers do i have running
as of now if you see i had only one
server that i had started which was my
cup server and automatically the other
three instances one is called not start
simply not in this these two are the
nodes and this is the master node so
these three got automatically
provisioned by the cops command that i
ran all right so this may take a while
for it to get validated a good 5 to 10
minutes so what i'll do is i'll pause
the video now and i'll come back once
the server the cluster is up and running
it's been a good uh eight to nine
minutes uh since i started my cluster so
let me validate now okay seems good so
there's a master node
minimum one max one some nodes which are
nothing but the slave nodes or the
worker nodes there are two of them due
to micro
subnet so my clusters seem to be up and
running and my cluster name is simply
learn.n so what i would want to do is
now let me just log into the master and
see if i can run some parts so let me
get back to my install installation
steps here the validation cluster is
done so let me log into my since my
cluster name is simply none dot and this
is the way to log into my box so let me
get into my box so if you see here uh
this is the host name of the machine
that i'm currently in if you see this
this is nothing but our this cop server
this is now from here i'm trying to get
into the master box all right so if you
see the ip address has changed i was in
a different box i'm in a different box
now if i see host name you'll find a
different host name so this is 153 which
is nothing but the master node yep it's
153 this is the particular host so i'm
getting into this machine now so i
started the cluster from my cop server
here it ran and brought up three nodes
so i'm actually getting into my master
node and see if i can run some parts on
it all right so let me try cuba ctl uh
get cluster info try cube ctl get nodes
all right so there are three nodes here
master node and um one master node and
two worker nodes so let me see if i have
some pods here cubicle get pods so
there's no port as of now so what i'll
try to do is let me just spin up a very
very simple part just to check if my
connections is everything is correct or
not correct i have a simple
node.js application that i've built uh
i've got a container for that this is
already pushed to the docker i've
registered is called simply learn docker
hub and the image name that i have here
is called my node app and i will use
this image to power one of my parts that
i will run so this is the way in which
i'm going to launch my pod let me show
you these commands cube ctl run the name
for my deployment that i'm going to run
hyphen iphone image and this is the
image that is going to be powering my
container so this is simply learn docker
hub forward slash my node app hyphen f1
replicas equal to i want two replicas to
be running and the port that i want to
expose this particular part is on eight
zero eight zero so let me run this as
soon as this is run it creates something
called as a deployment all right now let
me just say um i'm not really interested
in the deployment i'm interested in
checking if at all the parts are up and
running so i will say cube ctl get
all right so that was pretty fast so i
have two parts that are running here
these are two replicas because i asked
for two replicas these parts are running
so i can run cube ctl describe pod
pickup all right i can pick up any of
the pod name and see what is the pod
what is the information does it contain
from what is the image that is pulling
what is the image image name id this is
actually running my pod which is
actually spinning up a container great
so far so good so in kubernetes the pods
can are ephemeral so they can be there
at any time cannot be runtime if i need
to expose my pod outside i will have to
create a service for my pod so what i'll
do is i'll create a very very simple
service by exposing this particular
deployment before that let me check cube
cdl get deployment so there's a
deployment that is created the
deployment name is simply an app so i
will expose my deployment simply learn
app as uh yeah i'll just expose this let
me see all right i am not specifying
what type and all i don't want to get
into the complications of uh what are
the different types of exposing the
service and all that stuff so if i don't
specify anything uh it gives me
something closer cluster ip so this is
where my pod is actually exposed so let
me just check if at all this part is up
and running i'll just try a simple curl
command curl http colon this is my
cluster ip and the port is 8080 if at
all i hit this it's actually hitting my
application and giving me whatever i put
a simple
sys dot out kind of a thing where i'm
just printing um the container id of
whatever pod is serving uh being sold
out of so i'm actually hitting my
container and i'm getting this output
from the content so everything looks
good my content is up and running so let
me just go and clean it up i'll say
equip ctl uh delete deployment simply
learn app this should get rid of all the
parts that i created cube ctl get pod
all right these parts are intimidating
things let me just check cube ctl get
services there's one service i don't
want this service let me delete that
keep ctl delete service i want this all
right that sounds good so let me come
back to my host my cop server from where
i'm running so i managed to successfully
verify this part see if everything is up
and running so what i'll do is i'll just
go ahead and complete this demo by going
and
getting rid of my cluster so corpse
delete cluster hyphen f1 yes all right
so this will ensure that it will clean
up my complete cluster that i created so
i had three or four running instances if
you see that all the three are shutting
down because you know the cop server
which had cops installed on it has now
got a mandate to go ahead and
shut down and clean up the whole
instances and all those things that are
created as a part of my deployment
kubernetes versus darker but before we
jump into that i want you to hit the
subscribe button so you get notified
about new content as it gets made
available and if you hit the
notification button that notification
will then pop up on your desktop as a
video is published from simplyland in
addition if you have any questions on
the topic please post them in the
comments below we read them and we do
reply to them as often as we can so with
that said let's jump into kubernetes
versus docker so let's go through a
couple of scenarios let's do one for
kubernetes and then one for docker and
we can actually go through and
understand what the problems specific
companies have actually had and how
they're able to use the two different
tools to solve them so our first one is
with bose and bose
had a
large catalog of products that kept
growing and their infrastructure had to
change so the way that they looked at
that was actually establishing two
primary goals to be able to allow their
product groups to be able to easier more
easily catch up to the scale of their
business so after going through
a number of solutions they ended up
coming up with a solution of having
kubernetes running their iot platform as
a service inside of amazon's aws cloud
service and what you'll see with both
these products is they're very cloud
friendly but here we have
bose and kubernetes working together
with aws to be able to scale up and meet
the demands of their product catalog and
so the result is that we're able to
increase the number of non-production
deployments significantly by taking the
number of services from being large
bulky surfaces down to small micro
services being able to handle as many as
1250 and plus deployments every year an
incredible amount of time and value has
been opened through the use of
kubernetes now let's have a look at daca
and see what a similar problem that
people would have so uh the problem is
with paypal and paypal and processes
something in the region of over 200
payments per second across all of their
products and paypal doesn't just have
paypal they have braintree and venmo so
the challenge that
paypal was really being given is that
they had different architectures which
resulted in different maintenance cycles
and different deployment times and an
overall complexity from having a
decades-old architecture with paypal
through to a modern architecture with
venmo through the use of docker paper
was able to unify the application
delivery and be able to centralize the
management of all of the containers with
one existing group the net net result is
that paypal was able to migrate over 700
applications into docker enterprise
which consists of over 200 000
containers this ultimately opened up a
50 increase in availability for being
able to
add in additional time for building
testing and deploying of applications
just a huge win for paypal now let's dig
into kubernetes and docker so kubernetes
is an open source uh platform and it's
designed for being able to maintain a
large number of containers and what
you're going to find is that your
argument for kubernetes versus docker
isn't a real argument it's kubernetes
and docker working together so
kubernetes is able to manage the
infrastructure of a containerized
environment and docker is the number one
container management solution and so
with docker you're able to automate the
deployment of your applications being
able to keep them in a very lightweight
environment and being able to
create a nice consistent experience so
that your developers are working in the
same containers that are then also
pushed out to production so with docker
you're able to manage multiple
containers running on the same hardware
much more efficiently than you are with
a
vm environment the productivity around
docker is extremely high you're able to
keep your applications very isolated the
configuration for docker is really quick
and easy you can be up and running in
minutes with docker once you have it
installed and running on your
development machine or inside of your
devops environment so we look at the
deployment between the two um and the
differences kubernetes is really
designed for a combination of pods and
services in its deployment whereas with
docker it's around about deploying
services in containers uh so the the
difference um here is that kubernetes is
gonna manage the entire environment and
then and that environment consisting of
pods and inside of a pod you're gonna
have all of your containers that you're
working on and those containers that can
control the services that actually power
the applications that are being deployed
kubernetes is by default an auto scaling
solution has it turned on and is always
available whereas a docker does not and
that's not surprising because docker is
a tool for building out solutions
whereas kubernetes is about managing
your infrastructure kubernetes is going
to
run health checks on the liveness and
readiness of your entire environment so
not just one container but tens of
thousands of containers whereas docker
is going to limit the health check to
the services that it's managing within
its own containers now i'm not going to
kid you
kubernetes is quite hard to set up it's
is if of the tools that you're going to
be using in your devops environment it's
it's not an easy setup for you to use
and for
this reason you want to really take
advantage of the services within azure
and other similar cloud environments
where they actually will do the setup
for you docker in contrast is really
easy to set up you can as i mentioned
earlier you can be up and running in a
few minutes as you would expect the
fault tolerance within kubernetes is
very high and this is by design because
the architecture of kubernetes is built
on the same architecture that google
uses for managing its entire cloud
infrastructure in contrast docker has
lower fault tolerance but that's because
it's just managing the the services
within its own containers what you'll
find is that most public cloud providers
will provide support for both kubernetes
and docker here we've highlighted
microsoft azure because they were very
quick to jump on and support kubernetes
but the reality is is that today google
amazon and many other providers are
having first level support for
kubernetes has just become extremely
popular in a very very short time frame
the company's using both kubernetes and
docker is fast and every single day
there are more and more companies using
it and you should be able to look and
see whether or not you can add your own
company to this list hi guys welcome to
this video on docker interview questions
and answers
docker is a popular devops tool used to
automate the deployment of applications
in lightweight containers so that
applications can work efficiently in
different environments
docker was initially released in 2013
and since then has become the go to
solution for containerization
in this video
we have compiled the most important
docker interview questions that you
might face in a docker or devops
interview
so without further ado let's get started
so let's go through and you're going to
be asked to explain what the
architecture of docker is and docker
really is the most popular
containerization environment so docker
uses a client server architecture and
the docker client is a service which
runs in a command line and and then the
docker daemon which is run as a rest api
within the command line will accept the
requests and interacts with the
operating system in order to build the
docker images and run the docker
containers and then the docker image is
a template of instructions which is used
to create containers the docker
container is an executable package of
applications and its dependencies
together and then finally the docker
registry is a service to host and
distribute docker images among other
users so you'll also be asked to provide
what are the advantages of docker over
virtual machine and and this is
something that comes up very
consistently in fact um you may want to
even extend it as having what are the
differences between having a dedicated
machine a virtual machine and a docker
or docker-like environment and really
the the arguments for docker are just
absolutely fantastic you know first of
all docker does contain and occupy
docket containers occupy significantly
less space than a virtual machine or a
dedicated machine the boot up time on
docker is significantly faster than a vm
containers have a much better
performance as they are hosted in a
single docker image docker is highly
efficient and very easy to scale
particularly when you start working with
kubernetes easily portable across
multiple platforms and then finally for
space allocation uh docker data volumes
can be shared and reused among multiple
containers the argument against virtual
machines is significant and particularly
if you're going into an older
environment where a company is still
using actual dedicated hardware and
haven't moved to a cloud or cloud-like
environment your arguments for docker
are going to be very very persuasive be
very clear on what the advantages are
for docker over a virtual machine
because you want to be able to
succinctly share them with your team and
this is something that's important when
you're going through the interview
process but also equally important
particularly if you're working with a
company that's transitioning or going
through a digital transformation where
they aren't used to working with the
tools like docker you need to be able to
effectively share with that team what
the benefits are so how do we share
docker containers with different nodes
and in this instance what you want to be
able to do is leverage the power of
docker swarm so docker swarm is a tool
which allows the it administrators and
developers to create and manage clusters
of swarm nodes within the darker
platform and there are two elements to
the node there's the manager node and
then there's the the worker node the
manager node as you'd assume manages the
entire infrastructure and the working
node is actually the work of the agent
as it gets executed
so what are the commands to create a
docker swarm and so here we have an
example of what a manager node would
look like and once you've created a
swarm on your manager node you can now
add worker nodes to that swarm and again
when you're stepping through this
process be very precise in the execution
part that needs to be taken to be able
to effectively create a swarm so start
with the manager node and then you
create a worker node and then finally
when a node is initialized as a manager
node it can immediately create a token
and that token is used for the worker
nodes and associating the ip address
with the worker nodes question 17 how to
run multiple containers using a single
service it is possible to run multiple
containers a single service by using
docker compose and docker compose will
actually run each of the services in
isolation so that they can interact with
each other the language used to write
out the composed files that allow you to
run the service is called yaml and yamos
stands for yet another markup language
so what is the use of a docker file so a
dockerfile actually is used for creating
docker images using the build command so
let's go through and show on the screen
what that would look like and this would
be an opportunity where if you're
actually in a technical interview you
could potentially even ask hey can i
draw on a whiteboard and show you what
the architecture for using the build
command would look like and what the
process would look like um again when
you're going through an interview
process as someone who interviews a lot
of people one of the things i really
like is when an interview candidate does
something that's slightly different and
in this instance this is a great example
of where you can stand up to the
whiteboard and actually show what can
actually be done through actually
creating images on the whiteboard very
quickly little square boxes where you
can actually show the flow for creating
a build environment as an architect this
should be something that you are
comfortable doing and by doing it in the
interview and suddenly you want to ask
permission before you actually do it but
doing this in the interview really helps
demonstrate your comfortable feelings of
working with these kind of architecture
drawings so back to the question of
creating a docker file so we go through
and we have a docker file that actually
then goes ahead and creates the docker
image which then in turns creates the
docker container and then we are able to
push that out up to a docker hub and
then share that docker hub with
everybody else as part of the docker
registry with the whole network so what
are the differences between docker image
and docker containers so let's go
through the docker image so the docker
images are templates of a docker
container an image is built using a
docker file and it stores that docker
file in a docker repository or a docker
hub and you can use docker hub as an
example and the image layer is a read
only file system the docker container is
a collection of the runtime instances of
a docker image and the containers are
created using docker images and they are
stored in the docker daemon and every
container is a layer is a read write
file system so you can't replace the
information you can only append to it
so while you can actually use yamo or
our writing your so a question you can
be asked is instead of yammer what can
be an alternate file to build docker
compose so yaml is the one that is the
default but you can also use json so if
you are comfortable working with jason
and my that is something that you should
be uh get comfortable with is you want
to be able to use that to name your
files and as a frame reference json is a
logical way of being able to do value
paired matching using a javascript like
syntax
so you're going to be asked to how to
create a docker container so let's go
through what that would look and we'll
break it down task by task so the task
is going to be create a my mysql docker
container so to do that you want to be
able to build a docker image or pull
from an existing docker image from a
docker repository or hub and then you
want to be able to then use docker to
create a new container which has my
sequel from the existing docker image
simultaneously the layer of read write
file system is also created on top of
that image and below at the bottom of
the screen we have what the commands
lines look for that so what is the
difference between a registry and a
repository so let's go through that so
for the docker registry and repository
for the registry we have a docker
registry is an open source server-side
service used for hosting and
distributing docket images whereas in
contrast for repositories a collection
of multiple versions of a docker image
in a registry a user can distinguish
between docker images with their tag
names and then finally on the registry
docker also has its own default retreat
called docker harb for the repository it
is a collection of multiple versions of
docker images it is stored in a docker
registry and it has two types a public
and private registry so you can actually
create your own enterprise registry so
you're gonna be asked you know what are
the cloud platforms that uh support
docker really you know list them all and
we have listed here amazon web services
microsoft azure google cloud rackspace
but you could add in their ibm bluemix
could put in red hat really any of the
cloud service providers out there today
do support docker it's just become an
industry standard so what is the purpose
of expose and publish commands in docker
so if we go through expose is an
instruction used in docker file whereas
publish is used in docker run command
for expose it is used to expose ports
within a docker network whereas with
publish it can be used outside of a
docker environment for expose it is a
documenting instruction used at the time
of building an image and running a
container whereas with published is used
as to map a host port to a running
container port for expose is the command
used in docker whereas for publish we
use the command-p for when we're doing
our command line used in docker and
examples of these are expose 8080 or
with docker we would put in or for
publish we'd do the example docker run
dash d dash p and then 0.0.0.80
a colon80 as our command line hello and
welcome to kubernetes interview
questions now the great thing about
being a kubernetes expert is that there
is a growing market for people wanting
to hire you and you're going to get
asked a lot of questions in this video
we're going to take you through the 13
most common questions that you are
likely to be asked in a kubernetes
interview as always if you like this
video we have the subscribe button below
and then the like button that will
notify you of all new videos as they get
submitted also if you have any questions
feel free to post those into the
questions below and we'll get back to
you with answers we try and answer as
many questions as possible so without
any more hesitation let's jump into some
of the popular interview questions that
you're going to get asked we're going to
break up the interview questions into
three categories it's gonna be beginner
intermediate and advanced um the
beginner questions are really gonna
cover about three quarters of the
questions that we're going to ask here
and then the intermediate and advanced
will finalize out the we'll finish out
the final quarter and and the reason is
is that quite typically
most interviews um you'll be asked you
know intermediate to beginner level
questions mainly beginner level
questions just so you can demonstrate
your understanding of kubernetes and
then there's always one advanced
question that gets thrown out just to
make sure that you really do know what
you're talking about and you've done at
least one or two kubernetes environment
uh setups to be able to validate your
experience so let's kind of jump into
that first section which is you know why
is kubernetes widely used and your
answer to this really comes into the
fact that kubernetes um is widely used
because of three distinct areas one is
that uh kubernetes is an open source
platform that is readily available for
the management containers and allows you
to manage the deployment scaling and
management of those containers and so
the first area is that it allows you for
easy deployment of your containers the
ability to scale effectively within
kubernetes not just vertically but
horizontally for your containers and
then finally the kubernetes environment
itself was really designed to make it
easy to manage containers um in small
parts other key areas of why kubernetes
is popular is that kubernetes is the
single largest open source project out
there since its launch in 2014 is just
grown in leaps and bounds um around that
project there is just a huge community
both an online and physical community
there are just a large number of online
groups that are supporting kubernetes
and allow you to get fast access to
information but in addition to that
there are also a lot of
local meetup groups that cover
specifically kubernetes whether as part
of a devops group or as part of a
dedicated kubernetes group the actual
environment itself is a really robust
way of being able to manage your
containers containers are becoming the
most popular way of being able to deploy
cloud-based applications kubernetes is
an effective and persistent storage
environment so kubernetes is also able
to effectively manage persistent storage
whether it's local storage as a ssd
drive or a local hard drive or whether
it's cloud-based storage and because of
the way that kubernetes architecture
it's really designed for the cloud from
the ground up so it's a great way to get
started in building out your cloud
solutions and then finally the actual
tools within kubernetes are designed to
help and manage the health and
monitoring of the environment itself so
what is google container engine so the
google container engine is another open
source solution but it's designed for
managing the docker containers and
clusters and so kubernetes is a
container management solution and docker
is the most popular container solution
out there and this is just a way of
being able to bring the two effectively
with into each other so that you can
have docker containers manage the
application and then kubernetes manage
the scale of your applications as
they're vertically and horizontally
scaled across your network so what is
the difference between kubernetes and
docker and this is important because
kubernetes and docker are often dropped
in the same sentence and there's a lot
of people that get confused between the
two so fundamentally kubernetes is about
taking pods which contain containers
which have applications in and deploying
them at scale across a cloud network
docker is the container solution itself
so the actual application itself is put
into the docker container because of
this difference kubernetes is designed
for auto scaling it's highly available
whereas docker simply isn't because it
doesn't have to worry about that within
the container itself the kubernetes
environment will check for liveness and
readiness of the health of the entire
infrastructure whereas with docker it's
just really going to check the services
that are coming in and out of the actual
application itself within the container
kubernetes is complicated to set up it
really is just simply complicated setup
and what you'll find is a lot of cloud
services will actually do the setup for
you whereas docker is very easy to set
up the as you would expect with the
tolerance ratio there is high fault
tolerance with kubernetes whereas with
docker is low fault tolerance again this
is fundamental in the two different
types of strategy that kubernetes and
docker have they're both connected
tightly with each other but they both do
different things so what are the notable
features of kubernetes um one is the
ability to do container balance
kubernetes always knows where to place a
container within its entire network
within the pods and with its
infrastructure the services are managed
for security network and storage uh it
is self-monitoring so it goes in and is
able to check its own nodes for health
and the containers within the nodes so
it makes sure that the applications are
always running effectively you can do
the scaling effectively both vertically
and horizontally within kubernetes the
solution is open source so there's no
actual fee for the actual kubernetes
service itself and kubernetes allows for
storage orchestration what does it mean
by storage orchestration now storage
orchestration is that you're able to
access and share either local storage
such as a hard drive or ssd drive or a
cloud-based drive and my preference is
always to go with cloud-based drive
because then you're really positioning
your solution to be a true cloud-based
application so what are the main
advantages of kubernetes uh where you
get automatic rollback for changes that
go wrong the a you're able to automate a
lot of the processes that would have
been manual processes previously
you're able to scale the resources both
vertically and horizontally easily and
quickly and then the these three areas
the rollback automating role bank
automating services and being able to
scale indirectly allows you to save
money by reducing the amount of time of
people working on your operations
environment so let's break out the
architecture of kubernetes so you're
going to be explaining us to explain
how is kubernetes architecture
structured and there are three key areas
there's the application layer there's
kubernetes layer and then there's the
infrastructure layer we're going to
start off with the infrastructure layer
and so the infrastructure layer is our
base layer and this is where all your
where you make your clusters for your
collections of storage and networking
resources within kubernetes and this is
where you would um have if your
databases are your data stored locally
on a hard drive or in the cloud your
core network and the vms that you'll be
building out your infrastructure on
these allow you to group many machines
together into a single unit so that
you're able to scale up and down very
easily to meet customer demand so let's
talk about the middle layer which is the
kubernetes layer now so if we're looking
at our architecture for our kubernetes
layers really broken down for the the
core operating system the docker
container environment and the kubernetes
code itself and this is where you're
able to take machines and pull them
together as a cluster so that they work
within that kubernetes system you have a
master controller uh within the
kubernetes that actually then will go
ahead and manage the scheduler control
manager the api server and then you'll
be able to cluster all of these
kubernetes together so that they're all
working and processing as one single
unit and then finally let's look at the
application layer where you actually
have your apps and so the application
layer where you have your pool and your
services you know kubernetes will use
api to connect in and out of this layer
it's to run your applications within
containers and you use instructions that
are written in yaml or json to actually
set up those containers and you actually
have the environment running on a plan
that examines these instructions so it
keeps the entire environment healthy api
ecosystem is used to interact with the
cluster it's so you don't have to uh do
that by yourself so make sure that
you're referencing that the apis are
secured and connecting in and out of the
system and so you have your scheduling
control manager actually from the
kubernetes environment doing the hard
work and then the workers themselves
execute the commands that are coming
from kubernetes so you will be asked to
kind of dig into some of the key areas
such as explaining the master node and
listing its components so the master
node is comprised of four key components
there's the uh cluster store the
controller manager uh the scheduler and
the api server so four key components
remember four fingers four components
and then you're going to be asked to
maybe dig deeper into what is a cluster
within kubernetes and so a customer is
really a combination of resources such
as machines that into a single node and
then
those nodes are pulled together and work
as a single cluster as a whole
kubernetes will work with that whole
cluster and then once you're actually
working with that whole cluster uh if a
node fails or needs to be removed
kubernetes is able to do that quickly
and effectively so let's talk a little
bit about what are the different types
of controllers in kubernetes and there
are five types of control manager uh you
have the node controller the service
account the token controller the
endpoint controller and the replication
controller and so the node controller
controls and handles the node in the
system the service account enables
access controls in the system the token
controller cleans up any tokens for
non-existent service accounts the
endpoint controller joins services in
pods to the endpoint objects and the
replication controller manages the port
lifecycle so what is the role of the
cloud controller manager within this
environment and so the role the cloud
control manager is really to help manage
persistent storage and so persistent
storage is storage that's either local
storage to the physical machine such as
an ssd or hard drive or cloud-based
storage and this allows the storage to
be shared across the entire network what
is the role of the cube api server and
the cube scheduler so the cube api
server responsible for the establishment
communication between the kubernetes
nodes and the master components and and
it does this through the through apis
the apis themselves are all commands
that are rest based commands and it
implements an interface which means
different tools and libraries can
communicate effectively with each other
so what is the role of the cube api
server and the cube scheduler so the
cube's capture actually does the
distribution of work across the entire
infrastructure so the actual
yaml scripts that you've written are
executed appropriately at the right time
so you're going to be asked to explain
persistent volumes in kubernetes so a
persistent volume is just a place where
you can store data again this can be
local data as in a hard drive local to
the physical machine or it can be
cloud-based data so what is a cubelet
and a cube proxy so a cube light is a
service responsible for conveying
information to and from the control plan
itself the process and the q proxy
itself is responsible for maintaining
the work and the standards within the
node server in addition every node in
the cluster runs a simple network proxy
and cue proxy routes requests to the
correct container in that node in
addition you'll have some basic and
primitive load balancing and management
of the node from the proxy itself and
there's additional layers of management
that get done outside of the proxy but
the proxy is also there to help do some
localized load management so what is
cube ctl so cube ctl is your command
line or terminal window interface that
allows you to execute commands and later
uh in this video we'll actually go
through some of those commands etcd is
the store that configures the details
and essential values such as key value
pairs that are distributed across your
entire network it also manages the
network rules and the post-forwarding of
activity so what are the disadvantages
of kubernetes well the first is it's
really hard to install and configure and
this is why azure and many cloud
services such as google cloud will
actually do the installation and
configuration of kubernetes for you it
does take a long time to get up and
running with kubernetes not so much for
the actual software but your own
experience of being able to use
kubernetes it is not simple to manage
the service you actually have to have a
lot of experience and this is why people
get paid a lot for kubernetes skills
it's a difficult environment to get up
and running and be effective in that
management again kubernetes is just not
an easy platform to learn it takes a lot
of time and effort and
one of the disadvantages is that while
kubernetes itself is free because it is
an open source project getting the
people who are skilled you to using
kubernetes is expensive all right so
those were kind of the introductory
questions that you can expect to be
asked in your interview the next set of
questions are really going to be on an
intermediate and advanced level and
these are the questions that will be
thrown out you know you see these as
being the trick questions which are
really there to test that you have the
skill set to be able to implement and
manage kubernetes within a company so
what happens if a master node fails what
happens if a worker nerve fails how
would kubernetes manage that well
kubernetes is really designed for this
kind of scenario and so you can actually
look at it and the response would be is
that the part itself does not get
affected and kubernetes will actually
respond and fix the uh the failed node
whether it is needs to be repaired
whether it needs to be restarted or
needs to be replaced so what is a
service role in kubernetes so a service
role is an abstraction for all the pods
it provides a virtual ip address that
allows clients to connect to containers
running in the pods using that virtual
ip address and the command that you
would use to get that we would use some
of these uh cube ctl commands it's quite
a simple one it's cube ctl get services
and you get a full list then of all the
services that are available so how do i
do a rollback in deployment and so
there's a couple of ways you can do the
rollback and the first is if you want to
see the rollout history deployment you
would write cubectl rollout history
deployment and then in square brackets
deployment if you want to just restore
to the previous rollout the command
would be cube ctl roll out undo
deployment and then in square brackets
deployment and that would take you back
to the previous deployment so what is an
ingress controller so an ingress
controller really is a pod that manages
that inbound traffic and a prominent
feature of that traffic is that it is
secured with an ssl termination and so
what we're going to do to now address
some of the key ways in which you can
provide api securities on kubernetes and
we have eight of those so the first four
are
implementing tl tls for your security
the second would be api authentication
the third is to make the cubeless
protection the cubeless
protected via authorization
mode equals webhook command the fourth
is to monitor rbac failures the fifth is
to remove those default service account
permissions
six would be to filter egress to cloud
api metadata apis the seventh is to use
pod security policy to restrict
container policies and protect the node
and the eighth and final is to keep the
cube at the latest version all right
let's go into some of the more advanced
commands and so the advanced questions
you're going to get are all going to be
commands that you're going to be asked
to write now my advice for you for these
questions is to make sure that you have
some of these basic commands
memorized um they don't have to be
perfect when you're in the interview um
environment but it's good to be able to
get up to a whiteboard and actually
write out what these commands are just
so you can actually demonstrate that you
know what the commands are the
interviewer isn't gonna ask you
questions on how would you
apply kubernetes to the company that
you're being hired for because you
simply don't have that knowledge but
they do want to be able to see clearly
that you understand the commands and
terminal window instructions that will
be able to demonstrate how you would
actually go in and access some of that
information so one of the first
questions you might be asked is how do
you package kubernetes applications and
so you would use the package manager
within kubernetes to be able to manage
to pl and configure and deploy
applications uh into your cluster and so
here we have the uh the helm command
that you would use so what are in it
containers and uh any container gets
executed before any other containers can
run on the pod and so you want to be
able to illustrate what the init
instructions would look like and here we
have an example and i would again use
this example and maybe memorize it for
when you have this question come up in
your interview so what is the difference
between a config map and a secret and
these are more uh fundamentals so a
config map just has the instructions
that are clearly available in plain text
on what the
cube is supposed to do whereas uh the
secrets are actually encrypted and these
are
like uh passwords and other sensitive
data that you don't want to have um
easily available these are encrypted
information have to be decrypted to
access the content so if a node is
tainted is there a way to schedule the
pods to that node and the the answer is
no there isn't and so what you have to
do then is schedule the pod to be
fixed and so that schedule the pod to
fix the tainted node to allow for
tolerations to that and we have here the
example code that you would use to do
that so how do you deploy a feature with
zero downtime in kubernetes well
kubernetes is designed to be able to
roll out
applications with zero downtime and here
we have four examples using the rolling
update as a strategy for zero downtime
deployments in kubernetes again memorize
one of these so you can actually
illustrate how you use roll out to be
able to deploy a zero downtime solution
so how do you monitor a pod that is
always running and so to do that you
would use the liveness probe to check um
the health of the application within the
pod and see whether or not
there are any failures or whether or not
the part itself needs to be restarted so
how do you drain traffic from pod during
a maintenance so again
this is a simple command for you to
remember but to be able to drain an
application so that it's easy for you to
be able to do maintenance on the
application you would use the cube ctl
grain and then in square brackets the
node name and that would then uh
temporarily drain
that
particular part so you can actually do
maintenance on it what you have to then
and this would probably give you bonus
points with your in an interview is then
reference the uncorden command so that
you can uncordon the actual uh node
itself so that the part itself can come
back up into life and work as a fully
functioning solution so to be able to
tie surfaces to a partner to a set of
parts you can apply labels to the actual
parts themselves and then use the labels
as selectors to be able to glue surfaces
to that pod and again we have here an
example of how you'd actually do that
and again this is one of those where you
can probably won't be asked to write
this out but it'd be good to have this
memorized how would you get all pods on
a node and so the following command will
actually go ahead and bring all the pods
into a kubernetes cluster um this is
quite lengthy and you know maybe you
want to like talk to how this would be
done but we have the instructions on how
to do that right here the important part
is to make sure that you uh when you're
talking about the node name that you
reference to whoever you're interviewing
that you would what you would switch out
to
reference the actual nodes that you're
trying to pull together into the
kubernetes cluster so how do parts mount
nfs volumes and so in these examples
here we actually define the nfs server
and then the pod and how you'd actually
mount two together again what you want
to be able to do is illustrate why you
would use yaml and
how you'd actually then point to
specific ip addresses within your
kubernetes environment within either the
production or test environments to be
able to illustrate how you would mount
up those nfs volumes and with that we
have come to an end of this video on
docker fill course i hope it was
informative and exciting if you have any
questions about the topics covered in
this video please ask away in the
comment section below our team will help
you to solve all your queries thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you